welcome to this comprehensive go
programming course for beginners
throughout this course you'll learn key
Concepts and techniques to write
performant idiomatic go code you will be
guided by the expertise of Lane Wagner
and Alan lyers who combined have over 18
years of coding experience alongside
mastering topics such as variables
function loops and more you'll also have
the opportunity to apply your newfound
skills in seven real world projects
ranging from building an RSS aggregator
to implementing authentication with API
keys so get ready to unlock the
incredible potential of go go has been
exploding in popularity recently it
feels like all the most modern tech
companies are using go to build scalable
back-end infrastructure it actually
makes a lot of sense goes fast
lightweight has an amazing developer
experience and is actually super easy to
learn stick around and in just a few
minutes I'll explain the rest of the
reason why go could be a game changer
for your coding career at this point
I'll just introduce myself really
quickly I'm Lane the founder of boot.dev
and I've been writing go for a little
over seven years and I've been building
software for about 10. I've actually
spent over two years designing this go
course and I've taught thousands of
students with this material the feedback
from all of my students over the last
couple years has actually been
Incorporated in the course so everything
is very battle tested and up to date I
was actually just making some updates
yesterday so how does this course
actually work well we're going to start
by doing over 100 Hands-On coding
lessons and exercises now when we're
done with all of that you'll actually
have a really strong grasp on the
fundamentals so at that point we'll go
build a production ready back-end server
in go from scratch now I'm begging you
please do not binge watch this video
tutorial hell is a very real place and
it's a place that you will go if you
don't write your own code get your hands
on the keyboard and write some code with
me in fact you should actually be coding
ahead of me and only using my Solutions
when you get stuck so head over to
boot.dev and create a free account
that's where all of the code samples for
this course are hosted now alternatively
I have linked a GitHub repo in the
description below all of the raw code
for the samples in this course are
hosted there it won't be quite a
streamlined of an option but it is an
option now you should also know that
this course is just one part of the full
backend developer career path over on
boot.dev so if you're interested in
going from zero to hired as a back-end
developer you should definitely check
that out too now as long as we're
talking about external resources know
that if you get stuck during this course
you have some options for help first
you've got the boot.dev Discord second
you've got the free code Camp Discord
and third you've got the free code Camp
Forum I will link all of those down in
the description below okay one last
thing before we jump into the course if
you want to connect with me personally
or you want access to my other go and
back-end content then you can follow me
on Twitter at wagslane or you can
subscribe to my YouTube channel at
boot.dev I'll link both of those down in
the description below with all of that
out of the way let's talk about go
everyone always wants to talk about how
fast the go programming languages let's
talk about it and let's compare go to
some of the other more popular
programming languages
so in terms of execution speed
execution
speed
go is much faster than JavaScript python
Ruby and PHP pretty much any interpreted
language a language that's not compiled
is going to be slower than go because go
is a compiled language now don't worry
too much if you're not familiar with the
terms compiled and interpreted we'll
talk about those in just a minute for
now just understand that go is much
faster than these languages when it
comes to executing programs if we're
doing computationally heavy work go is
going to be much more performant than
some of these other languages now here
on the other side I've listed some
compiled languages so when it comes to
compilation speed
go is actually much faster than these
compiled languages when it comes to
compiling the code now again we'll talk
about compiling in a minute but for now
just understand that you have to compile
your code before you can run it when
you're working with a compiled language
and so by having a fast compilation
speed like go has it actually increases
developer productivity quite a bit we
can iterate more quickly on our code we
can deploy it more quickly it's not as
expensive to run tests to compile the
program and deploy it to production so
this is actually a huge benefit that go
has now I do want to point out that go
does not necessarily run faster it does
not necessarily have a faster execution
speed than all of these languages but it
does beat them handily when it comes to
compiling not to beat a dead horse but I
want to talk a little bit more about
execution speed so we talked about how
go is generally faster than the
interpreted languages right python
JavaScript Ruby PHP and so on it gets a
little interesting when we compare go to
kind of the name natively compiled
languages or the languages that compile
directly to a kind of machine code that
runs on your CPU versus the compiled
languages that run on top of a virtual
machine right so the the two big ones
that run on a virtual machine are Java
and c-sharp while some of the compiled
or natively compiled languages that
you'll be familiar with might be rust C
C plus plus even though go is a natively
compiled language a language that
compiles directly to machine code like
rust C and C plus its execution speed is
actually more similar to Java and C
sharp when it comes to its run time
speed how many computations it can do
kind of per second and we'll talk more
about this later but the primary reason
for that is the go run time
there's basically a chunk of code that's
included in every go program that
manages memory and that tends to slow
down the execution speed a little bit
that said it is worth pointing out that
a go program tends to use much less
memory than Java and c-sharp because
there isn't a need for an entire virtual
machine
here we are at the first coding
challenge let me break down what we are
supposed to do and then I'll kind of
explain what this code over on the right
actually does so
um our assignment is to log the string
starting textio server to the console
instead of hello world so throughout
this course we'll be building out little
pieces of the textio product which if
you're familiar with twilio it'll kind
of be like a twilio clone it's a kind of
back-end server that sends SMS and email
messages and works a lot with kind of
textual data every file of go code has a
package declaration at the top here we
have a package main simply because this
program builds into an executable go
program right so we can run this code
kind of Stand Alone the next line is
importing the fmt package from the
standard Library we are importing it
because we're using it down here within
the main function now the main function
is the entry point to the program so
every go program starts execution at the
top of the main function which is just a
function named main that takes no inputs
and doesn't return anything on line six
and seven we have some single line
comments these don't execute they are
not part of the program they're just
there for documentation and single line
comments just start with that double
slack finally on line eight we have the
one thing that this program actually
does which is print the string hello
world to the console so let me go ahead
and run that
see down here printed to the console
it's using the standard libraries fmt
package
um and the print line function that is
exposed from that package uh to do so
the assignment here is pretty simple
we're just supposed to swap out that
hello world message for starting text i
o server I'm going to run that and make
sure it looks like what I would expect
we're good to go next let's fix a quick
bug I love quick wins
um we're not going to talk about all of
this syntax in this program what we're
interested in is just fixing the math
bug on line 17. so the assignment
description says textile users are
reporting that we are billing them for
wildly inaccurate amounts they're
supposed to be billed for .02 dollars
for each text message they send
something else is happening so the total
cost here is being set to the cost per
message plus the number of messages
now that doesn't make a lot of sense to
me go ahead and pause the video see if
you can figure this one out on your own
um to me it looks like the cost per
message should be multiplied by the
number of messages right
and let me let me run it like this
so we can see
Doris spent 4.02 on text messages today
or messages
that doesn't make sense right for four
messages she should not be billed four
dollars and two cents if each message
only cost two cents so I'm gonna go
ahead and change that to a multiply I
would expect eight cents
yep Dora spent eight cents on text
messages today cool I'm gonna go ahead
and submit that
this is one of my favorite XKCD Comics
uh you can pause and read it uh really
quick if you'd like slow and resource
expensive compilation times are a really
terrible thing to work with I've worked
on systems in Java and C plus plus that
took over an hour to compile the code
that means that if we find a bug and we
want to deploy it to production even if
we get the bug fixed within five minutes
it's still going to take an hour just to
build the new production version so that
we can deploy it on our servers I've
personally never worked on a go program
that's taken more than just a couple of
seconds to build and compile so the
first question is go code generally runs
blank then interpreted languages and
compiles blank then other compiled
languages like cnrust so the answer is
going to be faster and faster right it
runs faster than most interpreted
languages and it compiles faster than
most compiled languages
so the question on this one is does go
generally execute faster than rust the
answer is going to be no
so I've thrown around this word
compilation or compiled a few times but
we haven't really talked about what it
means
when we write code
we write it in a human readable format
right typically in a file in the case of
go a DOT go file right maybe main.go
and this file is going to contain human
readable text right go code that we as
developers work on the thing is your
computer's Hardware doesn't know what
any of that human readable text means
your computer's CPU only understands
binary
right which is ones and zeros
right which at the end of the day is
just numbers right but it's just numbers
and simple operations things like add
and subtract
so we need some process that we can use
to convert human readable code to
machine code that can be executed by the
computer's hardware and that's all that
compilation is compilation is just the
process of taking some human readable
code right go code in our instance and
converting it to Binary or machine code
that our computer can actually
understand so what does this process
actually look like Well normally
you'd start by writing your go program
so say main dot go
and you'd run it through the go compiler
on your command line you type go build
and that would produce a new file which
is the executable program let's say we
were doing a hello word a hello world
program it might be hello
world
dot e x e
right an executable program on your
computer and then you could run that
executable directly on your operating
system without ever having to use the go
tool chain again so the great thing is
you can take this hello world.exe
program and give it to someone else and
they can run it on their computer
without ever having to install the go
tool chain or even know that you used go
to build the program in the first place
this is different than languages like
python where if you want to run
someone's python code you have to use
the python interpreter every single time
and you run the source code you run the
source code directly on your machine
it's also worth pointing out that part
of the reason that compiling is so much
faster at runtime is that we do all of
this compiling work up front so when we
go to run the executable we don't have
to do any conversions from Human
readable text to Binary machine code
that's different than how interpreted
languages work with an interpreted
language add as we run the program The
Interpreter is reading the human code
and kind of at runtime converting it to
machine code that the CPU can operate on
so you might be wondering where is the
compiling Happening Here on boot Dev
well we actually do the compiling and
the running at the same time for you so
when you click the Run button we're
actually taking your code shipping it
off to our servers compiling it running
it and giving you the result don't worry
when we get down the road to the actual
project you'll be building and running
your own go code on your own machine but
we can see the difference between a
compiler error and a runtime error even
here on boot Dev so for example here in
this code the assignment says to pass
this exercise fix the compiler error in
the code so I'm just going to run it as
is and you'll see we get this nasty
error here and it says main.go right
line six syntax error this is actually a
compile time error so we weren't even
able to compile file this code it didn't
fail at runtime it failed at compile
time right which again that distinction
will become more clear a little bit
later so anyways um we can fix it by
adding that close parenthesis that was
missing
and now it compiles and runs just fine
so to review
go code like this little go program here
that prints hello world
that's not understood directly by the
hardware on your computer your
computer's processor or your computer's
CPU understands machine code so we need
to take our human readable go code run
it through the go compiler to produce
the machine code that we can run
directly on our CPU right the CPU is
designed by the manufacturer to run a
specific format of binary
cool so the question for this exercise
is do computer processors understand
English instructions like open the
browser
no processes are not chatgpt they need
machine code
now we touched on this very briefly
before but I want to talk about how you
distribute a compiled program versus how
you would distribute an interpreted
program so let's say that you'd written
a script in Python so you've got this
script
main.py right this is raw python code
and you want to give it to your friends
so that they can run your script well
all you would do with an interpreted
language is give your friend
the main.py file and then on their
computer they would run the command
python
main dot p y
and they'd be able to run your code now
there are a couple of downsides to this
approach the first problem is that your
friend needs to have python installed on
their computer so your your friend being
able to use your program is dependent on
them already having python installed
it's even dependent on them knowing how
to use it or knowing how to use a
command line right so Distributing the
programs of interpreted languages can be
tricky because it's really only useful
if you're Distributing to other
developers who know how to use these
tools already the other problem is the
code itself let's say you spent you know
many weeks writing this python script
and it's super useful and you're trying
to sell it to customers if you just give
them your python code I mean they
effectively own it they can change it
even if you didn't intend for it to be
open source congratulations it's now
open source the problem is you can't
really allow someone to use your program
without giving them all of the special
sauce that makes it work let's review
how this works in a language like go
so in go we'd start the same way right
we'd write some human readable go code
in a file called main.co but instead of
giving that file to our friend we're
going to compile it first
I'm going to compile it
we'd use the go tool chain so we'd write
something like go build in our command
line and that would produce a new
executable file right so this is this is
machine code here
um let's just say that the name of our
program is Hello World why not
so for on Windows it might be
helloworld.exe
right so when you go online and you
download a program to you say it's a
video game it is probably a bundle of
machine code it is a built binary right
in order to run your favorite video game
let's say Starcraft 2 or World of
Warcraft you don't need to install the C
plus compiler right you're just given
the built kind of final product the
final executable program and that's what
we're doing in the go programming
language as well so now we can give our
friend this executable
they don't need to install go and they
do not need access to the original
source code so generally speaking
Distributing programs that are natively
compiled is much much easier than
Distributing programs that kind of have
a runtime dependency like an interpreter
so to answer the question for this
exercise do users of compiled programs
need access to the source code no they
don't and a related question which
language is interpreted we've got go C
plus plus Python and rust and the answer
is python
the rest are all compiled so now the
question is why is it generally more
simple to deploy a compiled server-side
program or back-end application and the
answers are compiled code is more memory
efficient because Docker exists there
are no runtime language dependencies or
because compiled code is faster
well it's just the same as what we
talked about earlier when we deploy to a
server say on the cloud we have to have
all of the dependencies that our
back-end application needs in order to
run installed on that server and if
there are no runtime dependencies if all
we need is a compiled binary then that's
arguably the simplest way to do it right
so the answer is it's more simple to
deploy a com to deploy a compiled
program to a back-end server if there
are no runtime language dependencies
things like the python interpreter or
The node.js Interpreter for example go
is strongly typed and statically typed
and that's a really good thing if you've
been paying any attention at all to the
JavaScript World you'll notice that a
lot of JavaScript developers are making
the switch to typescript and that's
primarily to get access to static typing
a lot goes into typing and type systems
but one of the biggest benefits of a
static type system light goes is that
when we declare a string right like say
this username string that I've set equal
to wagslane We Can't later accidentally
change it to an integer a number right
like a float64. it's going to stay a
string the nice thing about a static
type system like we have with go or that
you have with typescript is that we get
feedback on our errors uh much more
quickly right rather than finding out
about a bug when our code is running in
production we find out about the bug say
when we compile our code let's move on
to the assignment the assignment says
we'll be using basic authentication for
the text I O API so basic authentication
is is just this format here where you've
got a username and a password in an HTTP
header it tells the server on each
individual request to the server who you
are right it's kind of like logging in
um
or rather it's kind of like being logged
in
okay uh so the code on the right has a
type error change the type of password
to a string Okay cool so I'm just going
to run it to see the type error first so
invalid operation username plus colon
plus password has mismatch types of
string in it now this is a
physical time error we weren't even able
to compile this code right let alone run
it in production
um so we've been instructed in the
assignment change the type of password
to a string but use the same numeric
value so that it can be concatenated
with the username variable Okay cool so
I'm just going to change this to a
string by surrounding it in double
quotes that's how you do strings and go
pretty similar to other languages and
then I'm just going to change that type
to a string type and run it again
authorization basic Wags Lane colon
number that looks good to me
when we're talking about the performance
of a programming language or an
application we really care about how it
performs across two different axes one
is speed how fast it can do computations
right which is kind of measured in CPU
cycles and then we also have memory
consumption which is just how bloaty the
program is how much data it has to store
in memory to be able to do those
computations every program you write no
matter the language is going to be using
memory every time you create a new
variable it allocates space in memory
where it can store that variable's data
now in languages like rust or C memory
management is effectively manual now
that said Russ does have some nice
tooling that kind of takes care of it
for you at compile time so it's not
quite as error prone as as it would be
in C or C plus plus but at the end of
the day your program is allocating
memory right it's saying this chunk of
memory I'm going to use I'm going to
store some very variable data here in
this bit of RAM and then later your
program says I'm not using it anymore so
we can free it up for use by other
programs now let's jump over to Java so
with Java it's a little bit different
Java is a garbage collected language
garbage collection which essentially
means that memory management is
automated
and in Java it's done by the Java
virtual machine so every time you run a
Java program you're actually creating an
entire
mini virtual machine
that your Java byte code runs within so
this is the jvm
and then you kind of insert your code
into the jvm
and you run your code in there and the
jvm is what takes care of allocating and
freeing all of the memory that you use
and this creates overhead basically at
the end of the day Java programs use
quite a bit more memory than rust or C
programs go is in an interesting sort of
in-between world where go is a garbage
collected language like Java so it has
automated
automated memory management but it does
not have a jvm when you compile go code
rather than having to run it within a
jvm just like with rust and C you get
one binary or one executable program the
difference is that go includes a runtime
a run time
within every single binary that's built
using legal programming language
so we could think of it as something
like this it's kind of like a little
Sidecar
that is compiled alongside
your code
so your go program basically has this
this little bit of extra code that's
added to it and that bit of code is what
handles garbage collection and automated
memory management so it's a little more
bloaty than what you'd get with rust and
C right it is garbage collected
um but it's not nearly as
um expensive in terms of memory overhead
as a language like Java or c-sharp let's
take a look at what some actual numbers
look like I pulled this chart from
Dexter darwick's blog and if you're
following Along on boot Dev you can
click the link to go check out the full
the full blog in the description of this
experiment but basically he built a
restful web server in three different
programming languages right in Java go
in Rust and then measured the memory
consumption and when the servers were
just at rest effectively doing nothing
and waiting for requests to come in
rust used less than half of the memory
that go was using and go used 100 times
less memory right measured in megabytes
then the jvm was using to run the rest
service so to order the three languages
in terms of memory efficiency I would
say Java is the least efficient go is in
the middle and rust would be the most
memory efficient and it's also worth
pointing out just really quickly that as
the load on the server increases I would
expect go to have more similar
performance to Java in other words we
wouldn't see as quite a large
discrepancy here right go would likely
still be more memory efficient than Java
almost certainly in fact but it probably
wouldn't be a 100x discrepancy we're
seeing this huge discrepancy
um mostly because this is an idle a test
of an idle program so generally speaking
which language uses more memory that's
going to be Java
another question on the same topic is
what's one of the purposes of the go run
time so to style go code and make it
easier to read that doesn't make sense
that would be like compile time tooling
right not run time tooling
to clean up unused memory to cook fried
chicken or to compile go code so it's
definitely going to be to clean up
unused memory and if you remember the
runtime is just that little bit of extra
code that's included in every compiled
go program that among other things
handles memory management
so we've already talked about how go has
strong and static types but we haven't
yet talked about what those types are
you're probably already familiar with
Boolean values and string values which
are valid go types and also exist in
pretty much every other programming
language numbers are where it first
starts to get a little bit different if
go is your first compiled programming
language generally speaking numbers fall
into four different buckets we have
integers unsighted integers or uints
floats and complex numbers integers are
just whole numbers they can be positive
or negative right one two three four you
get the idea unsigned integers are the
same as integers but they're not signed
which basically just means they don't
have a negative component you can only
represent positive numbers in an
unsigned integer you're probably already
familiar with the idea of floats it's
just fractional numbers right numbers
that have a fractional component things
like 1.21 or 3.14 complex numbers are a
little funny they're used to represent
the concept of imaginary numbers if
you've gotten to imaginary numbers in
your math studies I've never actually
used complex numbers
um in production I'm sure there are
plenty of use cases for them but we're
not going to go into detail on how they
work here you can certainly go read up
on it if you'd like the only other thing
worth mentioning is that size matters
when it comes to types A uint 8 and a u
inch 16 are two different types they
both represent unsigned integers but a
unit 16 has twice as much room for data
within it it has 16 bits of data whereas
a unit 8 only has eight bits
for example the largest number that you
can store in a uint 8 is 255 because
that's the largest number you can
represent with eight ones and zeros in
binary but with a uint 16 the largest
number you can store is about 65 000.
again because that's the biggest number
that can be represented by 16 binary
digits just like bigger number better
person a bigger number in your types
means you can represent more possible
values within that type so bullet64 can
represent more values than a float 32.
the only reason you wouldn't use a
larger type is if if you're trying to
save on memory if you're trying to write
a program that is hyper performant
you'll want to use a smaller size right
if you know that an integer is only ever
going to store three different values
say one two or three then you might
consider using a uint8 the byte type is
an interesting one and it's one that
you'll use a lot especially when you're
say marshaling a Json object to be sent
across a network connection or maybe
you're reading to and from a file on
disk but under the hood a byte is just
an alias for the uint 8 type which makes
sense right a byte is just eight binary
digits eight bits and that's all a uint
8 is a rune is a Unicode code point
which generally speaking you can think
of as one character in a string and
that's usually how it's used under the
hood it's just an alias for the int32
type moving on to the assignment it says
initialize the given variables to end
float64 Bool and string respectively
with their zero values and and as we can
see here if we just use VAR the name of
the variable and the type that should do
it so we'll initialize the variables
here so VAR
SMS sending limit is an INT
bar cost per SMS is a float
64.
has
permission
is a Bool
and
username
is a string okay cool and all so all of
these variables are now instantiated and
should contain their zero value so for
example 0
0.0 false and empty string let's go
ahead and run that
and that looks correct to me I'm going
to go ahead and submit it
we've been declaring variables the hard
way now we're going to do it the easy
way there is an operator and go colon
equals that is the short assignment
operator and it allows us to declare
variables and have go infer their type
so instead of typing VAR empty string we
can just say empty colon equals the
empty string and go knows that this has
to be a string so it is a string now
when we use this short assignment
operator we're not saying this is a
loose type that can change in the future
it's still a static type empty is a
string just like it would be if we
declared it this way in reality in go
you will very rarely see variables
declared like this you will almost
always see them declared using the
shorts the short assignment operator for
example
num cars colon equals 10 creates a new
variable called num cars and sets it
equals to 10 and its type will be
inferred to be an INT and the int type
Alias is either into 32 or in 64
depending on your computer's
architecture if you want to specify a
particular size of integer then you
would declare it using this kind of long
hand syntax so in this assignment we're
just meant to declare a variable named
congrats with the value happy birthday
using a short variable declaration so
as simple as congrats colon equals the
string happy birthday
let me run that
perfect
this next assignment says our current
price to send a text message in textdio
is two cents however it's likely in the
future that the price will have to be a
fraction of a penny or have a fractional
part to the cost so we should use a
float 64 to store this value edit the
pennies per text declaration so that
it's inferred by the compiler to be a
float64. Okay cool so here
we're just setting it equal to two
I run that
and I get the type of pennies per text
is int and this percent T in go
um is is a formatting verb that tells
the go programming language or or at
least the printf function I should say
the formatting package from the standard
Library
um that I want to print to the type of
this variable rather than its value so
that's why we're saying in there instead
of 2.
um to get a float all we need to do is
change it from 2 to 2.0 I believe
64. cool
another handy syntactic Quirk of the go
programming language is that we can
declare multiple values on the same line
so in this assignment it says declare a
float called average open rate and a
string called display message on the
same line okay so average open rate
display message
same line the average open rate must be
0.23
and the display message should be the
string
is the average open rate of your message
and then it looks like
this is just going to print them
together so it's going to say 0.23 is
the average open rate okay cool let's go
ahead and run that
0.023 is the average open rate of your
messages that looks correct to me
so we've already briefly talked about
the different type sizes in go right so
we have the int type int 8 in 16 into 32
and in 64. and it's important to
understand that the int type just
aliases into 32 or in 64.
um same with the uint type just
depending on your cpu's architecture so
you might be on a 32 or a 64-bit machine
most modern machines are going to be 64
bits my recommendation is that unless
you have an explicit reason to care
about the size right so unless you're
trying to kind of hyper optimize for
performance then you should really just
stick to these four types int uint
float64 and again if you're working with
imaginary numbers then complex 128 but
that's honestly unlikely so these three
types are going to do the vast majority
of the heavy lifting when it comes to
working with numbers in go we can also
convert
between you know different number types
for example we could take a an integer
88 and convert it to a float like this
so become
88.0 right converting the other way is a
little trickier though because say we
had 88.6 if we were to convert it to an
INT we would lose the 0.6 we would
truncate it down to just 88. now this
assignment says our text Au customers
want to know how long they've had
accounts with us follow the instructions
in the comment provided you will create
a new variable called account age int
that will be the truncated integer
version of account age Okay cool so
create a new account age end here
should be the result of casting a count
age to an integer so we'll just do int
account age and I would expect that to
be 2 after casting it because it should
truncate the 0.6 so let's go ahead and
run that
your account has existed for two years
yeah that looks good to me
we already briefly touched on this but
it's worth mentioning again I recommend
that you stick to the I call them the
default types so for example we know
there's um you know five or six I can't
think of it off the top of my head now
different types of ins right int int 8
and 16 and 32 and 64. I'd recommend
sticking to int unless you have a very
good reason to specify a smaller size
like int 8 or in 32 and that's simply so
you avoid cluttering your code with tons
of type conversions that can sometimes
even lead to bugs so unless you need a
smaller type for performance reasons
just use these default types
okay so the question for this assignment
is when should you elect to not use a
default type
when either a default or a specific size
will work when my system has lots of
extra Hardware that I want to utilize or
when performance and memory are the
primary concern
so it's going to be performance if you
have performance concerns that's the
time I would maybe
stray away from the default types
the next question is what does the size
of a type indicate so a float64 what
does 64 mean is it bits bytes or nibbles
the answer is going to be bits now it is
worth pointing out nibbles is a real
thing so a byte is eight bits a nibble
is actually Four bits if you didn't know
that fun interesting trivia
aside from variables go also supports
constants which are immutable values and
in go just like in JavaScript or
typescript we use the const keyword and
constants do not support the short
declaration syntax so we have to kind of
write it all out
okay so getting to the assignment says
use two separate constants something
weird is happening in this code what
should be happening is that we create
two separate constants Premium plan name
and basic plan name right now looks like
we're trying to overwrite one of them
okay cool so on line six we've got
Premium plan name
and we're setting it to Premium plan and
then we have Premium plan name again
attempting to override the value
and set it to a new string if we try to
run this we actually get a compile time
error so we're not allowed to mutate
constants in go
so what we should be doing is creating a
separate constant and it should be named
basic plan name
let's go ahead and run that
plan Premium plan plan basic plan looks
good to me
Constance in go are not the same as
constants in JavaScript and in
typescript in JavaScript and typescript
the const keyword really just means you
can't reassign to this variable but you
can compute the variable or the
variable's value at runtime in go every
value that's stored in a constant must
be known or computed at compile time
before the program runs so if we create
this new constant called my int and set
it equal to 15 within the compiled go
binary effectively this symbol my int
just refers to the static number 15.
the cool thing is that we can actually
compute constants like we can make
constants that depend on other constants
but that computation will run when we
compile our code not when we run our
code
so for example I can create this
constant first name Lane last name
Wagner and then I can create a new
constant called full name it's first
name plus a space plus and a last name
and that's really convenient in case I
ever want to change first name now I
don't have to change it in two places
right full name will automatically
update but this is only valid because
all of the inputs to this full name
constant first name and last name are
known at compile time so the compiler
can still do the thing it wants to do
which is replace full name with a static
string right lane space Wagner
so on to the assignment
says keeping track of time in a message
sending application like textile is
critical imagine getting at a point
reminder an hour after your doctor's
visit not very helpful right
complete the code using a computer
constant to print the number of seconds
in an hour
Okay so we've got the number of seconds
in a minute is 60. the number of minutes
in an hour is also 60 so how many
seconds are in an hour
cool well we could hard code this as
like 60 times 60.
but the cool thing is we can actually
compute it because we can say well we
know the minutes the number of minutes
in an hour and we know the number of
seconds in a minute
and if we multiply those two together we
should get the number of seconds in an
hour right
that looks correct to me
so I'm obviously a huge go fan but
formatting strings and go is honestly
one of my least favorite features of the
language I think it's one of its
weaknesses at the moment who knows maybe
it'll improve in the future the way it's
done well we essentially have two
different functions provided to us by
the standard Library we have printf and
S printf printf prints a formatted
string directly to standard out and S
printf just Returns the formatted string
as a value basically all string
formatting in go currently works the
same way we have these formatting verbs
things like percent V percent s percent
d
and they're replaced in the string
template with actual values so for
example I am percent V years old the
percent V in this case is replaced by 10
the first parameter that comes after the
template in the printf function
here we could also replace with a string
instead of an issue right I am percent V
years old way too many Prince I am way
too many years old percent V is sort of
the default formatter it's usually what
you want a us don't want to print in
kind of the default standard way using
percent V then there are a few others
percent S interpolates A String percent
D interpolates an integer in decimal
form so for example 10 becomes the
number 10 instead of say in binary form
uh percent s is for floats so you can
specify the number of kind of places
after the decimal point that you want
printed out to the console or print it
out to the returned string in the case
of s printf
um
so actually do end up using percent F
fairly regularly when I'm working with
floats so on to the assignment it says
create a new variable called MSG on line
9. MSG stands for message of course it's
a string that contains the following hi
name your open rate is open rate percent
where a name is the given name and open
rate is the open rate rounded to the
nearest tenths place okay so the tenths
place is the number right after the
decimal so let's get started here
message colon equals fmt dot s printf so
we're going to use S print f
instead of print F because we don't want
this value going to standard out we want
it returned from the function so we can
save it in the MSG variable
let's just grab this template
so we'll use percent s we could use
percent s or percent V here because
we're just uh interpolating a string and
we'll do percent
point one F because we want
to just print the first
number after that the decimal point
right the tenths place
okay and then we just pass
the two values as the following
parameters or as the last two parameters
so name and open rate
all right so the first value name we'll
go into the first verb the second value
will go into the second verb let's run
that see what we get
I saw Goodman your open rate is 30.5
percent that looks good to me
let's talk about conditionals in go so a
conditional is just where we are
checking if a condition is true if it is
we do one thing if it's not we may do
another so for example uh here's an if
statement in go and if this expression
evaluates to true then we'll run the
stuff within the curly braces the body
of the if statement if you're familiar
with other programming languages like
JavaScript this is a very very similar
syntax the only difference is we're not
surrounding the height is greater than
four section with parentheses so again
to be clear this bit between the if
keyword and the curly brace will be
evaluated and if it evaluates to true
then the stuff inside the curly braces
will be executed
um so in this case we have the variable
height and we're using the greater than
operator to compare it to the number
four so if height is greater than four
then we'll print you are tall enough
sort of listed some of the different
comparison operators down here at the
bottom they're basically identical to
pretty much every other programming
language you will probably have used uh
up to this point
additionally we can do different things
if the if statement does not evaluate to
true so this is a perfectly valid if
statement you do not need an else if or
an else block they are they're optional
effectively
um but the way it works is when we get
to this code basically we'll we'll
compare height to six right and if that
expression evaluates to true then we'll
just print you are super tall and we'll
be done
okay otherwise if that expression of
values to false then we'll drop down
into this next if else or sorry else if
statement and we'll compare height to
four if height is greater than four then
we'll print you are tall enough and
again we'll be done at that point so if
this evaluates to true we execute this
kind of section of code between the
curly braces and at that point we'll be
done
otherwise if that's also false so if
height is not greater than 6 and height
is not greater than 4 then the else
statement executes notice the else
statement does not have its own
expression it just kind of always
executes if all of the if and else if
statements um turned out to be false
so let's jump into the assignment it
says fix the bug on line 12. the if
statement should print message sent if
the message length
is less than or equal to the max message
length or message not sent otherwise
okay cool so up here we've defined two
variables message length is 10 Max
messes length is 20.
um and then here we're going to do some
comparing let me just run the code in
its current state
it says trying to send a message of
length 10 and a max length of 20.
message not sent okay so that seems
problematic right because with a message
length of 10 and a Max message length of
20 I should be able to send that message
so the Bug Online 12 I think we just
need to flip this operator to be less
than or equal to so that now this
expression right message length less
than or equal to Max message length
should evaluate to true because it is
message length is in fact smaller okay
let's run that
message sent that seems to work
it's worth pointing out that in go we
also have kind of an alternate way to
write if statements
if the variable that we are comparing in
an if statement is only used in that if
statement then this syntax can be
helpful okay so here's kind of the
traditional way of doing something we
would create a variable called length
let's just assume it's an integer you
can kind of forget this function Syntax
for now we'll talk about it in a future
chapter but basically the idea here is
we have a length variable it's an
integer right and we're initializing it
here we're creating the variable here
um and then we're comparing it against
one right we're checking if it's less
than one and if it is we're doing
something in this case we're printing
that the email is invalid well instead
of this syntax then by the way this
works perfectly fine there's nothing
wrong with doing it this way but we can
alternately do it this way which is
basically to initialize that length
variable in the if block within that
first kind of initial statement so
notice there's two statements here
separated by a semicolon
and in the first one we're creating that
length variable and then we're moving
the comparison itself kind of after the
semicolon
and then if that condition obviously
evaluates to true then we'll execute the
block this does kind of two things for
us first it saves us a line of code
um which I would argue probably isn't
the biggest benefit in the world
um but more importantly uh it makes it
so that this length variable is only
accessible within uh kind of the scope
of this if block so kind of down
underneath this code we wouldn't be able
to use the length uh variable anymore
which is kind of nice if you never
intended to use it in the first place
you can kind of think of this as a clean
code hack or like a
um kind of safety hack to ensure that
the length variable is never reused Down
Below in other code when you never
intended it to be reused okay so uh the
question for this assignment is why
would you use the initial section of an
if statement and the answers are to
confuse other programmers to keep the
code concise and the scope limited or to
speed up your code
um the answer is going to be to keep the
code more concise and to again limit the
scope that that variable exists Within
like other programming languages go
supports functions functions are
basically just a way to break up your
code into individual units that are
easier to reason about right a function
takes in a specified number of inputs
and it returns a specified number of
outputs for example this subtract
function here named sub takes two inputs
X an integer and Y an integer and it
returns a single integer in this case it
just performs the simple calculation x
minus y and then Returns the result to
the caller now this little bit right
here right Funk sub X integer y integer
returns integer is what's known as the
function signature if you've never heard
that term before it's basically just a
description of what the function does in
terms of its types in terms of its
inputs and its outputs and what types
they are right this basically says this
is a function called sub it takes an
integer X and an integer Y and returns
another integer function signatures are
great because they tell us how we can
use the functions really at the end of
the day if we're the person calling the
function or the person using the
function really all we care about is
what we need to give the function as
inputs and what we get out of the
function in terms of its outputs so we
function signature basically tells us
all we need to know about a function to
be able to use it it omits all of the
implementation details the stuff with
within the curly brackets or within the
body of the function so let's get on to
the assignment Simon says we often need
to manipulate strings in our messaging
app that makes sense right we're working
with SMS and email messages within
textio so we're doing a lot of textual
data manipulation
the concat function should take two
strings as inputs and smash them
together right so returning a new string
that is a concatenation of the inputs
for example hello Plus World equals
hello world so we'd expect to return
this concatenated string from our concat
function over here fix the function the
function signature of concat to reflect
its Behavior Okay cool so let me try
running this and just see what happens
looks like undefined S1
undefined S2 undefined this one okay so
these are undefined and
so S1 and S2 that kind of stands for
string one string two that makes sense
the problem here is that we're not
we're not telling go
what the types of the inputs should be
and this plus operator when operating on
strings just concatenates so that should
work let's go ahead and run that
yeah this looks good to me I want to
just make one more point about function
signatures in go you'll notice that the
type comes after
the name of the variable so S1 is a
string S2 is a string and that's just to
make it a little easier to read the
authors of the go programming language
kind of built on uh a lot of the ideas
from C and in C it was the reverse it
was string S1 string S2 and that just
kind of reads a little clunky if you're
used to kind of speaking in plain
English makes more sense for the type to
kind of come after what it describes go
provides another bit of interesting
syntactic sugar when it comes to
function signatures when multiple
arguments are of the same type in this
case X and Y the inputs to the add
function are both integers the type only
needs to be declared on the last one
assuming that they're in order right so
in this case this is valid go code and X
and Y are both integers because they
follow one another we can put the
integer just after the Y if we were
going to add say a string as a third
parameter to this function then we would
just add a comma here after int and put
you know name String or whatever this is
just a bit of syntactic sugar it makes
our code a little less verbose you don't
need to do this you can explicitly put
the type on every input and output but
you will often see code like this it's a
convenient shorthand so we've got these
two example Snippets of code Funk create
user first name String last name String
age ins and Funk create user first name
last name String agent so which of the
following is the most succinct way to
write a function signature succinct is
just another word for kind of it's I
guess it's the opposite of verbose right
fewer fewer words
um it's going to be the one that uses
the syntactic sugar which is this one
because we're omitting the string
keyword after first name so we already
talked about this briefly the idea that
in go we specify the type of a variable
after the variable name and this is you
know different from kind of the C style
way of doing things which if you were to
declare a variable Y in C you would say
int Y and really the authors of the go
programming language just felt that that
didn't flow naturally from English it's
not the way we talk right we say x is an
integer not integer is X if you want to
read up on that decision and why they
ended up choosing that style then you
can follow this link here assuming
you're following Along on boot Dev
so the question is what are we talking
about when we discuss this declaration
syntax right this the swapping of the
name and the type
um and here are options the decision
about camel case versus snake case
um the style of a language used to
create new variables types and functions
guard Clauses versus if else no the ever
important question of tabs versus spaces
now it's going to be the style of
language used to create new variables
types and functions related question is
Which languages declaration syntax reads
like English from right to left see or
go the answer is going to be go go
supports functions as data or basically
the idea that you can pass functions
around your program to be called in
different places callbacks right if
you're familiar with JavaScript then
you're probably familiar with the idea
of a callback it's a function that you
could pass to another function to be
called later this question deals with
that idea whenever we pass a callback in
go the type of the function changes
based on what its inputs and outputs are
so for example here
Funk int is a function that takes two
integers as an input and returns an
integer and that's going to be a
different type
than a function that say took three
integers as input and returned an
integer and if you think about it it
makes sense right if I'm going to pass
ion to another function so that it can
call it later it kind of needs to know
how many inputs how many parameters it
can pass into that function if it's a
function that takes two inputs versus
three inputs then the caller is going to
have to write the code differently so we
have to treat every function signature
as its own unique type so this question
is a bit of a doozy I encourage you to
pause the video and try to work this one
out on your own but basically it says
what is this hairy beast here right F
Funk Funk int
all right
potential answers are a function named F
that takes as int takes an INT as the
argument and returns an INT
no it is not nearly that simple right
a function named F that takes a function
and an INT as arguments and returns a
function let's see
uh that right there is a full function
and an INT
as arguments and returns a function no
this returns an INT
okay a function named F that takes a
function and an INT as wrote arguments
and returns in it that's what I believe
it will be
function named F that takes a function
as the argument and returns an INT yep
that's not it so to be clear
f is a function
it takes two parameters
a function
right a function of a specific type a
function that takes two ins and returns
an INT
and as its second parameter an INT
and then F returns an INT
hopefully that makes sense again feel
free to pause the video and and stare at
that for a second
let's talk a little bit about memory and
how data that we create in our program
using variables is stored in memory so
over here
I'll keep track of the memory of our
program and over here I'll write some
code
so let's say
in our code we write X colon equals five
right so we're creating a new variable
called X and we're giving it the value
the integer value of five and then we're
placing the value five
in that memory right stored as binary
data within Ram now in our program X the
symbol is essentially just a pointer
it points to this location in memory so
let's say on the next line of code we
update X and we say x equals 2. so now
we're reassigning the value of x to 2.
now let's try something different what
if we create a new variable called y
and we initialize it to the current
value of x which in this case happens to
be 2.
well in this case
we're actually going to allocate a new
section of memory to store the value of
y
and we'll initialize it to the current
value of x which is 2.
and the symbol y
now has its own location in memory so we
basically created a copy of X now this
idea is really important to understand
because sometimes in programming we'll
have multiple variables that actually
point to the same location in memory
they can overwrite each other
and sometimes we don't sometimes we have
copies
of data right so now for example if I
were to update y let's say I made y
equal 1
at this point x would be unaffected X
would remain 2
but y now
becomes one right because we have a copy
these two variables X and Y reference
different locations in memory so why
does all of this matter well in go
variables are passed by value not by
reference so let's take a look at this
code snippet here
top of main we declare a new variable
called X we set it equal to five and
then we pass X into a function called
increment
the increment function just adds one to
X right making it six
after that we print X and the weird
thing is
that when we print X here we still get
five and the reason for that is the
increment function was operating on a
copy of X when we pass X in here to
increment increment gets a new copy of X
still equal to 5. it increments that X
to 6 and then because we are not
returning it it essentially just gets
thrown away and then back in main we
still have this same X that's still
equal to 5. the correct thing to do here
would be to have the increment function
return X after making its modification
and up in main we would write x equals
increment X so that we could capture the
return value from the increment function
so moving on to the assignment it says
it's critical in textio that we keep
track of how many SMS messages we have
sent on behalf of our clients fix the
bug to accurately track the number of
SMS messages sent okay let me just try
running this in its current state
and we're missing a return
okay I'm going to remove this
this uh type return there and see what
happens
set 430 messages
and it looks like here we have sends so
far sends to add increment sends is
doing nothing because sense so far is
still printing
is 430.
okay I think I'm understanding so let me
put that back in
the assignment says alter increment
sends so that it Returns the result
after incrementing sends so far
alter the main function to capture the
return value from increment sends and
overwrite the previous sends so far
value Okay cool so this is pretty
similar to the code snippet here
basically we need to return an INT so
we're going to return
send so far
and then here
we need to reassign since so far
into the result of increment sense
cool
so
again here we'll still be operating on
copies but because we're going to return
the copy and save it back into the
original variable we should be good to
go let me run that
yep you sent 455 messages that looks
correct functions in go can have
multiple return values and when they do
have multiple return values the Syntax
for specifying that is just to wrap the
return values in parentheses as well so
when there's just a single return value
we do not wrap that return value in
parentheses but when there are multiples
we do wrap them in parentheses one thing
I really like about go is that it does
not allow you to have unused variables
and because it doesn't allow you to have
unused variables and because it allows
you to have multiple return values from
a function we kind of need a way to
ignore some of the return values because
there are definitely instances where a
function returns two things but maybe we
only care about one of those things for
example a point on a graph can be
described by its X Y coordinates but
maybe all we care about is the x
coordinate so here we can call the get
Point function and ignore the Y value by
using an underscore and it's important
to understand that the underscore is not
just like a conventional name that we're
going to ignore it's actually ignored
the compiler
completely removes it from our code so
moving on to the assignment here in
textio we have obviously first names and
last names for all of the users that
we're able to send messages to well when
we welcome someone to textio we don't
need their last name so let me go ahead
and try to run this code
and you'll see we'll actually get a
compiler error that says last name
declared and not used like I said go
does not allow us to have unused
variables which I think is a kind of an
awesome uh little bit of the tooling it
helps keep our code very clean and
concise easy to understand
um so we need to explicitly ignore that
last name with an underscore if we're
not going to use it let me try running
that again
and that looks good to me
in go we can name our return values and
if we do it actually Alters the behavior
of the function just a little bit let's
take a look at this function get chords
or get coordinates it returns two
integers and we've named the integers X
and Y and by naming them we've actually
initialized at the top of the function
the the variables X and Y and they're
initialized with their zero values so in
the case of an integer literally just
the number zero for both of them the
other interesting thing about naming our
return values is that if we use a naked
return statement
a return statement that doesn't
explicitly say for example return 0
comma five then the values of X and Y
are automatically returned from the
function so
this version of get coordinates is
actually the exact same as this kind of
more verbose version of get coordinates
right here we have not given the return
values the names X and Y and instead
we've initialized X and Y to their zero
values and then returned them explicitly
now a couple of recommendations I would
recommend using named returns when you
want to document kind of what the
intended purpose of each return value is
so for example if you have a function
that just returns three integers that
function signature could be pretty
confusing but if you have a function
signature that says it returns three
integers and they're named width height
and length that's a lot more interesting
to the caller of the function they
understand the purpose of each
individual return value much better so I
like to think of named return values as
basically a built-in way of documenting
what the purpose of all of your return
values are and you should generally just
use the them on the other hand this
implicit or automatic return that you
get along with named return values I
would typically advise against you'd
only want to use this in like very short
very simple functions because it harms
readability right and I'm pulling this
directly from the tour of go they also
agree with me
um implicit returns or naked return
statements
um generally a little bit harder to
understand so the way I would write this
function personally would be get chords
x y and and then I would explicitly
return X and Y so let's jump down into
the assignment it says one of our
clients likes us to send text messages
reminding users of Life events coming up
fix the bug by using named return values
in the function signature so the code
will compile and run as intended Okay
cool so this is the function we are
interested in fixing years until events
looks like it takes a user's age as
input and then returns or should return
kind of the number of years until
they're an adult which is 18 the number
of years until they can drink at least
in the US which is 21 and the number of
years until they can rent a car which
apparently is 25.
um
and it looks like we never want a
negative number so if if any of these
are less than zero we just set them
equal to zero that makes sense once
you're over 18 your years until you're
an adult are just zero right you're
already an adult
okay let me try running this see what we
get okay undefined years until adult all
right this makes sense right because
there's no colon here so we're not
defining a new variable and the
assignment said to use named return
values so let's go ahead and do that
two years until adults years until
drinking I'm gonna
format this a little better
and we'll do years until car rental
so again this will declare all of these
values with their zero value at the top
and then this naked return statement
should return them in order
and just to make sure adult drinking car
rental
adult drinking car rental okay we're in
the right order let me run that
first test so four years old they'll be
an adult in 18 years can drink in 17
coming to current 21 that all looks good
10 it's going down 22 Yep this looks
good to me so as I mentioned before
explicit returns are probably better
than implicit returns in most scenarios
it just makes a lot more sense right so
here in this function get chords x y and
so we're using named returns but we're
still explicitly returning X and Y this
is how I would recommend writing most of
your go code
um
this this function here is doing the
same thing it's explicitly returning
hard-coded values though instead of the
variables X and Y and it's just
important to understand that this
effectively overrides the implicit
return of X and Y so in this case 5 and
6 will be returned again that's why I
recommend doing it explicitly because
when you see a return statement that has
explicit values being returned those are
the ones that are returned you don't
have to do any guesswork you don't have
to scroll back to the top of the
function to see which values are being
returned so now we're going to break
that advice just for practice's sake
um the assignment says fix the function
to return the named values implicitly
okay so here we have a problem in our
code where we are basically explicitly
returning zeros which as we talked about
overrides the implicit return so my
guess is if we look at all of these yep
every test is returning zeros
if we just remove that implicit return
and run that
and it should work as intended
yep
and then just to show you what I mean
like what I would recommend doing is
this
bigger
like that that's how I'm going to
recommend doing it and in fact because
Boot Dev just checks the output this
should work just fine with our test so
I'm going to submit it like this
moving on to some questions about named
returns so it says when should naked
returns be used and the answers are for
large functions for small functions or
for complex functions and I would argue
if you're going to use naked returns at
all which honestly I'd kind of just
recommend against then you should only
use them for small functions the more
complex and large your functions get the
more important it is to be explicit and
readable and document your returns with
named returns and things like that the
next question is when should named
returns be used so when there are many
values being returned when the function
is simple or when there are few
parameters being returned I would argue
it's never really a problem to name your
return values but it's really important
when there are many values being
returned especially if there are many
values of the same type being returned
because then you can you know
essentially tell the caller of your
function through your function signature
what they should expect each value to
represent let's talk about one of my
favorite programming patterns or
programming styles that is early returns
or what they're also sometimes called as
guard Clauses so in early return or a
guard Clause is exactly what it sounds
like it's just when we return early from
a function so this function divide if
it's past a divisor of zero then it
returns early with an error otherwise it
goes ahead and does a kind of the
division and Returns the results and a
nil error now we're going to talk about
errors soon you don't have to worry too
much about how they work for now just
understand that a nil error effectively
means no error so when we're looking at
this divide function we can understand
that if the divisor is zero we're going
to return early and basically say we
can't do this division because we can't
divide by zero otherwise we'll take the
happy path towards the end of the
function
practices when it comes to software
engineering and how we write code change
all the time right there's millions of
developers all around the world writing
code and we all have different opinions
and kind of the the common opinion about
a certain style tends to change over
time
um the interesting thing is I think that
these days
um guard Clauses and early returns are
kind of looked at as a good thing this
is clean code right this is a good way
to write code certainly most go
programmers think this way but it wasn't
always that way there used to kind of be
a heuristic that developers used which
was you shouldn't ever return from a
function in more than one place so back
when that was kind of the more popular
way of doing things you'd get kind of
nasty if else nested statements like
this if you look at this function get
insurance amount
basically takes a status as input it
returns an integer and it only has one
return statement so it only returns from
one place but I would argue that doesn't
necessarily make this function all that
much easier to understand right we're
initializing a variable up at the top
amount and then just in this big nasty
nested if else chain we're kind of
reassigning the value of amount based on
some conditional logic now compare that
with guard Clauses right so with guard
Clauses instead of overwriting the
variable amount and then returning it at
the end of the function we're just
returning early with the proper amount
at each step of the way now both of
these functions do the exact same thing
they have the same behavior but I would
argue that the one with the guard
Clauses is much easier to understand
so the question for this exercise is
which is true guard Clauses are
unreadable guard Clauses are generally
worse than nested if else statements or
guard Clauses provide a linear approach
to logic trees okay so it's definitely
not
um these two right so I'm gonna go with
provide a linear approach to logic trees
and really all that means is rather than
having to follow kind of a tree
structure to look at conditional logic
we can just follow a straight line right
is it this no we move on is it this no
we can move on right it allows us to
break up kind of the cognitive load when
we're when we're reading code so
definitely a linear approach there the
next question is what is a guard Clause
so a bit wise or operation and and
operation in Boolean logic or an early
return from a function when a given
condition is met and it is an early
return
let's talk about structs so structs are
the first collection type that we're
going to talk about in this course a
collection type is just a type that
contains other types in the case of a
struct a struct is just a collection of
key value pairs if you're familiar with
python dictionaries or JavaScript object
literals this is basically the same idea
so for example we can define a car
struct and we can say a car has a make a
model a height and a width and each of
those fields has its own Associated type
so let's move on to the assignment I
think looking at the code is going to be
the easiest way to understand structs
okay complete the message to send struct
definition it needs two Fields phone
number and integer and message a string
and
um on these exercises I always recommend
kind of going and looking at the test
Suite this is all the code the way boot
Dev works like all the code is here and
we're really just testing standard
output to see if you got the right
answer so you can see literally
everything that's going on
um
so here you can see where a message to
send is going to be instantiated with
phone numbers and messages and here you
can see where it's the uh if fields are
going to be accessed with the dot
operator so let me go ahead and run it
in its current state we should get yep a
compile time error where it's saying
message is undefined phone number is
undefined right so we need to add those
to the definition
all right phone number
integer
message
string
let's go ahead and run that
and sending message love to have you
aboard to that big number okay that
looks good to me
struct keys can hold any type not just
primitive types like integers strings
and booleans here you can see we've
actually nested the wheel struct within
the car struct right so we have the car
Struck from the last example and we've
added a front wheel and a back wheel and
they are each of type wheel right and a
wheel has a radius and a material so we
can actually Nest structs within other
structs and then we also saw this just a
little bit in the last assignment but
this is how we can instantiate a new
instance of a struct right so
this is the struck definition we're
saying this is what a car looks like and
then here we've created a new empty car
called my car and when you create it
kind of with those empty uh those empty
brackets all of the fields inside of the
struct will just be initialized to their
default values there's zero values right
so strings will be empty strings ins
will be zero
and then here we're using the dot
operator to access Fields right so my
car dot front wheel right so we're
accessing the front wheel key and then
dot radius to access access the radius
within the front wheel and we're setting
it equal to five again with this syntax
stuff it's just best to get Hands-On
keyboard and jump right into it so let's
get to the assignment says textio has a
bug we've been sending texts with
information missing before we send text
messages in textio we should check to
make sure the required Fields have
non-zero values notice that both the
user structs that's this here is a
nested struct or notice that the user
struct is a nested struck within message
to send okay so message to send has a
message which is a string and then a
sender and a recipient and both of those
are of type user okay that makes sense a
user is the sender a user is the
recipient and then there is a message
cool complete the send the can send
message function
okay
it should only return true if the sender
and recipient Fields each contain a name
and a number if any of the default zero
values are present return false instead
Okay cool so can send message this is
essentially a function that's going to
validate a message to send to see if it
actually has data inside of it so
if I run the code right now
it's always returning true right so you
have an appointment tomorrow you have an
event tomorrow
I'm Susie Saul ah see there's a phone
number missing there that's a problem
looks like there's a phone number
missing there that's a problem okay
let's see so
sender and recipients contain a name and
a number so if m
to send
Dot
sender enter
name whatever dot name is
empty
and false
right
and then if Ms dot is going to be
recipient
is empty also return false so we're just
going to do some guard Clauses here
and then sender and recipient and now
we're interested in the number
number is an integer so if it's zero
cool so we're just basically doing a
very simple validation to make sure
um that names aren't blank and numbers
are not blank so let me run that
okay so this one has all the information
there and it's sent now this one has a
number missing can't send message that
looks correct
okay this is looking good to me
all right next up we have Anonymous
structs so Anonymous trucks are just
struct instances that don't have a name
so whenever you create a new Anonymous
struct and go you're you're immediately
instantiating a struct of a given type
right the type of the struct doesn't
have a name so for example here we have
a struct
with a make and a model now in the
exercise previously remember we actually
had this same exact struct but we'd
given it a name the name was car right
here we haven't created a new struct
definition we haven't created a new
struck definition called car instead
we're immediately instantiating a new
instance of a struct called my car this
could be named anything right and it
just has a make and a model field on it
so the only reason you would use an
anonymous struct is if you have no
reason to create more than one instance
of the struct so to be clear about
what's happening here we're creating a
new variable called my car
and it has two Fields it's a struct with
two Fields make and model and we're
immediately giving it a value of make
Tesla Model 3.
and this type this specific struct type
doesn't exist anywhere else within our
program this is kind of a type that's
just unique to this one instance called
my car it's not very common that you'll
see kind of top level Anonymous structs
like this more often you'll see nested
Anonymous structs right so rather than
creating wheel as a separate struct type
we've just said well Wheels kind of
always exist within cars I know that's
not really true but maybe within our
program it's true so we just create a
little Anonymous struct within the
greater car struct now as far as best
practices in writing clean code my
opinion is that you should generally
favor named structs you avoid Anonymous
trucks unless you have a really good
reason to use them you'll really never
go wrong with naming your structs okay
so the question on this assignment is
what is a good reason to use an
anonymous struct you're worried about
security you need your code to be faster
you're worried about user privacy or it
is only being used once
well the only thing even remotely
related to how Anonymous trucks work
um is that it's only being used once so
if you're certain that you only want
this type to be used one time maybe you
don't want someone accidentally reusing
a type
then you might want to use an anonymous
struct
next question is what's one advantage of
using an anonymous struct anonymous
trucks make your code run faster
Anonymous drugs prevent you from reusing
a struck definition you never intended
to reuse or Anonymous trucks can be
compiled more quickly it's this reuse
one one place that I have used Anonymous
kind of top level structs from time to
time is in HTTP handlers so if I know
that a given HTTP endpoint will always
return a specific Json payload then I'll
use an anonymous struct to define the
shape of that Json payload we haven't
really talked about Json in go yet but
kind of spoiler alert structs are how we
structure Json data typically
next we have embedded structs and
embedded structs are not the same thing
as nested structs an embedded struct is
basically where we take all the fields
from one struct and kind of shove them
into another one let me show you what I
mean so here's our car struct that we've
been using for our examples um it's got
to make in a model great here's our
truck struct now you'll notice we've
embedded the car type here but the car
is missing kind of a name a key in the
truck struct the bed size is the key ENT
is the type here we just have the type
which is car
so what does this do and how does it
differ from a nested struct well in the
embedded struct if we want to access the
field model from a an instance of a
truck rather than doing truck dot car
dot model we would just do truck dot
model because these fields of the car
type are becoming kind of top level
fields of the truck type we're
inheriting all of those fields from the
car type now I have to be careful with
the word inherit even though it is kind
of a pretty good descriptive term for
what's happening go is not an
object-oriented language because it
doesn't support classes or inheritance
in the class-based sense so if you're
familiar with the idea of object
oriented programming just know that
classes and inheritance aren't really
what's going on here this is you can
almost just think of this as a shorthand
for kind of retyping this make and model
into the truck struct it's it's almost
just a syntactic sugar so that we don't
have to retype all of these fields so
let's take a look at some code and how
we would use this truck struct so I've
created this new instance of a truck
called it Lanes truck has a bed size
which is an integer right and it has a
car
here now you might look at that and say
that looks an awful lot like a nested
struct and the Syntax for creating a new
instance of an embedded struct is very
similar to the Syntax for a nested
struct essentially the key is just the
same name as the type this is kind of a
quirky thing about
um composite literals the embedded stuff
looks like the nested stuff however when
we're accessing the individual fields on
um Lane's truck using the dot operator
you'll see they're all accessed at the
top level it's not Lane's truck dot
car.make it's lanestruck. make right
it's not
lanestruck.car.model it's just Lane's
truck dot model so those fields are
being brought up
into the top level it's just when we
kind of instantiate the truck the first
time that we need to do this sort of
nested syntax so let's hop into the
assignment it says at textio a user
which is a struct represents an account
holder an Ascender is just a user with
some additional sender specific data a
sender is a user that has a rate limit
field that tells us how many messages
they are allowed to send fix the system
by using an embedded struct as expected
by the test code okay so let's go ahead
and take a look at the test code
so it looks like the test code is
creating some senders
and it's expecting that a sender
has a rate limit and that it has a user
right and this is looking like an
embedded struct
and up here you can see s is a sender
and we're directly accessing name number
and rate limit all the top level
so I think all I need to do here is
embed the user struct in fact let's run
this without without that see what
happens yep we're getting some undefined
fields
we'll embed the user type in there
and that's looking pretty good to me
I will mention just to give you an idea
of like when you use this in the real
world one place that I use it actively
on boot Dev is users have kind of public
fields on boot Dev and private Fields so
public fields are stuff that we show on
the leaderboard things that kind of
anyone can see about your profile maybe
your bio or your profile picture but
users also have private Fields things
like your hashed password right the
password we store in the database and
I've actually embedded
the private Fields within the public
user so that I can easily nullify them
when I don't want to send private data
to a given web page
all right let's go ahead and run this
code
let's talk about methods on structs or
just methods in general in go
um I know I told you go is not objects
oriented and it's not but if you squint
really hard structs in go kind of look
like classes in a language like Java
JavaScript or python so methods in go
are just Behavior or functions that we
can Define on a type and more often than
not we end up defining methods on
structs although we could Define methods
on any type so let's take a look at the
Syntax for this so here we have a simple
rectangle struct it has a width and a
height right and here we've defined an
area method on the rectangle struct so
this is just a function right we're
familiar with functions already the only
difference is that we've added this
special parameter before the name of the
function
which is again just a parameter that
comes into the function just it's just a
special parameter in in this case it is
of type rect which is just a struct and
we've named it r
and then this function just returns r
dot width times r dot height right so it
Returns the area of the rectangle so why
would we use a method on a struct well
there are reasons that we'll get to
later when we talk about interfaces
um but for now it's mostly a syntactic
thing a syntactic sugar thing if we have
behavior that we want to Define on a
given type then structs can be a really
good choice they give us this nice
syntactic sugar right we create this new
rectangle called R and now we can just
call r dot area to get the area of the
rectangle it a nice way to do computed
properties on a type right so we could
have stored area as a separate number
within the rect struct
the problem with that is now we lose
kind of a single source of Truth when it
comes to the area right if we store the
area as say 50 and the width and height
is 5 and 10 but then we update the
height and forget to update the area
right now we have a bug in our code so
this is a great way to kind of have a
one-line accessor to get the area of a
rectangle but we don't have to actually
store that area in our struct as kind of
duplicate data so let's get down to the
assignment it says let's clean up
textio's authentication logic we store
our users authentication data inside an
authentication info struct okay so
that's here it's got a username and a
password we need a method that can take
that data and return a basic
authorization string the format of the
string should be authorization basic
username colon password right so this is
the kind of standard basic authorization
that's used in HTTP requests
the assignment says create a method on
authentication info called get basic
auth that Returns the formatted string
okay cool
so let's create a new
a new method and we can kind of
reference this syntax over here so it's
func and we want the receiver to be an
authentication info struct so I'll just
call it AI who that's that's actually
confusing let's do auth auth I
authentication info
and we wanted the name of the method to
be called get basic auth
and it returns a string
okay and then we want to return this
format here
so if you remember we can use the format
package to do that so we'll return
fmt.sprintf
remember s print F Returns the string
rather than printing it to standard out
over to the console and we'll use
that template
username and password are both just
strings so we'll use percent s for our
formatting verbs and then we can do auth
I Dot
username first
and auth I dot password
next okay cool that looks correct to me
let's run it
perfect
let's talk about interfaces so an
interface in go is just a collection of
method signatures for example take a
look at this shape interface so we have
an interface it's named shape and it
specifies two different method
signatures so area is a method that
takes no parameters and returns a
float64. perimeter is another method
that takes no parameters and returns a
float64. now any type that implements
both of these methods and and matches
their method signatures will implement
the shape interface which really just
means that we can think of it and treat
it as a shape so for example let's take
a look at this rectangle struct so erect
has a width and a height both of which
are float 64s and again this is just a
this is just a kind of standard struct
and it has two methods on it uh one is
the area method it takes no parameters
returns a float64 one is the perimeter
that takes no parameters and returns a
flow 64. and because a rectangle
implements both of these methods we can
think of a rectangle as a shape a shape
is just anything where we can kind of
calculate its area and calculate its
perimeter and multiple types can
implement the same interface so for
example this circle struct it has a
different underlying data right rather
than a width and a height we can
represent a circle with just a radius
but to calculate its area and its
perimeter the calculation is a little
bit different right we're using pi for
example but the method signature is
identical right we don't pass anything
in because we have all the data we need
on the circle struct and we just return
a float64. so both circles and
rectangles because they implement the
required methods can be thought of as
shapes or we could say they implement
the shape interface let's get into the
assignment I think it'll all start to
make a little more sense so the
assignment says the birthday message and
sending report structs have already
implemented the get message method
so let's take a look at that so birthday
message is destruct here sending report
is destruct here they both have this get
message method that returns a string
and they're just it looks like the
strings that they return are just a
little bit different right the birthday
messages get message uh function returns
this like hi blank it is your birthday
on blank and ascending report says your
blank report is ready right so they're
just they just formatted a little a
little differently
okay so Simon Says first add the get
message method as a requirement on the
method interface okay so we need to
finish the message interface
and add a get message method
that returns a string
Okay cool so now this message interface
because birthday message and sending
report both implement this method we can
think of both of those as messages next
it says complete the send message
function it should print a messages
message which it obtains through the
interface method Okay cool so the a
message is an interface so inside of the
send message function we don't actually
know if we're dealing with say a
birthday message or sending report we
just know that we have access to a
message so really the only thing we can
do with it is call get message
which we know will return a string and
it says it should print a message so
we'll do fmt.printline
just print out the message
cool
okay now this is powerful right let's go
take a look at how this code is actually
called so we have this test function
that also just takes a method a message
and it sends that message right it's
just calling our send message function
here
but down here and this is where it's
most interesting the test function is
not past like
interface literals that's not even like
a real thing right an interface is like
abstract type that represents other
types instead because the test function
takes an interface we can pass into it
any struct that implements that
interface so for example here on line 42
we're passing an ascending report and
then on line 46 we're passing in a
birthday message those are two different
types in a strongly typed language being
passed in as the first parameter to a
single function but the reason it works
is because we're using interfaces
okay let's go ahead and run this see
what happens
your first report report is ready you've
sent 10 messages hi John Doe it is your
birthday
this looks great this looks great to me
in go interfaces are implemented
implicitly and what that means is when
we have a type like in our last example
we had the rectangle type that
implemented the shape interface we never
had to explicitly write anywhere on the
rectangle struct that it was intended to
implement the shape interface because it
satisfied all the requirements of the
shape interface it just kind of
automatically implemented it and that's
fairly unique to go in a language like
Java we might have to write something
like this
um we can take a look at this little
example here we've got this employee
interface and a contractor struct if we
wanted the contractor to implement the
employee we would need it to still
fulfill the interface right by
implementing all the methods but we
might need to also explicitly type
something like implements
employee
right we'd explicitly say that we intend
to implement that interface in go it's
done automatically let's hop into the
assignment it says at textio we have
full-time employees and contract
employees we've been tasked with making
a more General employee interface so
that dealing with different employee
types is a little simpler add the
missing get salary method to the
contractor type so that it fulfills the
employee interface Okay cool so we have
the employee interface we have the
contractor struct
and if we look at the full-time struct
it looks like it already implements
the employee interface so we just need
to add the Missing Method because right
now a contractor has a get name but does
not have a get salary okay cool
let's go ahead and do that we'll do
employee
get salary it returns an INT
and a contractor's salary is their
hourly pay multiplied by how many hours
they work per year
okay so be something like
C Dot
hourly pay multiplied by C DOT hours
here
okay and just because I'm curious I want
to go look at how a full-time salary uh
employee works yeah so you can see the
the way that a full-time employee their
salary is calculated is is totally
different like their their salary is
actually just stored probably because
the way we think of full-time employees
is like you know you make sixty thousand
dollars a year you make seventy thousand
dollars a year whereas contractors often
get paid by the hour so it makes sense
that they have a different calculation
and then down here in the test Suite
um this looks very similar to the last
assignment where the test function is
able to take as inputs any type of
employee right so we can pass in both
full-time and contractors here let's go
ahead and run that
Jack Bob and Jill we can see all of
their salaries even though
Jack is full-time and Bob and Jill are
both contractors so that looks good to
me
in go types Implement interfaces
implicitly because it kind of decouples
the definition of the interface from the
definition of the type the type doesn't
even really need to know that it
implements a certain interface and
that's really really cool because it
means it's easy for a type to interfa to
implement lots of different interfaces
so the quiz question here is how is an
interface fulfilled
answers are a type has all the required
interfaces methods defined on it or a
struct embeds the interface in its
definition and the answer is going to be
it has all the methods defined the next
question is can a Type fulfill multiple
interfaces or Implement multiple
interfaces and yes why not another quiz
question go uses the blank keyword to
show that a type implements an interface
and the answers are fulfills implements
inherits and there is no keyword in go
and the answer is that there is no
keyword in go interfaces are implemented
implicitly
in the next question it says in the
example given the blank type implements
the blank interface let's take a look
so example here we've got the shape
interface Circle struct
Ural has an area method so it looks like
the circle type implements the shape
interface like we talked about before a
type can Implement multiple interfaces
it just needs to have all the methods
for all the different interfaces for
example the empty interface so that's
this this definition right here this is
an interface with no methods required
is actually always implemented by every
single type in the go programming
language now it's often not a very
useful interface because you can't
really do anything with an empty
interface you have no methods to call
let's jump down into the assignment it
says add the required method so that the
email type implements both the expense
and printer interfaces Okay cool so
we've got these expense and printer
interfaces
two different methods we need to
implement
and we have this email type with an is
subscribe Boolean and body string cool
all right cost method
if the email is not subscribed so if not
e dot is subscribed I believe is what
the field was
then the cost is 0.05 times
uh the length
for each character in the body so the
length e dot body now remember go is
strongly typed and we can't multiply an
INT by a float directly so we need to
cast this integer sorry I think I
highlighted those backwards
the length of the body is an integer
this is a float so we need to cast
the length of the body to a float so we
can we can multiply a float by float
um otherwise we'll return
uh it's a 0.01
times that same thing the length of the
body
cool uh the print function should just
print to standard out the email's body
text easy enough
print line e dot body
okay
so now our email struct implements both
of these interfaces and if we come down
here to look at the test function
this is interesting the test function
takes an expense and a printer
right so we can use both of those
methods there
and actually the email struct so we're
creating instances of emails here we're
actually passing it into test as both
the expense and the printer right
because it makes sense it implements
both cool let me run that
oh what did I screw up 0.05 times float
64 length value of type 64 is not used
to
let's see
0.05 times 64 length of e dot body what
did I screw up value of type float64 is
not used
I forgot my return
cool let's try that again
Okay so
switching with cost 11 cents hello there
printing with cost one dollar I want my
money back yeah that looks that looks
pretty good
let's submit it
up until this point we haven't really
been naming the arguments of our
interfaces method signatures
um but we totally could so if we take a
look at this this is The copier
interface it's a copy method that it
requires which takes two strings and
returns an INT the interesting thing is
when you look at this method signature
it's kind of hard to tell what the
intention behind the interface is it's
like great it takes two strings but what
are those strings supposed to represent
right so here we can take a look at what
I would consider a better interface
definition where The copier interface
actually has a copy method that
specifies the source file is kind of the
name of the first parameter and the
destination file is the name of the
second parameter and it bytes copied is
the integer that's returned so you know
the functionality here is identical but
now we have much better I I mean I would
consider it documentation of what the
intention behind this interface is
so the question is are you required to
name the arguments of an interface in
order for your code to compile properly
uh no no it'll work fine either way next
question is why would you name your
interface's methods parameters right
like we don't need to why would we do it
execution speed memory savings or
readability and Clarity uh it's going to
be for readability and Clarity type
assertions so type assertions are
something you'll see every once in a
while I would argue they're probably not
super common but you will come across
them and the whole purpose of a type
assertion is so that you can take an
interface and kind of cast it back into
its underlying type so in this code
sample here we can kind of assume that s
is an instance of a shape interface and
at this point in the code because it's
just an interface we don't know
necessarily if it's a circle or maybe a
square or maybe some other type so what
we do is we do a type assertion to cast
it to the circle struct and basically
what what happens here is on the left
hand side of the um this short
declaration operator here we get back
the instance of the circle so this is
going to be an instance of the circle
struct again the underlying struct
behind the shape interface
if it was a circle right because we
can't be sure if we had a shape we're
not sure if it was a circle or maybe
something else but this okay variable
this is going to be a Boolean and if
it's true then it was a circle and we
should have a valid kind of filled out
Circle struct if okay is false then we
kind of have to discard the circle
um because we weren't able to parse out
um the shape as a circle because it
wasn't a circle
so let's move on to the assignment it's
an email then it should return the
emails to address and the cost of the
email if the expense is an SMS then it
should return the sms's phone number and
cost if the expense is any other
underlying type just return an empty
string and a 0.0 for the cost Okay cool
so we've got this get expense report it
takes an expense as input and my guess
is yep expense is this interface so our
job is to kind of try to cast it into
the potential underlying types email and
SMS
so
first we do
email okay
expense Dot and we'll cast it to an
email type
if okay
so if it's an email return the emails to
address so it's going to return email
dot to address
as that string there
and
also it's cost so email dot looks like
cost is a method
email.cost okay
next we can do s okay
e dot cast on SMS so if it's an SMS we
can return
sms's to phone number to phone number
and the
sms.cost I believe that's also just yep
just a method
okay it says otherwise if it has a
different underlying type return empty
string
and 0.0 for the cost
okay cool that feels
at least like we followed the
instructions let's see what we get
not enough arguments in call to SMS dot
cost let's take a look at sms.cast
hmm
have want
what did I screw up here
ah it should be s dot cost I named I
named The Struck the struct S all right
let's try that again
report the email going to John Doe will
cost
11 email the sms okay cool and invalid
expense perfect
I mean that feels right I can come down
here and check the test Suite yeah
invalid okay cool let's submit that
when we want to do a lot of successive
type assertions in a row there's
actually a better way and that's with
type switches so here's a Syntax for a
type switch basically we have an
interface and we cast it
at the very top of the switch and then
we can actually check and kind of
pattern match against different possible
types
if none of the types that we've
specified are the matching underlying
type then it will kind of fall down to
the default case so let's write some
code and see how it works um down in the
assignment it says after submitting our
last snippet of code for review a more
experienced gopher or term for a go
developer told us to use a type switch
instead of successive assertions let's
make that Improvement implement the get
expense report function using a type
switch
Okay cool so kind of the same thing
though if it's an email we'll return a
to address and a cost if it's an SMS
then we should return a phone number to
cost blah blah blah right the difference
is we're going to use a different syntax
this time okay so we're going to be
using this switch syntax
so switch
value colon equals e DOT type
okay Open brackets case we are
interested in if the expense is an email
so case email now the interesting thing
is with now within this case block V is
an email so I can treat it like an email
so I can do return V Dot
oh what was it two address I think yeah
new address
B dot cost
Ace SMS
return V Dot to phone number I think it
was two phone number
B dot cost
and default
return
uh I think it was empty string just zero
values right empty string and 0.0
okay cool let's see what happens
with that oh am I forgetting nope I've
got
oh I'm indenting a little weird
there we go let's run that
cool BMS SMS is going to be is going to
this number with this cost
got some emails and costs okay that's
looking good to me now that we've
learned what interfaces are and how we
use them let's talk about how we can use
them more effective and in a sort of
idiomatic and clean way if you forget
all of the other advice that we're going
to go over when it comes to writing
cleaning interfaces don't forget this
one and that is to keep interfaces as
small as you can the best the cleanest
and the most useful interfaces typically
just have one or two methods defined on
them imagine a simple Stringer interface
it has one method defined on it called
string that simply returns a string you
can take that interface and implement it
on basically any type and now you have a
super useful interface for logging out
string representations of different
types there isn't a hard and fast rule
about exactly how many methods you
should be defining on your interfaces
but what you really should be doing is
looking for kind of the minimal Behavior
necessary to accurately represent an
idea or concept right so for example
here's a slightly larger interface from
the standard Library again normally
we'll see interfaces in the standard
library with maybe just one or two or
three methods this one has five but this
is kind of still the minimum amount or
or the the minimal necessary behavior
that we need to describe a file like a
file in your file system right we need a
way to close the file we need a way to
read it we need a way to seek to
individual uh kind of sections of the
file
so this is an example of a slightly
larger interface right I would say five
methods is definitely a on the larger
end but it's still a good interface
because it's using as as little Behavior
as it possibly can to describe an
operating system file so the question
that goes along with this is interfaces
should have as blank methods as possible
and the answers are complex few and many
and the answer is going to be few the
next mistake that I've seen new go
developers make is when they write an
interface that sort of knows about the
types that they've intended to satisfy
it so for example if you have a car
interface and you've defined an is fire
truck method on the car interface that
returns a pool you know whether or not
it's a fire truck that's probably a
mistake you would actually just want to
use a type assertion or a type switch if
you really needed to figure out the
underlying type you should not make your
interfaces aware of the underlying types
this also breaks rule number one right
because rule number one we don't need to
know if a car is a fire truck for like
the minimal behavior of a car I mean you
can see how this sort of design pattern
would get out of hand very quickly
because we might need to also Define
other booleans like is pickup is sedan
is tank right if you start catering to
all of the underlying types of a given
interface your interface is going to be
really bloated and become very very
large so the question here is actually
the reverse it says it's okay for types
to be aware of the interfaces that they
satisfy if it were flipped around the
answer would definitely be false but
because we're talking about the types
being aware of the interfaces they
satisfy I don't think that's necessarily
a problem they don't need to be aware of
them right because again in go
interfaces are satisfied implicitly but
I would argue to some extent they are
aware of them because the developer had
to go in some cases out of their way to
satisfy the implementation of an
interface so I'm going to go with true
on this one so now this is the reverse
question it says it's okay for
interfaces to be aware of the types that
satisfy them no they should not be aware
finally I just want to talk about how
interfaces are not classes sometimes
this can get mixed up especially if
you're coming from an object-oriented
background interfaces are just a very
different idea interfaces are not
classes they are much Slimmer classes
have a lot of functionality going on
inheritance is a fairly complex topic
interfaces are honestly just a simpler
idea interfaces don't have Constructors
or deconstructors that require the data
is created or destroyed right so that's
another way that they differ from
classes that have kind of this inherent
setup and tear down situation
interfaces are not hierarchical right
there's there's no hierarchical
inheritance tree when it comes to
interfaces and the most interesting one
is that interfaces defined function
signatures but not underlying Behavior
right so this is actually a big
difference between interfaces and
classes in a class A Child class can
inherit behavior from a parent class
which can kind of dry up your code right
don't repeat yourself in go that's not
the case at all an interface doesn't dry
up your code you still have to go
Implement all of the methods on all of
the different types individually
interfaces just allow us to use all of
those types kind of in the same places
later in this course we'll get to talk
about generics which is a way to kind of
dry up your code and funny enough kind
of uses interfaces under the hood or
kind of as a part of the generics system
to make that happen
so finally the question is interfaces
allow you to define a method's behavior
once and use it for many different types
that's false go has a very unique way of
handling errors really quickly let's
review how JavaScript handles errors and
the way JavaScript handles errors is
very similar to python or Java it uses a
try catch Paradigm and let's contrast
that with how go handles errors in its
sort of unique way let's pretend that we
have a function called get user and
we'll start with JavaScript so we have a
function called get user whoa
and it returns a user so we'll do const
user equals get user and we have to wrap
the get user function the call to the
get user function in a try block because
we know that the get user function can
throw because let's just say for example
maybe the user doesn't exist Okay cool
so if something goes wrong we add a
catch block and if this function throws
execution will stop we'll enter the
catch block and do whatever's in here
for now we can just console.log
the error now let's take a look at what
this function looks like in go
we'd do something like this we do user
error colon equals get user
if error does not equal nil
then we could print out the error and
return so that we don't continue and
then down here we could you know deal
with the user object so use user here
and for consistency sake we could say
use user here after the user object is
created in JavaScript okay so what's the
difference well let's talk about the
first reason why I prefer goes error
handling to JavaScript error handling
let's pretend we need to go get some
data for the user after we've already
kind of retrieved the user successfully
so let's say we need to go get the
user's profile picture well in go all we
would do
is call the next dangerous function
let's say get user Pro profile and maybe
it takes a user dot ID as input right so
we need to successfully wait for the
user to come back and then we can go
fetch its profile
all right so this looks very similar
we're
doing another dangerous function get
user profile and it returns a profile
and an error if an error with the
profile occurs again we'll just kind of
print out the error in return otherwise
now we have a profile object okay what
would we do in JavaScript well in
JavaScript we can't just take this try
catch and paste it down here and update
some stuff this will not work if we do
get user profile user dot ID
profile
the problem with this code is that user
is only available within this try Block
it's scoped to the try block right so
this user object here will be undefined
so the normal thing to do in JavaScript
would just be to take this line here
and inject it within
the try block
the original try block right so now I'm
doing my second dangerous function after
I do my first dangerous function the
reason I don't like this is that the
logic for handling the errors is now all
in one place if I want to handle the
error for the get user profile function
differently or separately that I want to
handle the error from the get user
function I have to actually Nest the
whole try catch
like this
right so now user.id is accessible
because I'm in the same try block but I
get a second catch block so we kind of
get this nasty nesting if we want to
treat each individual error separately
and this kind of brings us to the second
reason why I prefer goes error handling
and it's that it forces us to think
about each individual error that's
passed back from a dangerous function so
again in JavaScript kind of the normal
thing to do unless you really needed
separate error handling would be to just
kind of do all of your dangerous stuff
in one large try block the problem with
this in my opinion is that it kind of it
doesn't encourage me to remember which
of these functions is dangerous in the
first place for example maybe this is a
safe function and this is a dangerous
function that can potentially throw in
error but looking at this code from kind
of a calling perspective I don't really
know that that's the case whereas in go
because a function returns kind of the
valid data and the error with every
function call I know for a fact that the
get user profile function can throw an
error because it returns an error value
this will probably make more sense if I
actually write out some of these
functions so in JavaScript the get user
function might look just like this
function get user
uh we could say uh do some get user
logic here
and then maybe it returns you know a
user
looking at the function signature
all I can tell in JavaScript is that
this function takes no arguments and the
only way for me to know what it returns
is to go find that return statement see
oh okay it returns a user however in go
I actually get two super helpful things
in the function signature and remember
the function signature is just kind of
that first line of a function definition
so in go if I were to write the function
definition for the get user function
would be something like this funk
get user
doesn't take any inputs but it returns a
let's say a user struct
and an error
right and then we have some kind of
do get user logic here
right so now just by looking at this
function signature I can tell that it
returns a user and that it could
possibly return an error as well that I
need to go handle whereas again in
JavaScript not only do I not get to see
in the function signature what is
potentially returned but I also don't
know that this function can throw I have
to kind of go digging deeper into the
function definition to see if there's
potentially something uh dangerous going
on in the meat of the function so again
to reiterate because this is actually a
super important point when you're
learning about how errors are handled in
go the primary reason I like error
handling in go is that it forces me as I
write my code to be kind of hyper aware
of every potential error and make sure
that I write code that handles it so now
that we understand what error handling
in go kind of looks like from a high
level let's dive into the details errors
in go are just values and specifically
they're just interfaces so the built-in
error interface is an interface with a
single method the error method and that
method returns a string describing what
went wrong so how do we actually go
about handling errors in code well let's
take a look at this function right here
so this is a function in the standard
Library it's called ASCII to integer it
takes a string and attempts to convert
it into an integer value and potentially
that can be problematic right because
you can write strings that aren't
numbers under the hood Okay cool so what
do we do we get back an integer and an
error and in essence it's it's really
simple the error
is either nil or it's not nil if it is
nil that means everything went fine and
nothing went wrong so if the error is
nil it means there is no kind of string
representing what went wrong because
nothing went wrong however if the error
is not nil that means something did go
wrong right so if the error is not nil
in this case then we'll print an error
message and return from the function
right so we're basically writing guard
Clauses that say something went wrong
let's handle this error and get out of
here right enough talk let's write some
code so you can see what I mean
let me expand this so it's a little
easier to see the code okay the
assignment says we offer a product that
allows businesses that use textio to
send pairs of messages to couples it's
mostly used by flower shops and movie
theaters okay great complete the send
SMS to couple function so that's this
function here it should send two
messages first to the customer and then
to the customer's spouse so use send SMS
to send the message to customer if an
error is encountered returns 0.0 and the
error uh do the same for message to
spouse if both messages are sent
successfully return the total cost of
the messages added together okay I think
I understand what's going on so we're
basically going to send both of these
messages one after the other
um if any errors happen we kind of abort
early and return the error
okay so uh send SMS takes a message's
input so first we'll say uh send
SMS and we'll send the message to the
customer
and send SMS returns a float64 on air so
we'll say I think it's the cost
return the total cost okay yeah so cost
error
send SMS all right if error does not
equal nil so if there was a problem
sending the SMS
uh returns 0.0 in the error so return
0.0
right because this function send SMS to
couple Returns the total cost and an
error so we're saying if we failed to
send the SMS then it costs nothing and
we'll return the error that describes
what went wrong
otherwise we'll do it for the message to
spouse so we kind of are just going to
do this exact same thing so I'm going to
say cost for for let's say customer
cost for spouse
and we'll be sending the message to the
spouse
cool
all right now if we get to the bottom of
the function that means nothing went
wrong so we can return
cost for customer
Plus
for spouse
and nil
right because we get down here nothing
went wrong so we don't have an error to
return okay let's go ahead and run this
code and see what we get
and I want to just scroll down and take
a look at some of these test cases
okay message for customer thanks for
coming into our flower shop message for
spouse we hope you enjoyed your gift
error can't send texts over 25
characters Okay cool so I mean if we
look at the send SMS function it
actually throws an error or I shouldn't
say throws because we don't throw in go
right but returns an error value that
says can't send text over blank
characters
so that looks correct to me
um here we've got message to customer
message to spouse total cost
okay this is looking pretty good to me
I'm going to go ahead and submit that we
talked about how error handling in go is
all built around the error interface in
fact let's just review that really
quickly this error interface is really
just an interface that wraps a method
returning a string because if you think
about it at the end of the day an error
is just a kind of nullable string either
it's a string representing what went
wrong or saying what went wrong or it's
nothing because nothing went wrong so
being good at handling errors in go has
a lot to do with being good at
formatting strings or formatting useful
error messages so let's review how we
format strings and go most formatting go
is built around kind of these formatting
verbs that are defined in the format
package the fmt package of the standard
Library so for example the S printf
function returns a string where it
interpolates the values passed into the
function after the formatting string
into the formatting stream string where
where where the verbs exist so for
example this first percent V is replaced
with name the second percent V is
replaced with age
percent V is the verb we use for sort of
the default format right if you format
an integer using percent V then it kind
of just prints the integer in string
form but there are other ways that we
can format stuff for example the percent
F verb is used to format floats and you
can actually specify how many decimal
places you want to show up in your
output string by kind of prefixing the F
portion with a 0.2 for two decimal
places or say a point one for a single
decimal place so let's jump right into
the coding assignment
assignment says we need better error
logs for our backend developers to help
them debug their code complete the get
SMS error string functions that's this
one right here it should return a string
with this format
Okay cool so I'm just going to jump
right ahead
so it should return
fmt.s printf right because we're trying
to format a string
this format let me expand that a little
bit
okay so turn a string with that format
cost is the cost of the SMS so I'm going
to replace cost here with the cost
formatted to two decimal places so
percent point two F right for two
decimal places and replace recipient
with the stringified representation of
the recipient's phone number which is
the string here
so percent V it's important to point out
I could also use S here to format a
string but V and S do the same thing
effectively when you're working with
strings
and
then we need to pass in as parameters
the values that we want to format or
that we want to interpolate into the
string so it's going to be cost and
recipient
I'm going to dedent that because that is
some crazy formatting
okay that looks better
all right SMS that costs percent 0.2 F
to be sent to percent V this looks good
to me all right I'm gonna go ahead and
run that and see what we get
ah right can't forget to
import the formatting package
let's run that
okay SMS the costs 0.4 1.40 to be sent
to the string cannot be sent
awesome this looks correct to me I'm
going to go ahead and submit that
let's talk about building our own custom
error types so remember the error
interface is an interface in fact let me
jump back and show you what it looks
like again so it's just this interface
here and because it's an interface that
means we can build our own types like
this user error struct here that
Implement that interface which means
they can be used as errors and remember
that the error interface just has one
single method that we need to Define
right the error method that returns a
string and as long as we have that then
our type can be used as an error so for
example we could create this user error
type that stores a name
and then we can use it as an error to
format an error message that contains
the name of the user's account who had
an error so for example in this snippet
here we have a send SMS function and if
we're not able to send a message to a
user we can actually just return that
user error struct with the user's name
and again that is an error we can return
that struct as an error type because it
implements the error interface the
caller of this function would then just
treat it like any other error the reason
this is useful is that we can store
structured data within our errors so if
we want to format them a specific way we
have access to sort of dynamic data like
a name let's write some code that uses
this concept so the assignment says our
users are frequently trying to run
custom analytics queries on their
message deliverability metrics right so
we're sending lots of messages we want
to know are these messages getting
delivered
they end up writing a bad query that
tries to divide a number by zero it's
become such a problem that we think it
would best to make a specific type of
error for dividing by zero update the
code so that the Divide error type so
that's this error type here or rather
this struct here
implements the error interface its error
method should return a string formatted
and falling way cannot divide dividend
by zero okay let's write that method so
it's going to be
a function on the Divide error type so
I'm going to name it d e which is a
a divide error
and the name of the function must be
error takes no arguments and returns a
string right so that's that's the
function signature we need to use to
implement the error interface and then
we're going to return a string
and we're going to need to format the
string so we'll use S printf
the format package is already imported
and this is our template
and dividend in this case is a float 64.
and
you it says here dividend is the actual
dividend use the percent V verb so
percent V okay so we're just going to
kind of do the default formatting for a
float64.
and
let me indent all this so that it's kind
of readable
or dividend is the actual dividend of
the Divide error okay so we'll do d e
Dot
dividend
that will interpolate there
okay that looks correct to me I think
we've implemented the error interface
properly let's go ahead and run that
oh I forgot my comma
um this is kind of an interesting Quirk
of the go programming language
um if you add a new line after the last
parameter to a function you have to put
a comma so this would work
all right and
this would work
but this does not work right that's what
I did the first time so just kind of
something to watch out for
okay so let's take a look at this um
dividing ten by zero cannot divide 10 by
0 dividing ten by two quotient 5
dividing 15 by 30. five okay this is
looking like it formatted properly let's
submit that so we've got a quiz question
it says what is the underlying type of
an error is it an interface is it a
struct is it a string
well it could technically be a structure
a string right like we saw in the last
uh the last assignment but the most
correct thing would be to say an
interface because it must always be an
interface right it must always implement
the error interface it could also be a
structure a string but it will always be
an interface next question is can a Type
be an error and also fulfill another
interface
well errors are just interfaces and we
know that types can fulfill any number
of interfaces as long as they have all
of the required methods so yeah there's
no problem with this let's talk about
the errors package so the standard
library and go has an errors package
that exposes a few useful
functionalities but the one we're most
interested in right now is the
errors.new function so the useful thing
about the errors.new function is allows
us to create a new error from just a
string so we don't need to kind of you
know Define a new struct or a new type
and then have it explicitly implement
the error interface that can be a lot of
code if all we want to do is kind of
return an error with a very specific
string let's go ahead and use it the
assign is twilio 's software Architects
may have over complicated the
requirements from the last coding
assignment yeah all we needed was a new
generic error message that Returns the
string no dividing by zero when a user
attempts to get us to perform the taboo
right the taboo of dividing something by
zero complete the divide function use
the errors.new function to create an
error when y equals zero that reads no
divided by zero okay so this is pretty
straightforward basically if Y is 0
which means that the the number that we
divide by would be zero which is
obviously a huge problem in mathematics
you're not allowed to do that in go or
most programming languages that I'm
aware of so we need to return an error
here so that this operation never
happens so we'll return errors.new
looks like the errors package is already
imported for us and we just need to
return an error
that says no dividing by zero
okay let's go ahead and run that and see
what we get
oh I screwed up
this function returns a float64 and an
error so we should return a zero value
for that first value when we're
returning a non-nil error let's go ahead
and run that
cool dividing 10 by 0 no dividing by
zero
all of this looks good to me let's talk
about loops in go so if you are familiar
with Loops in other languages loops and
ghosts and tactically are very similar
to say Loops in JavaScript the main
difference is just that we don't use the
parentheses around uh kind of the the
signature of the for Loop
um which again is very similar to how if
statements in go work we're basically
just dropping those uh parentheses
syntactically
um the initial portion runs at the
beginning so for example in this snippet
of code where We're looping over the
integers 0 through 9. in the initial
section we're just initializing a
variable I and setting it equal to zero
in the condition section we're checking
and making sure that I is less than 10.
so at the end of every uh kind of
iteration of the body which in this case
we're just printing I in the body we're
going to check and make sure that I is
less than 10. if it is we'll continue on
to the next iteration of the loop
otherwise we'll be done and then at the
end of every iteration we'll also be
running this after section so we'll be
incrementing I and that happens before
the condition is run so for example if
we increment I to 10 and then I is no
longer less than 10 we will not continue
on to the next iteration of loop which
is why this prints 0 through 9 and not 0
through 10. let's jump right into the
assignment it says at textio we have a
dynamic formula for determining how much
a batch of bulk messages cost to send so
we need to complete the bulk send
function it takes a number of messages
as input and returns a float64 which it
looks like will be the total cost of the
batch of messages okay each message
costs 1.0 plus an additional fee the fee
structure is so it's going to be first
message is 1.0 plus 0 so 0 is the fee
second message is 1.0 plus 0.01 third
message is 1.0 plus 0.02 okay cool and
then our job is to use a loop to
calculate the total cost of all of these
messages for you know the number number
of messages that we've been given
okay let's let's just start writing some
code so total cost I'm going to just
start it out at 0.0 and then we'll use a
loop where I colon equals zero to do
like num messages iterations so you know
a number of iterations equal to num
messages so start I at zero and then
we'll do I is less than
now messages
and I plus plus
okay so this kind of body of the for
Loop should execute num messages times
and we're going to want to add to the
total cost so plus equals and we're
going to use this formula so it's going
to be 1.0 Plus
this fee and how do we calculate that
fee well it looks to me like it is 0.01
times the basically the message number
right so for the first message at index
0 I equals 0 it's going to be a fee of
zero so if we just use I this should
work because if I is 0 and we multiply
that by .01 anything multiplied by zero
is zero right so we'd get 1.0 plus zero
for the second message I should be one
so we'll get 1 plus 0.01 because
anything multiplied by 1 is itself and
so on and so forth that's looking
correct to me
at the end of the function we'll just
return a total cost
cool let's run that
oh
untyped float constant truncated to int
okay so I is an INT and we cannot
multiply an INT by a float 64. so I'm
going to cast
um I to a float 64. let's try that again
and take a look at some of these numbers
Okay cool so the cost for 10 messages is
10.45 and that sounds about right
because each message costs one
plus this like fractional part that
grows over time so like the 10th message
would have cost like
0.10 and it would decrease over time
so that looks about right to me
50 messages
yep okay I'm going to go ahead and
submit that one interesting thing about
for Loops in go is that each section of
the for Loop the initial the condition
and the after are actually optional and
we can omit any of them so for example
if we omit the condition then the for
Loop will just run forever so let's see
why this might be useful um let's jump
into the assignment the assignment says
complete the max messages function given
a cost threshold it should calculate the
maximum number of messages that can be
sent and then it looks like the fees for
each message are going to be identical
to the last assignment so let's go ahead
and just get started so max messages we
have a threshold a cost threshold right
we want to see how many messages we can
send while keeping the total cost under
the threshold so I'm going to create a
total cost variable
and set it equal to 0.0
and then this is going to look really
similar to the last assignment but
basically we'll set I equal to 0 to
start
I'll skip the condition for now because
we don't know to what number we're kind
of looping up to right we're trying to
calculate that so I don't know where to
stop yet
um
but I do want to increment I with every
iteration of the loop
and then I basically want to update the
total cost by adding to it and use this
formula over here right so it's going to
be 1.0
Plus
0.01 times
I which I need to cast to a flow 64.
okay so that formula is looking again
identical last time now if I want to
return
the the maximum message that I can send
while keeping the cost under the
threshold and basically I need to check
and say if the total cost is greater
than the threshold
then I should return
I
does that sound right so for example
let's say that right off the bat
the threshold were I don't know say
negative one
right so I'm not allowed to send
anything I would want to in that case
return zero right because I can't send
any messages so what would happen we'd
enter the loop I'd calculate the total
cost for the first message which would
be 1.0 and then because the total cost
is already higher than threshold I would
return I which would be zero so that
works right
however if the threshold were a little
higher let's say the threshold were 1.5
then what would happen is we'd do that
comparison the total cost would be
less than the threshold so we'd continue
to the next Loop iteration of the loop
where I would be incremented to one
and then on that next iteration we'd go
over okay so this is looking good to me
let me go ahead and run this code
okay so with a threshold of 10
I can send nine messages without going
over the threshold
that sounds right
right
because I have like nine in some
fractional part
let's go ahead and submit it and see
most programming languages have support
for a while loop and really a while loop
is very similar to a for Loop except it
doesn't have that kind of initial and
after statement it it just runs until
some condition is no longer true now
because of this similarity the authors
of the go programming language decided
to not include an explicit while loop
with a while keyword instead the for
Loop is a while loop where just
basically both those side kind of
sections are omitted and we just have a
condition that follows the four keyword
so in other words if we have a four
keyword and then a single expression
then it is a condition
that while true will continue to kind of
run the body of the loop over and over
and over again until the condition stops
being true let's take a look at an
example here we have a variable called
plant right we start it equal to one and
we've done this outside of the for Loop
right and then within the for Loop we
just have one section where we're
comparing the variable plant height to
the number five
right and while it is less than five
we'll print this message and then at the
end of the loop we'll increment plant
height now you might notice this looks
just like a for Loop where we've
essentially taken the initial statement
and moved it up outside of the for Loop
body and we've taken the after statement
and moved it within the for Loop body
and that is what we've done right but
it's to demonstrate that this is valid
syntax let's jump right into the
assignment okay so the assignment says
we have an interesting new cost
structure for our SMS vendor so at
textio we have a vendor that we have to
pay to send text messages through right
so we're a software service that makes
sending text messages easy but we do
have to pay some kind of maybe Hardware
service that actually does the sending
of uh the text messages kind of over the
wireless network
okay
um they charge exponentially more money
for each consecutive test text we send
let's write a function that can
calculate how many messages we can send
in a given batch uh given a cost
multiplier and a Max cost in pennies
okay so given a cost multiplier and a
maximum cost our function will return
basically the number of messages that
we're allowed to send
um that's under that that Max cost so it
says in a nutshell the first message
costs one penny Okay actual cost and
penny starts at one and each message
after that first message uh costs the
same as the previous message multiplied
by the cost multiplier okay so that's
happening here
um it gets expensive uh there is an
infinite Loop in the code okay so on
line 10 here we have this four with no
body and then an open curly bracket
um let me show you what happens when we
run that
our code's going to sit and run and
execute the body of that for Loop over
and over and over and over with no exit
condition uh this is obviously a problem
we don't want uh an infinite for Loop
there so our job is to exit before
incrementing Max messages to send if the
cost of the next message would go over
the Max cost so all we need to do is
check
and only execute this Loop while the
actual cost is less than
or equal to the Max cost in pennies
and we're going to have to cast looks
like so this is a float this is an end
so we're going to cast this to
64.
now this should work because Max message
to send starts at zero
so
assuming the actual cost is less than
the Max cost then we go ahead and
increment say we can send one more
message and then we take a look at the
next cost and if the next cost is still
less
then we'll essentially get to add
another message so we'll keep kind of
looking ahead and calculating the next
cost right and as soon as the next cost
goes too high we stop
okay so I'm gonna go ahead and run that
cool so with a multiplier of 1.1
and a Max cost of five we can send 17
messages that sounds about right
right the actual cost starts at one
the Max cost is five multiplier of 1.1
yeah that sounds right
um so the multiplier goes up
Max cost goes up now we can send nine
messages that all looks good to me let's
talk about the modulo operator how it
works and go and kind of how it works uh
generally so the modulo operator is a
percent sign so it looks like this
right and the modulo operator
essentially calculates remainders
remainders so what do I mean by that
well let's jump into an example let me
switch colors so
four
four divided by 3
in sort of a normal floating Point
division uh equals like
1.333333 forever right we have this
fractional part however that's how math
Works normally and that's how math Works
in floating Point division in a language
like go if we're doing integer division
then we can't have a floating Point
result so the result of 4 divided by 3
in integer division is actually just one
it's essentially the number of times
that 3 can be divided evenly into four
and then we chop off the remainder
the interesting thing about the modulo
operator
is that for modulo 3 doesn't return the
number of times that 3 can be divided
evenly into four it Returns the
remainder
after that division so actually in the
case of Four modulo 3 the remainder is
also one so it's the same but for
example five modulo 3
is 2.
and 6 modulo three
is zero again because 3 divides evenly
into six right
six integer division
by three
is two right because 3 goes evenly into
six twice but the remainder is zero
that's why six mod three is zero let's
say let's do a couple more examples feel
free to pause the video in between when
I give the question and provide the
solution
um so maybe you can practice a little
bit
okay so let's do 12.
mod 4.
we'll do in fact maybe I'll just write
out all the problems first let's do 16
Mod Five
let's do
mod 8.
and let's do
mod
six
I think those will be
also we get okay 12 mod 4. so does four
divide even Lanes twelve uh yes four
times three is twelve right so the
remainder is zero
all right how many times does five
divide evenly into 16 the answer is 3
right 5 10 15.
and the remainder would then be one
how many times does eight go into 22 8
16 24 so 24 doesn't work so it's going
to be 16 and then 22 subtract 16 is 6 is
the remainder
right and then 27 mod 6 goes into 27 4
times 6 times 4 is 24 so a remainder of
3. so an important thing to note here is
if you're trying to figure out if a
number divides evenly into another
number then you can just check if say a
mod b
equals zero right if a mod b equals zero
then that means B divides into a an even
number of times so a is a multiple of
so in go the module operator is just
that percent sign right so 7 mod 3 this
expression is going to evaluate to one
we'll also need to know about the
logical and operator and the logical or
operator which are double Ampersand and
double bar respectively The Logical and
operator operates on two Boolean values
and only returns true if both sides are
true right this and that
the or Operator just needs at least one
side to be true right in order for the
entire expression to evaluate to True
let's jump into the assignment it says
we're hiring engineers at textio so it's
time to brush up on the classic fizzbuzz
game coding exercise has been
dramatically overused in coding
interviews around the world
it's a function that prints the numbers
1 to 100 inclusive each on their own
line but substitutes multiples of three
for the text Fizz multiples of five for
Buzz and multiples of three and five for
fizzbuzz Okay so maybe a for Loop
or I colon equals zero I is less than
100 actually less than or equal to
because it's set inclusive right I plus
plus
okay
um we need to think about the order in
which
kind of these things can happen so we're
checking for multiples of three
multiples of five and multiples of three
and five so we actually should check for
multiples of three and five first
because something could be that and one
of the other two conditions right it
could be a multiple of three and five
and just a multiple of three
that makes sense maybe it'll make sense
when I type it out so if I mod
three zero
and I mod
three
zero oops not three and three
and five
then we'll print
Biz Buzz
right
else if
I mod
three zero
then we'll just print
is
else if I Mod Five is zero we'll just
print Buzz
otherwise
we'll print
I
right
if they're both multiples fizzbuzz if
it's just three Fizz if it's just five
Buzz okay let's try that
Oh cannot forget to import the
formatting package
okay
let's see
fizzbuzz one two Fizz four Buzz five is
seven eight is Buzz one oh ha ha
one through one hundred that would have
been close I almost didn't follow
instructions I was like why do we have a
Fizz Buzz up front that doesn't uh that
doesn't make sense okay cool
the one tooth is four Buzz right five is
a multiple of five ten is a multiple of
five fifteen is a multiple of five and
three so this is looking correct to me
I'm gonna go ahead and submit that so in
the last assignment we kind of uh did a
if else chain within our for Loop but
there's another way that we can write
guard Clauses within Loops
um so that we don't have to necessarily
do that if else chaining
um if we don't want to the continue
keyword stops the current duration of a
loop and continues to the next iteration
so continue is a powerful way to use
guard classes right so we write our for
Loop and then if some condition happens
we can kind of bail out of the body of
the for Loop early and just continue on
to the next iteration the break keyword
is similar in that it stops the current
iteration but instead of continuing on
to the next iteration it just ends the
loop entirely moving on to the
assignment it says as an Easter egg we
decide to reward our users with a free
text message if they send a prime number
of text messages this year because
textio is is run by a bunch of nerds
complete the price the print primes
function it should print all of the
prime numbers up to and including Max
X it Should Skip any numbers that are
not prime okay so here's the pseudocode
print primes Max so let's convert this
pseudo code into real go code so for n
in range 2 to Max plus one so we're
going to do four and colon equals two
n is less than
Max Plus One
n plus plus
okay if n is 2 if n is 2
n is prime printed fmt dot print line n
and we need to continue right
continue to the next iteration you're
basically saying okay this n is prime
we'll print it and then we can move on
all right if n is even so if
n mod 2 is 0 right that's an easy way to
check if something is even
and not make your way onto our
programmer humor
if n mod 2 is 0
n is not prime skip to the next end so
we do not print and we just skip
okay
next we do a nested for Loop here for I
in range so for I clone equals
three to the square root of n plus one
okay this is actually interesting I
could use the math dot square root
function here that would be a valid way
but if I want to stay in integer land
which I think I do
I can do
um
I can instead Square I so I times I
times I
and see if it's less than n
plus one
right
does that make sense so instead of doing
I is less than the square root of n
I can do I squared is less than n
right
that that makes sense to me
cool
um because basically we're just saying
we only need to check up to the square
root of n we know that if we go higher
than that
um we don't care about numbers higher
than the square root
um
cool
next one is I plus plus
if I could be multiplied into n so if n
mod I oops
if if I goes into n evenly so if that
results in a zero
n is not prime skip to the next n
okay so I can't continue here because if
I continue here I'll just skip to the
next I and I want to skip to the next n
so I think what I do here
is I do something like is prime
true
here I set is prime is false
and break
and then at the end of the for loop I
can say if not is prime
continue
okay
if n is not prime skipped next n yeah so
we'll break out of this Loop
it will break out of this Loop
and then we'll continue
cool
now I just want to be clear there are
other ways to write this function I'm
kind of on purpose using lots of
continues and breaks so that we can get
some practice with it
cool um n is prime printed so if we get
all the way to here without any of these
kind of guard Clauses being triggered
then n is just Prime so fmt.printline
and
let's run that and just sanity check our
code
primes up to 10. two three five seven
yep right that's two is a prime number
it's kind of like the only even prime
number and nine is an odd number before
10 but it's not prime because it's
evenly divided into by three right maybe
I should have even explained what prime
numbers are in the first place in case
you're not familiar there is uh there is
a link here if you want to go read more
about them but basically a prime number
is any number where the numbers that
multiply evenly into it are anything
except one in itself so if it has any
multiples or if it has anything that
multiplies into it that isn't just one
and itself it's Prime right so seven you
can't you can't multiply two into seven
you can't multiply three into seven you
can't multiply four into seven right um
so it's Prime
um let's just uh look at a couple more
of these examples so up to 20 we've got
two three five seven eleven thirteen
Seventeen nineteen right again we're
skipping 15 because it has the multiples
three and five
's up to 30
um again skipping 25 and also skipping
27 because 9 divides evenly into 27 as
as just three cool so hopefully that
makes a bit of sense
and then just kind of as a as an
explanation of why this pseudo code
Works we're skipping even numbers
because they can't be prime right if 2
divides into something it's not prime
um we only check up to the square root
because anything higher than the square
root has no chance of multiplying evenly
into n
right so like for example take the
number 16. its square root is 4 nothing
over 4 could possibly evenly divide into
16.
that the square root couldn't right so
like for example 8 divides evenly into
16 but that's only because 4 and 2
already do
okay we start checking it two because
one is not Prime
one's kind of a special case number
okay so this is looking correct to me
I'm going to go ahead and submit it
let's talk a little bit about how arrays
work under the hood so if you're
familiar with the idea of arrays from
JavaScript or lists from python a race
and go are similar
you can think of an array as just an
ordered list of items so we usually
denote arrays with square brackets
and an array of say three integers might
be something like two
two three
one right so we've got three integers
stored in our array the first thing is
the integer two it's stored at index
zero the next one is a three it's stored
at index one and finally we have a one
stored at index two now here's the big
difference between arrays and go and
arrays in JavaScript or lists in Python
in go arrays have a fixed size so the
type of this array would be
three
int
so inside of the square brackets we kind
of indicate the size of the array and
then after we indicate the type of thing
in the array so this arrays type is an
array of three integers in languages
like JavaScript or again like lists in
Python arrays are kind of dynamically
resized they don't have a fixed size you
can add things onto the end you can push
stuff on to the beginning but in go
arrays are always fixed so to show you
what this looks like in code basically
we can create a new array of 10 integers
like this
it will initialize all of the indices in
the array to the zero value so this
would be an array of ten zeros basically
if we know what we want to store at each
index in the array then we can use an
initialize literal here so we're saying
we have an array of six integers and in
the first index I wanted two and then a
three and then a 5 and so on so let's
jump into an assignment and see how this
works
the assignment says when a message is
not responded to we allow our clients to
have up to two additional messages that
are sent as nudging reminders get
message with retries returns an array of
three strings where index 0 is the first
message if the first message is not
answered by the recipient we send second
and then we'd send the Third
update get message with three ties to
return the three following strings in an
array
click here to sign up pretty please
click here we beg you to sign up Okay
cool so this is pretty straightforward
here we're just going to return
an array and you can see the return type
up here it's a string array of size
three so we just need to create an array
literal and return it
and in this case we want an array of
strings of size three so Ray string size
3 and we can use these curly brackets
um
to be kind of where we put this string
literal so the first string is going to
be click here to sign up right this is
the first message of the sent
pretty please click here
and we beg you we beg you to sign up
and then just remember that in go you do
have to put that last comma if you're
going to use a new line
okay
um pretty straightforward right
let's see how that works
sending
sending to Bob click here to sign up
they responded sending to Alice click
here to sign up pretty please click here
they responded okay this is looking
this is looking good to me
I'm gonna kind of get a peek at the uh
at the test Suite
cool let's submit it and see how we did
so we've talked about how arrays are
fixed in size and you might be wondering
well that's not very useful why would I
care about an ordered list of things if
I can't even add to or remove from the
list well that's where slices come into
play so let's draw out a simple array
I'll do it in yellow let's just say it's
storing some numbers we might have some
numbers like six
three
two six
five
and I'll draw the indices let's do that
in pink so the index of the first item
is zero and then one two three four
right and the size of the array is five
which in go we would write like like
this we would say we have
an array of five items and they are
integers Okay cool so we understand what
an array is but what's slice well slice
is in go are written with this syntax
open close bracket
int
and you'll notice that the size is
missing okay so a slice is a dynamically
sized flexible view into an array so
slices are built on top of arrays so
that means for example that I could
create a slice
that just looks at this kind of middle
portion
of this array if I were to write this in
code I would basically say if this array
is named a so a is this yellow array
here if I want to create a slice on top
of that array then I could write B
colon equals a
from we're using square brackets here
index one
up to but not including index four
okay so the first the first number is
inclusive the second number is exclusive
and now B is this slice of kind of just
that middle view of the array and here's
the important thing to understand in go
we actually almost never deal with
arrays directly 99 times out of 100
you'll just be working with slices
because slices provide a much better
developer experience they're built on
top of arrays for kind of memory
management reasons which we'll talk
about in just a second but you really
want to be working
um for the most part with slices because
you don't have to worry about that fixed
size problem so just to review slices
sort of in code we can create an array
literal like this right this is an array
because we have we have the size of the
array there six integers
and then we can create a slice on top of
the array like this
cool
um let's jump into the assignment so you
can kind of get a feel for how this all
works
okay the assignment says retries are a
premium feature Now text use free users
only get one retry message while Pro
members get an unlimited amount complete
the get message with retries for plan
function it takes up plan variable's
input that's a string matches up to one
of these if the plan is a Pro Plan
return all of the strings from get
message with retries Okay cool so get
message with retries it looks like
returns
an array of three strings
okay let's just jump right into it if
plan is
plan Pro
then we'll return all messages
right return all the strings yep and a
nil error
otherwise if the plan
is plan free
return the first two strings right the
original string and kind of the what the
first retry message so return all
messages and we're going to slice it
from index 0 up to not including index
two subtly indexes zero and one right
two two strings
and then we'll also return nil
and finally if it's neither of those
return an error that says unsupported
plan
so return
nil errors dot new unsupported plan and
nil
um is just kind of the zero value of
slice
cool um this is looking good we need to
make sure we import the errors package
let's go ahead and run this and see what
happens
we got an error cannot use all messages
variable of type
array size 3 string as slice of string
okay cool
so we have an array
all messages is an array not a slice
right so we actually need to slice this
to change its type but we want all of
the values inside of the array so we're
just going to use this colon syntax
to get access to everything in the
underlying array let's run that again
cool sending to Oscar
click here to sign up pretty please
click here so that's two two messages
with no response
um and I'm guessing because yep Oscar's
on a free plan just Jeff is on a Pro
Plan so he gets all three messages this
is looking correct to me these next few
questions will reference kind of
excerpts from the effective go book
which is definitely a book I recommend
reading although it is a bit out of date
it was written a while ago
um and the authors have basically made
the decision not to update
um the book over time kind of keeping it
as a snapshot so it has a lot of great
stuff in there and go has very strong
backwards compatibility so it's still a
great read I'm just going to be aware
that it hasn't been updated
um in a while
cool
um that said everything we explained
here I'll obviously provide uh context
um four so the thing that's important to
understand in this section is that
slices are references to kind of what
goes on underneath the hood with arrays
so what that really means to you as a
developer is when you use slices and
more specifically when you pass them
around say into a function you're
actually passing a reference which means
if you change the values in that slice
within a function
the caller the person who called your
function or I should say the bit of code
that called your function will actually
have access to those changes it will see
those changes even if you don't
explicitly return the slice again now
this is different
um from sort of normal primitive values
which are passed by value you might
remember us talking about pass by value
earlier in the course
typically if you pass in say a string or
an integer into a function and then
within that function you change it the
caller won't see those changes you have
your own copy of that data that's that
does not hold true with slices so just
understand that when you pass a slice
into a function it might get modified
okay cool
um so which references the other is the
question do arrays reference slices or
do slices reference arrays and the
answer is that slices reference arrays
the next question is can multiple slices
point to the same array right is that
true or false multiple slices point to
the same array
um that is true remember slices are just
kind of a view into an array so it makes
sense that you can have multiple views
into the same underlying array so
multiple slices can point to the same
array now here's that question
um that we talked about earlier a
function that only has access to a slice
can modifying the underlying array
the answer to this is that is true even
if the function doesn't return that
slice it can modify the values in the
underlying array let's talk about how
slices work um kind of specifically how
they work in relation to your computer's
Hardware or your computer's Ram
now Ram just stands for Random Access
Memory it's where variables are stored
the best way to think about Ram is just
a mapping of addresses
so address
to data
right it gives us a place to store stuff
so for example at address 0
we might have some data that represents
I don't know the number four
right
and then at address one
we might have some data representing the
number five I don't know I'm just making
stuff up
but you get the idea we have addresses
and we have data associated with that
address slices and the arrays that they
are built on top of are stored in
contiguous memory basically what that
means is a slice or an array is an
address in memory where the slice or
array starts so for example at address 0
we might say this is the start of a
slice
and the slice actually continues for the
next you know several uh kind of bytes
of data let's say that it's a slice of
length three so it actually would reach
across all three of these addresses so
if you have an array or a slice
um and its address is zero and its
length is three then you know kind of
how many uh stores of data in memory
um your slice or array will use now this
is primarily important for performance
because all of the data is stored next
to next to each other in memory it's
going to be going to be stir to kind of
iterate over all of the values in our
slice if we stored each index in kind of
random places in memory it would take a
lot longer to go collect all of that
data just you know from a hardware
perspective however there is a downside
to having to store all of our memory
um kind of next to each other let's
pretend that we have this slice or this
array that starts at address 0 and has a
length of three so it's using kind of
these three addresses in memory or these
three bytes of memory and let's say here
at address 3 we're storing a different
value
maybe we're just storing I don't know
the number six
um but this is a different variable
this is some other variable the problem
is if we want to expand our slice say
add another value to it we're going to
run into the next thing in physical
memory that's a huge problem we don't
want to overwrite some other variable
just because we're growing our slice so
this is why arrays are fixed in size if
we just can't grow them then we'll never
have this overwriting problem so the the
question of course is how do slices do
it right so well slices are built on top
of arrays and basically what happens is
I can draw this out for us
when we want to grow a slice
whose underlying array has run out of
room right so we have our slice
um built on top of this length three
array and we want to grow it into a
length of four what happens under the
hood and this all kind of happens
without you seeing it as a developer
you'll you'll see later when we get to
the syntax it's actually really simple
um what happens is this data is copied
into a new location of memory so we just
take this four we put it over here 5
over here uh actually I'm going to use
the same colors that would probably be
easier to understand so 4 comes over
here 5 comes over here 3 comes over here
and then let's say that we
um we know we want to grow our slice
significantly so the new underlying
array
let's say we'll have a length of 6 now
so it had three here
now the new array has allocated
pre-allocated right we've essentially
reserved memory for us up to six spaces
let me draw all of that out
cool
and these addresses over here are going
to be totally different right maybe it's
address 15 address 16 17 18 19 and 20.
cool so all the data from the old array
gets copied over and now we're able to
expand our slice
our slice to our length of four
right so here our slice was length three
and the underlying array was length
three now we've copied over the data
we've created a much larger underlying
array
and now we have a slice of length four
maybe we wanted to append say
the number two to the end of the slice
so again as the developer you're not
going to have to do all of this array
management manually but it's important
to understand that this is what's going
on under the hood because it has
performance implications copying data
isn't super efficient if you're copying
data from one section in memory to
another over and over and over again it
can slow down your programs so now that
we've covered all of that memory stuff
and how it works under the hood what
does that mean in code right well this
is how we can create a slice without
explicitly creating an array under the
hood right so this will automatically
create an array under the hood for us if
we use this syntax so this is basically
saying I want a new slice of integers I
want its initial length to be five so
the length of the slice right the length
of the view into the array will be five
and the capacity will be 10. so the
capacity is kind of the total space that
we have to grow the slice until we need
to allocate a new array under the hood
so you could almost think of this
capacity as just the length of the
underlying array now I told you that you
don't need to think about the size of
the under the lying array and that is
true
typically you'll actually use this
syntax where you don't even specify a
capacity
so if you do not specify a capacity it
defaults to the length so the kind of
length of the underlying array for a
slice of integers with length five will
just be five and if you grow it past
that the memory copying will happen and
you'll create a new underlying array now
you might be thinking oh that's terrible
for performance in reality it's not that
bad the only reason you would start to
kind of fuss with specific capacities
and optimizing your memory copying is if
you're having performance problems
generally speaking the convenience of
keeping your code simple and easy to
understand is going to outweigh kind of
the performance cost that it'll have
it's it's a very small one generally
speaking and then it's also just worth
pointing out that we can also create
slice literals right so this just
creates a new slice of length three and
initializes these three values into that
slice rather than what would happen up
here which is that we create kind of all
of the zero values to fill out the slice
kind of of the given length so this
would be a slice of five zeros right and
then to just point out two more things
regarding syntax there is a built-in
length function that Returns the length
of a slice and a built-in cap function
that Returns the capacity so now that we
are experts on slices let's jump into
the assignment
says we send a lot of text messages to
text you and our API is getting slow and
unresponsive so I just mentioned how you
probably shouldn't worry about
performance well here's a case where you
should worry about performance right you
shouldn't worry about performance until
well it starts to become a problem so
we're starting to have a problem with
this memory copying being slow
so we've been asked to pre-allocate our
slices
it says
um if we know the Rough Side of this
life before we fill it up we can make
our program Faster by creating the slice
with sis ahead of time alright so
complete the message get message costs
function
it takes a slice of messages and returns
a slice of message costs float64s right
reallocate a slice for the message cost
of the same length as the message slice
let's go ahead and start off with that
so costs
we'll make a new slice and it's going to
be a slice of float
64. and a length of
length messages same same length
cool
um now we want to fill the co fill the
cost slice with cost for each message so
let's go ahead and iterate over each
message so for I colon equals zero
I is less than length of messages
I plus plus
let's get the message at that index
messages zero
oh not a zero excuse me
at High
okay the cost in the cost size should
correspond to the message in the message
slice the same index the cost of a
message is the length the message
multiplied by .01 so cost
equals the length of the message
multiplied by
0.01 that's going to need to be cast to
a float 64.
perfect
cool and then we just need to save that
into the costs slice so costs at I
equals cost
right
correspond with the same index and we
know that that
um that index already exists because we
pre-allocated it to the correct size
cool so now we can just return costs
let's go ahead and run that
and see if these make sense
okay these costs line up with the length
of the messages so this is looking good
to me let's review the difference
between the length and the capacity of a
slice sometimes this can be a little bit
confusing the length is the thing that
you're going to care about most often
the length just tells you how many
things are in that slice right if I have
five items then the length of the slice
is going to be five
the capacity the capacity of a slice
reports the maximum length the slice can
assume right before it gets kind of
reassigned into a new array so capacity
is really again only something you're
going to care about if you're worried
about performance but the length you'll
be concerned about just for kind of
normal business logic reasons right just
because you want to know how many things
are stored in your slice so to answer
this question it says what does the cap
function return answers are at the last
element of a slice or the maximum length
the slice of the slice before
reallocation of the underlying array is
necessary the answer is going to be the
maximum length the next question is what
does the length function return length
of the slice or the maximum length of
slice before the reallocation is
necessary and the answer is going to be
the current length of the slice and we
haven't really talked about this yet but
I'll just kind of inform you as we
answer this question it says what do
length and cap the two functions do when
a slice is is nil do they Panic or
return zero and the answer is that they
return zero they are safe functions to
call
um they won't make your code panic and
error and crash right
um I don't know how much we've talked
about panicking up to this point in the
course but panicking just means run time
error that's unrecoverable unrecoverable
um generally speaking you don't want
your code panicking and you want to
write your code in such a way that it
can't Panic so again length and cap here
are safe they will never Panic if a
slice happens to be the zero value which
is nil time for some very attic
functions this sounds like a really
complex thing but we've actually been
using variatic functions up to this
point in the course because the S printf
print F print line all those functions
are actually very Attic So a variatic
function receives the variatic arguments
as a slice let's take a look at the
syntax so here we have a sum function
and its function signature is just maybe
a little bit different than you're used
to basically we have this nums parameter
which is of type dot dot dot int
now here's the thing dot dot dot int
as far as the function definition is
concerned is just a slice we treat this
just like we would if it said you know
square brackets int it's just a slice of
integers so you're probably sitting
there thinking well why can't I just use
a slice of integers why can't we just
keep it simple why do we have to do
everything differently ah okay well uh
don't don't worry too much
um the difference is on the caller's
side so the function definition is the
same whether you use dot dot dot int or
square brackets int but if you use a
variatic function
then the calling code so the code that
uses the sum function can actually pass
in kind of any number of arguments and
they'll come into the function as a
slice of integers so here we could call
for example sum one two three and the
sum function gets a slice of integers
with you know the values 1 2 and 3 in
the first three indexes of the slice
um this means that the caller could also
call sum 1 comma two right and we'd have
a slice of length too so it kind of just
gives the caller of the function a
different syntax and specifically kind
of a more flexible syntax uh for how
they're able to pass in sort of a
dynamic number of arguments into the
function now again we've already been
using variatic functions you probably
remember the print line function right
this is how we print text to the console
um it's a very attic function dot dot
dot interface right so it can take any
number of arbitrary inputs and it sort
of prints them all out with new lines in
between each element now along with
variatic function definitions we also
have another operator called the spread
operator and the spread operator is kind
of like the inverse of a variatic
function by using the spread operator
we're able to take a slice of values and
pass them into a variatic function
so this isn't the intended use case 100
of the time otherwise you just Define
your your function to take a slice of
strings and you'd pass in a slice of
strings but if you do have a function
that is already variatic and you want to
pass in a slice as the variable part
then you can use this spread operator
this trailing dot dot dot to sort of
spread out
in this case this name slice into the
variatic function let's get our hands
dirty with this so it says we need to
sum up the costs of all individual
messages so that we can send an end of
month Bill to our customers complete the
sum function so that it Returns the sum
of all of its inputs
cool so this is going to be very similar
to this sum function right the
difference here is that we're using
float64s and we're going to write it
from scratch so that we get our own our
own crack at it
Okay so
first things first let's create kind of
the default sum which is going to be
0.0.0 so
let's say total
now remember we can treat nums as just
another slice of 64s so
4i colon equals zero
I is less than length of nums
I plus plus
total plus equals
nums at I
right
return total
cool pretty straightforward
um let's go ahead and run that
so summing three costs bill for the
month six dollars five costs 15 10 costs
55 do these match up
looks like yep that should be six
plus four plus five that's six plus nine
that's fifteen Yep this is looking good
I'm gonna go ahead and submit that
now I told you that resizing slices is
possible we just haven't really done it
yet that's what the append function is
for so the built-in append function is
actually a very attic function but it
allows us to just add new things to the
end of a slice and it automatically
takes care of adjusting the length and
the capacity of the slice accordingly
right allocating new underlying arrays
as necessary now here are your syntax
options for using the append function if
you just want to append one thing then
you'll use this top option let's say we
have a slice called slice we want to
append a variable called one thing to it
basically we call the append function we
pass in the slice we want to append to
as the first item we pass the variable
that we want to append onto the end as
the next thing and then we reassign back
into that same slice now because append
is a very attic function we can append
multiple things right so if we want to
append the first thing and then the
second thing thing after that we could
do it like this and obviously we could
also use the spread operator if we want
to to be 100 honest though 99 of the
time you'll be using this first one
because you'll just be appending items
one at a time let's hop into the
assignment it says we've been asked to
bucket costs for an entire month into
the cost that occurred on each day of
the month so complete the get cost by
day function it's return a slice of
float64s where each element is the total
cost for that day okay so we have like
this giant list of costs and we need to
kind of uh condense all the costs that
happened on a specific day into one
index for that day makes sense to me the
length of the slice should be equal to
the number of days represented in the
costs slice
including any days that have no costs up
to the last day represented in the slice
Okay cool so if we have costs just for
say the first month or the first day of
the month and the fifth day of the month
then we should have
um kind of five indexes in our resulting
array with kind of a non-zero value in
the first and the fifth indexes zeros in
the middle and nothing after that
okay here we've got an example
um
given this input so day cost so we have
costs on days on days zero one and five
this would be the resulting array right
four dollars on the first day 5.2 on the
second day because we sum those right
and then on that last day we'd have 2.5
cool let's write the function
so first things first we're going to
need
um we're going to need a slice to append
into so costs by day
we'll make a new uh a new slice of float
64. and here I'm just using the slice
literal syntax instead of the make
function there
pretty dang similar
now we're probably going to want to
iterate over all the costs so for I
colon equals zero I is less than length
of costs
I plus plus
I
okay so a cost is this structure here
and we can take a look at the day there
um
we're going to need to figure out
basically when we're appending to this
cost spy day slice and when we're just
adding to an existing index so I think
the easiest thing to do would basically
be to say
um if
day is greater than the length of costs
by day
actually it's going to be a four so like
while the day is greater than the length
of cost by day we're going to a pen cost
by day equals append cost by day
0.0
right so in effect this for Loop here
just says if I've encountered a day
that I don't yet have room for I'm going
to grow the slice by just appending
zeros until I have enough room
so once we're done with that Loop
we should be able to assign directly
into the costs by day
by basically saying cost by day plus
equals
cost.value
right
because it starts at zero so then we can
just add
let me just add the cost
and again if if the day is less than
cost by day then we just don't do this
step we just skip over this for Loop
so that's looking correct to me I'm
going to go ahead and return costs by
day
and let's run that code
see what we get undefined day what did I
screw up here
yeah needs to be cost dot day right
access that field
invalid operation cost byte a plus
equals cost of value
so cost value is a float 64
costs by day
is a slice of flow 64s
right because this is a slice so costs
by day
at
cost dot day
right
right because our the slice that we're
returning
um the indexes in each or the indexes of
the slice represent each day in the
month so we need to index back into the
day
okay
try that
whoa what do we got
Panic runtime error index out of range
zero with length zero
okay
what did we screw up
so
somewhere we are indexing into a slice
where the value doesn't like the the
index that we're indexing with is
outside the range of the slide so
um we haven't really talked about this
this is probably great that we ran into
this bug
um
if you try to index which is this
operation here so like this is indexing
into index five right but here we're
indexing into cost.day which holds an
integer
um if you try to index into an index
that is outside the length of the slice
so you have a slice of length say three
and you try to access index six then
you'll encounter this error that's what
we're seeing here
so it looks like that's what we're doing
so for cost.day is greater than the
length now let's think about that
if the day is 5
and the length is five
we're not going to do our growth so I'm
actually I think I have an off by one
error here right I actually what I
actually want to do is say if the cost
if the if the cost ID is greater than or
equal to the length right because an
array or a slice of length four
actually only has three
kind of indexes I mean it has four
indexes but they start at zero so like
length four the indexes are zero one two
and three right let's go ahead and run
that again
cool
no more panic
day one one dollar or day zero one
dollar day one five ten day two 250
let's see if that
lines up with the test Suite
so here it looks like Day Zero should
have one day one should have yep 5.1 if
we add those together and day three
should have five point was it six point
three yep six by three okay this is
looking correct to me
slices can hold other slices right this
kind of creates a 2d Matrix
of values right so for example here a 10
by 10 matrix of integers would look
something like this where the First
Slice is just a slice of slices
hopefully that makes some amount of
sense if not don't worry we'll get into
the assignment here in just a second
so it says we support various graphs and
dashboards on textile the display
message analytics for our users the UI
for our graphs and charts is built on
top of a grid system let's build that
grid logic so this is super common in
graphics development right we're kind of
building on 2D screens so we need sort
of an X and A Y cell within a matrix
which is again often represented as a
slice of slices the assignment says
complete the create Matrix function it
takes a number of rows and columns and
returns a 2d slice of integers where the
value of each cell is I times J where I
and J are the indexes of the row and
column respectively
Okay cool so create Matrix we get two
integers representing how big we want
the Matrix to be and we just have to
return the Matrix
okay cool
so
let's go ahead and start building that
out first we need to create or
initialize the Matrix let's say Matrix
slice let's use make make slice slice it
right
and we can just initialize it to a
length of zero it doesn't matter we're
going to grow it
and for I colon equals zero I is less
than length of rows
I plus plus
and then we're going to need an inner
for Loop
manage J which is going to
deal with the number of columns columns
J plus plus
okay so what do we do
um when we get to the first row well the
first thing we need to do is make a new
slice to represent the row so
we'll say row
make
and we can just do
a single slice of integers
again row length of zeros is fine
um we could pre-allocate but it probably
doesn't matter too much at this point
um and then for each J we're now going
to append into the row so we do row
equals append
row
I times J I believe was the formula
right we want every cell
to be the result of I times J so the
values will sort of grow out as the
Matrix gets larger and larger
cool so that's adding the like this
inner loop is adding values to each
individual row and then we just need to
append the row to The Matrix so Matrix
equals append Matrix
row
and then when we're done appending all
of the rows to The Matrix we can return
the Matrix itself
go ahead and run that
invalid argument rows variable of type
into or length
see what we got here
where did I screw up
this time right
I don't know why I'm checking a length
here
Rose is just an integer
it's not
a slice with a size
let's try that again
cool creating a three by three Matrix
does that math check out
one times one is one one times two is
two two times two is four yep that looks
good
cool let's submit it
I want to show you a common Pitfall that
you might fall into when dealing with
slices and how you can just outright
avoid it
um this is something you should pretty
much never do when you want to append to
um other slice in this case you want to
append elements to other slice you
should always reassign into the same
slice so this should read other slice
equals append other slice element you
don't want to be appending kind of into
one thing and reassigning into a
separate slice you'll run into some bugs
and we're going to talk about how that
works right now so in this first example
we have these slices a b and c and by
the way I would highly recommend coming
here on boot Dev so that you can
actually kind of look and puzzle through
what's going on in the code rather just
seeing it on the screen but basically we
have these slices and when we append to
them
we're we're breaking the rule basically
we're uh appending for example here
um four onto a but then returning the
value
the value returned by append we're kind
of saving it into a new slice called B
which again you generally should not do
you should just save it back into the
same slice a
um but anyways we're going along um kind
of doing that pattern and at the end
you'll notice that nothing too terrible
happened basically we ended up with an a
with three zeros B had four appended to
it properly and C had five appended to
it properly so you could kind of take
away from this example well maybe
there's nothing wrong maybe we can just
kind of uh break the rule and append
into new slices seems like everything's
working like I'd expect and it's worth
pointing out that we can even print out
the addresses in memory of the slices B
and C and see that the addresses are
different in other words when we call
this append functions where we append
five onto
um you know the slice a and and save it
back into the variable C we can see that
actually C is being kind of copied into
a new location so again everything's
kind of working as we'd expect now it's
really in this example two that
something very strange happens
if we look down
here we're appending on to J
the value for
and then we're appending on to G here
the value 5.
but the interesting thing is that after
we append 5 to G if we print out J again
we can see that J was actually changed
kind of under the hood right up here
J had four in its fourth index
and then we never touched J again
directly but by appending on to G we
actually screwed up J we mutated J and
the reason for that is because in this
example because of the way we've
sloppily used the append function G and
J actually point to the same address in
memory so mutating G changed J now I
already mentioned that we were doing the
same thing up here right we were using
the same kind of sloppy use of the
append function that I'm recommending to
avoid but we only had the bug in example
two and the reason for that is because
the original slice in example 2 has a
capacity of eight
while the original slice in example one
had a capacity of three so what that
means is when we used the append
function in the first example once we
went over the capacity we allocated a
new underlying array which is why we got
different memory addresses and so when
we mutate C here C is in a different
place in memory than b so they're kind
of operating independently which is
again what you usually want in your code
however because the capacity was already
large enough in example two there was no
need for the append function to create a
new underlying array so G and J point to
the same
same array in memory
again which means if we mutate g under
the hood we are just mutating J so again
the way you can avoid all of this
headache
is to just not do this right append onto
the same slice pretty much every time
unless you have like some crazy specific
reason not to do so which like I'm
skeptical that exists I certainly
haven't run into it in you know many
years of writing application code and go
so the question for this quiz is why is
5 the final value in the last index of
array J right so why why did we have a 5
here even though we appended four
um and the answers are J and G point to
the same underlying array so G is append
over row J the go team is trolling I
think that's obviously not it uh and
because append only works properly when
the number of elements is less than 10
uh that would be very silly so it's it's
definitely this middle one
we're overriding the same location in
memory next question on the same topic
is why doesn't the bug regarding slices
J and G in example two occur in example
one as well and the answers are because
there are fewer elements and goes
runtime can't handle more than eight
elements that would be awful or the
arrays cap is exceeded so a new
underlying array is allocated and and
that one is the answer so the next
question is how can you best avoid these
types of bugs don't use the append
function always assign the result of the
append function back into the same slice
or always assign the result of the
append function to a new slice
well it's not using a new slice that's
how we got into this trouble in the
first place and we definitely want to
use the append function it's pretty
useful so again always assign the result
of the append function back into the
same slice
you'll avoid a lot of headache that way
finally some syntactic sugar to help us
iterate over the elements of a slice
you've probably been wondering for the
majority of this chapter ugh do I have
to do this like I equals zero I is less
than the length every time I want to
iterate over the elements of the slice
other languages have syntactic sugar to
make it easier so does go so the syntax
is pretty simple this is it right here
and basically by writing it this way
index at each iteration of the loop will
be equal to the index in the loop
starting at zero right so zero one two
three and then element is the value
associated with that Index right and
then obviously slice here is the name of
the slice so range is really the
interesting keyword that allows us to
iterate over everything stored in a
slice to give a more concrete example
here we have a slice of strings called
fruits and we can arrange over the
fruits and if we print I and fruit in
this example that we print zero apple
one banana two grape and so on let's
jump into the assignment it says we need
to be able to quickly detect bad words
in the messages that our system sends
complete the index of first bad word
function okay so that's this
um it finds any bad words in the message
if it finds any bad words in the message
it should return the index of the first
bad word in the message slice this will
help us filter out naughty words uh from
our messaging system if no bad words are
found will return negative one instead
use the range keyword
Okay cool so the bad words themselves
are defined for us and passed into our
function and then the message itself is
already broken up into words it looks
like and passed in is an array of
strings right so we can I'm kind of just
figuring this out by looking uh looking
down here so we have a slice of bad
words and a slice of words in the
message hey there John okay cool
so
um let's start
by iterating over all of the words in
the message right seems like a
reasonable place to start so four
I
word colon equals range message
and then we want to check and see if
if one of these words is equal to one of
the bad words so we're going to use a
nested Loop actually
we'll do J
bad word in range bad words
right
and then here we can say if word equals
equals bad word
that means we found the bad word and we
can return
we want to return the index so we return
I right that would be the index of the
bad word
otherwise if we don't find a bad word
we'll just keep going in fact we'll just
keep going through all the bad words and
then we'll keep going through all the
rest of the words
and if we get to the end of everything
without finding any matches then we can
just return negative one
makes sense right
cool let's run that
J declared not used
right so we've come across this syntax
before we can ignore variables with an
underscore right
let's run that
let's take a look at our test Suite
scanning message hey there John for bad
words
index negative one
that means none were found right
which makes sense we didn't have any
scanning message uh oh my Frick for bad
words
brick is a bad word index three okay
this is looking good to me I'm gonna go
ahead and submit that
if you're familiar with object literals
in JavaScript or python dictionaries
then maps and go are essentially the
same thing maps are just a way to
associate a key with a value so let's
take a look at this example we create a
new map
with this syntax here we're going to use
this built-in make function and then
pass in the type of the map so map of
string to integer so we're mapping
strings two integers
and we're going to say inside of the
ages map we're going to set the key John
to the integer 37. so again we're
mapping that name John to the value 37.
rather than creating an empty map and
then kind of adding key value pairs one
at a time we can also declare the entire
map up front and use kind of this colon
syntax to separate the keys and the
values and then we can also check how
many keys I guess keys and values are in
the map by using the built-in length
function similarly to how you would use
it on a slice so in this case we create
a new map we create two keys each with
their Associated values and then by
printing the length we'll just print the
number two so let's jump right into the
assignment that's usually the best way
to get an idea for how all the syntax
works
assignment says we can speed up our
contact info lookups by using a map
looking up a value in a map by its key
is much faster than searching through a
slice so when we look up something in a
map by a given key that's going to be an
instant lookup
if we had stored it in a slice then we'd
have to search through the entire slice
sort of index by index looking for the
value that we want so Maps can be a
great way to make our code more
efficient
the assignment says complete the get
user map function it takes a slice of
names and a slice of phone numbers and
returns a map of name to user structs
and potentially an error okay so let me
expand our coding window here
okay so we're returning a map of string
to user structs looks like the user
struct is defined right here
if the length of names and phone numbers
is not equal return error with string
invalid sizes the first name in the name
slice matches the first number and so on
Okay cool so first things first we're
gonna have to create a new map so we'll
do
um
user map
colon equals and I'm just going to
create a literal a new map literal
actually no I won't I'll do I'll use the
syntax from up here this works just fine
so we'll use the make function
so make map of string to user
all right so that's now an empty map
and then what we're going to do is check
and make sure that these are the same
length so if the length of names does
not equal the length
of phone numbers
then we'll return nil so nil is the zero
value of a map
we could also return an empty map of the
same type but I'd say you should prefer
nil for slices and maps and things and
then the error
should say invalid sizes so errors dot
new
invalid
sizes
support the errors package
Okay cool so if we get down to line 13
now we should know that both of these
slices names and phone numbers are of
the same size which means we can Loop
like this so four I starting at zero
I is less than the length of it doesn't
matter because they'll be the same right
length of names
I plus plus
then we can say name
is names at I
and we can say phone number
phone numbers
at I
okay
and then we're going to want to insert
values into the user map so we'll do
user map
at
the key in this case the key is the name
right so key is the name
and we'll set it equal to a new instance
of a user struct so user
and the user struct has two Fields name
which will just again be the name and
the phone number
which will just be this phone number
here
cool
so that should fill the entire user map
with all of the names and phone numbers
and then by the end we should just be
able to return
user map nil
okay cool I think we got everything
let's go ahead and run that
and see what we get
so creating map key John value name
number key Bob value name number this is
looking this is looking correct to me
here we have creating a map with invalid
sizes
um if we take a look at the tests
uh yep that makes sense the second test
has two names but three numbers so I
would expect it to get that invalid
sizes error
cool let's uh let's submit that
so the primary way you interact with
maps is just by setting and deleting
values at a given key right they're very
associative right a value maps to a key
but there's no other ordering Maps
aren't ordered from you know index 0 1 2
3 like a slices everything's unordered
you're literally just mapping values to
keys Okay cool so let's take a look at
some of the different syntax that we can
use to interact with maps so we can
insert an element by just setting the
key equal to the value
we can get an element out just by
accessing it directly at its key we can
delete Elements by using the built-in
delete function where we're passing in
the map itself and the key that we want
to delete notice that we're not passing
in the value at all we're just passing
in the key
and then we can also check if a key
exists by parsing the return value of
kind of this access syntax into two
separate values where the first value
will be the element itself and the
second value is a Boolean if the Boolean
is true then the element will be
whatever element was stored of that key
however if the Boolean is false that
tells you that that key didn't exist in
the map and the element will just be the
zero value for its type let's jump into
the assignment so it says in fact Let me
let me resize this a bit
says it's important to keep up with
privacy regulations and respect our
users data we need a function that will
delete user records okay complete the
delete if necessary function it takes a
map of users and a name which I'm going
to guess is the key in the map and it
will return a Boolean saying whether or
not the user was deleted and then an
error if something went wrong
Okay cool so if the user does not exist
in the map or turn the error not found
oh interesting so if we're trying to
delete something and it's not there
that's an error
if they exist but aren't scheduled for
deletion then return deleted as false so
we'll this will be false and there won't
be any errors but if they exist and are
scheduled for deletion then we'll return
the deleted Boolean as true with no
other errors okay that's making sense to
me and then a note on how maps are
passed into functions is that like
slices maps are actually passed by
reference so even though this function
delete if necessary does not return a
map
if we mutate this user's map it will be
mutated for the caller of the function
so that's how we are able to delete
something from the map even though we're
not returning the map once we're done
with it so the first thing we need to do
is just check and see if the name that
we're trying to delete exists so let's
do this if
blank okay colon equals users
at name
not not okay
so this is that kind of special if
statement syntax right where we're
actually ignoring the value itself we're
just interested in that Boolean value
telling us whether or not this
um this key exists in the map and if it
does not then we're going to go ahead
and return
uh return the error not found so false
because we always do zero values for
everything besides the error and then
errors dot new
not found and we'll make sure to import
that errors package
okay cool and again I'm just I'm just uh
using this syntax here
let's check if a key exists
cool moving on okay so if we get past uh
that guard Clause to line 12 well then
we know
um that the user exists so
um at this point ah we need to check if
they're scheduled for deletion so I'm
actually going to switch up my syntax
here the user struct has the scheduled
for deletion Boolean so I'm going to go
ahead and do this on a separate line
and I will save that user
so I'll do
um
existing user
and then we'll just do if not okay
so that down here now I can use that
existing user struct so I can say if
existing user dot scheduled for deletion
so if they exist and are scheduled for
deletion return deleted as true with no
errors and delete the record for the map
so we need to use this built-in delete
function so we'll delete
users
name
and then we'll return true
no
all right so if they are scheduled for
deletion we'll delete them and report
back that we deleted them
cool
um otherwise
if they're not scheduled for deletion
return delete is false with no errors so
return
false no
okay that looks right to me let's go
ahead and run that
attempting to delete John deleted John
attempting to delete musk not found
Santa not found attempt to delete K did
not delete Kate Okay cool so I mean all
that look it looks like all the cases
were covered let's just come down here
and take a look
okay so we had a John and John was
deleted
and that attempting to delete musk
there's not actually a musk in the map
so not found makes sense there's also
not a Santa and Cade was not scheduled
for deletion so he did not get deleted
and then the final map still has those
keys that looks correct to me
in this next section we're going to be
covering some of the material from the
go blog now I'm not going to read all of
this out uh that would be a little dry
but I definitely recommend reading this
over if you have the time otherwise I'm
going to cover kind of the key points so
the first question is what makes a type
qualify to be able to be used as a map
key okay so any type can be used as a
map value but not every type can be used
as a map key and that's because map Keys
maybe of any type that is comparable so
things like strings booleans numbers all
those can be compared for equality what
cannot be compared for equality are
slices maps and functions and kind of
one of the reasons for that is slices
and maps and functions they're kind of
just pointers to addresses in memory so
if you compare one slice to another
slice you're not really comparing the
underlying values you're actually
comparing kind of where those two slices
are stored in your computer's Ram
and because they're stored in different
places you'll actually get two slices
with maybe the exact same values stored
in them say slice one has the numbers
one two three in the first three indexes
and the second slice has the same
they might still be compared as unequal
because they're stored in different
addresses in memory so I mean all that
being said long story short you just
can't use slices and maps and functions
as map keys so to answer the question
what makes type qualify to be used as a
map key the type is comparable this next
question is interesting and kind of
plays on the idea that we can Nest Maps
kind of one inside the other or we could
do something that's arguably simpler let
me show you what I mean so here is an
example of a map of strings
that maps to another map
which maps from strings to integers so
like the first string kind of maps to
the second string which maps to an
integer if you want to think about it
that way if you're familiar with Json
objects this would be like mapping Json
objects kind of down multiple levels of
keys so in the example given in the go
blog essentially what's being said is
we're mapping two strings to account
and so what that looks like in code is
if we want to get access to the count we
actually have to go to the map
index the nested map with a key and then
index into that next map with another
key before we get the value out now this
looks simple on the surface but what
actually happens is when you need when
you go down those nested levels you
actually can't be sure that the inner
map exists and So to avoid panicking
your code will actually Panic by the way
if you try to access a key in a map that
is nil So to avoid panicking you have to
check and make sure that those nested
Maps actually exist which just results
in a lot of extra code so while nesting
Maps definitely works and I've used it
quite a bit there can in some instances
be a simpler way which is to actually
use a struct as a key notice that a
struct was not named as one of the
non-comparable types structs are
comparable so if you want to create a
map that kind of has multiple keys that
kind of combine together to form a
composite key then just create a new
struct right with two values inside of
it and those two values kind of unique
together create their own key so this
simplifies a lot of things where now we
can have one map and we can use that
struct key to create kind of uniqueness
across two different values this might
be useful for example if you're trying
to create
a map That's Unique for first last name
combinations right you want Lane Wagner
stored in two different fields first
name and last name to be unique together
so to answer the question which is
simpler to use a struct directly as a
key or to Nest maps and the authors of
the go blog and I would agree
argue that using a struct directly is
going to be simpler let's jump right
into this next assignment it says we
have a slice of user IDs okay so those
are strings and each instance of an ID
in the slice indicates that a message
was sent to that user we need to count
up how many times each user's ID appears
in the slice to track how many messages
they received implement the get counts
function okay so that's this one
a map of string to int so that each int
is a count of how many times each string
was found in the slice okay cool simple
enough
so let's create a new map so this will
be the counts map
and it's going to be a map of string to
integer
and then let's Loop over all of the user
IDs so for blank user ID
and range user IDs
and we're just we're going to ignore the
index because we don't care about it
and the first thing we're going to do is
check to see if a value in the map for
the given user ID already exists so
count
okay colon equals
user IDs
sorry counts
at user ID
right
cool
um in fact now like now that I type that
out I'm not actually sure that I need
this
because if I don't use this
this access will still work it's just if
if the key didn't exist count will be
zero which is fine so actually I don't
even think I care
um
cool so we get the count it'll be zero
if it didn't yet exist and then we just
increment it by one so count plus plus
and then we'll save it back into the map
so counts at user ID equals count
so we're just grabbing it out
incrementing it by one and putting it
back
that seems like what we want to do right
and then at the end we'll just return
counts
cool
let's go ahead and run that and see what
we get
jittering counts for 10 000 user IDs
Counts from selected IDs zero zero has
31 FF has 27 DD has 37 okay and if I
look down here it looks like the IDS are
being generated randomly
cool so
let's go ahead and submit it because
this feels right
cool we're good to go this next section
is about a piece or an excerpt from the
effective go book
um that is a book that I'd highly
recommend reading um some of the stuff's
a bit outdated they've made the decision
not to continuously update effective go
but it is an Open Source book you can go
read the whole thing for free um and the
link is right there so go check that out
if you're interested
um that said you don't need to I'll be
talking through the parts that we care
about here so Maps can have at most
blank values associated with the same
key the answers are one any number of
three and two well maps are associative
right they map a single key to a single
value and you can't have duplicates of
the same key in a map that wouldn't make
any sense right then when you put in a
key you would maybe get back a slice
like that doesn't quite work so the
answer is Maps can have at most one
value associated with the same key the
next question says attempting to get a
value from a map where the key does not
exist Returns the closest Value panics
or Returns the zero value that's covered
here in the section on missing keys but
basically to summarize if you attempt to
get a I mean we actually covered this in
the last um the last coding assignment
but if you attempt to access a key in a
map where the key doesn't exist you'll
just get back to zero value so for
example if it's a map of strings to
integers
and you access a string that doesn't
exist you'll get back as the value zero
and that's kind of nice just because
accessing values in a map is a safe
operation your code will not will not
panic so to answer the question it
Returns the zero value
and it's also worth pointing out really
quickly that if the map doesn't exist so
not that the key that you're trying to
access doesn't exist but if the map
itself doesn't exist if it's a nil map
then your code will Panic so that is a
dangerous operation you want to make
sure you're always accessing values in
maps that have been initialized the next
question is a function can mutate the
values stored in a map and those changes
blank the caller effect or do not affect
the caller now the answer to this one is
in this first section that Maps like
slices are references so when we pass a
map into a function that function can
change what's in the map and those
changes will be visible outside of the
function this is different from
Primitives right strings integers
um booleans those are all passed into
functions by value if you mutate them
within a function uh the the caller of
that function will not see those changes
unless you return those values but the
same does not hold true for slices and
maps
so to answer the question a function can
mutate the values stored in a map and
those changes they do affect the collar
the next question says what does the
second return value from a retrieve
operation in a map indicate so let's
take a look at this code example here so
we've got this time zone map where we're
accessing the map at a given a given key
and it can return two values
the first value is the value associated
with the key and the second value is a
Boolean right we use this in the last
coding assignment so a Boolean that
indicates whether the value at the key
is a nil value nope that's not accurate
a Boolean that indicates whether the key
exists that's the one
let's practice with some nested Maps so
like we talked about earlier Maps can
contain other Maps as their values not
as not as their keys right so let's jump
into the assignment it says because
textio is a glorified customer database
right I mean we're sending
SMS and email messages to a giant list
of customers we're basically just a big
customer database we have a lot of
internal Logic for sorting and dealing
with customer names complete the get
name counts function it takes a slice of
strings names
and returns a nested Maps this is going
to be very similar to the last
assignment we did
um but this time it's going to be a
nested map where the first key is all
the unique First characters of the names
and the second key is all the names
themselves so this could be useful if
for some reason we wanted to get access
to all of the names that start with a
very quickly so to kind of visualize
this we've got this example if the input
names slice is this slice here Billy
Billy Bob Joe it would create the
following nested map so the first key is
just a letter
the second key is the full name and then
the value is the number of times that
name showed up in the original list and
then it's worth pointing out here that
the return value is a map of runes to a
map of strings and integers in go we
often just represent individual
characters as runes rather than strings
of length one it just gives us a little
more kind of a surety in our type system
okay so let's start by creating a new
top level map so we'll call it counts
and we'll make that full map
now it's important to understand because
this map contains Maps inside of it we
will need to continuously initialize new
maps I'll show you what that looks like
so now let's just Loop over all these
names so for
um we don't care about the index name
and range names
Okay so we've got a name the first thing
we need to do is actually check and see
if we already have a map associated with
the first character of this name so
let's get that first character let's do
if
we probably need to do some safety
checking so like if length of name
actually the easiest thing to do would
just be if name is the empty string
and we'll continue
we don't care about blank names they
they don't do anything for us right so
we'll just we'll just skip them great if
it's not the empty string
then we can say first character
is name zero
okay so that gives us the roon at the
first index in the name
and then what we can do is look up in
our map so counts at first oops counts
at first character
um we can see if the inner map
exists
so if it does not exist not if not okay
let's just keep it simple if it doesn't
exist we'll just initialize it so if it
does not exist we'll say counts at first
character
equals and we'll initialize the new
inner map so we just need a new map of
string to integer
at that first character key
right
right in fact
to be explicit I'm going to ignore the
inner map there
so by the time we get down here to line
18 we should be 100 certain that counts
at first character contains an
initialized map
so then we can just simply do counts of
first character at
name
plus plus
right
because we've we've made sure that the
inner map exists and if
the name key doesn't exist it will
return a zero which we can then
increment and save back into the map so
that should work just fine
at the end we can return counts
cool hopefully that makes sense
and we've got some test cases down here
Matthew George Drew Philip Bryant and
then a big list okay cool let's run it
and see what happens
whoops cannot use first Char variable of
type byte as roon value
right so when you index into a string
right so name is a single string in go
then it is a byte type but we want to
Rune type so
I'm gonna go ahead and cast it
and run it again
cool uh generating counts for 50 for the
first 50 names count for M Matthew is
three
G George is One D Drew is four we don't
have any panics so these counts look
totally plausible to me let's go ahead
and submit it
it's time to talk about first class and
higher order functions which are just
really kind of confusing complex terms
for a much simpler idea which is
functions as data
a programming language is said to
support first class functions if it
allows you to pass around functions just
like you pass around any other variable
storing essentially an entire function
as a value and then a function that uses
that first class function so a function
that accepts another function as a
parameter or returns a function as a
return value is said to be called a
higher order function let's take a look
at a concrete example okay so here we
have two functions add and multiply
these are very simple functions you
should be able to understand uh what
they do just by looking at them for a
second
um but here we have kind of an
interesting function it's called
Aggregate and it takes as input
three integers a b and c and it takes as
input an entire function right so it
takes a function and we're calling it
here arithmetic it's the fourth
parameter to the aggregate function and
this function has a specific signature
this function arithmetic must take as
its parameters two integers
okay and return an integer itself and
then the aggregate function just returns
an integer so what does the aggregate
function do well it calls the function
it was given Twice first it calls it
once with a and b
and then it calls it again with the
results of A and B and C
so for example if we call aggregate with
the numbers 2 3 4 and the function add
then it will add all three of those
numbers together right which would in
this case print nine
and then we can also use that same
aggregate function with the same numbers
two three and four but this time pass in
that multiply function and here we'll
get 24 right because we're multiplying
um all of the variables together instead
of adding them it's okay if this is a
bit confusing uh if this is the first
time you've worked with functions as
data take a second to really kind of
stare at this code and and figure out
these this crazy function signature it's
actually not that complex once you kind
of get past the scary syntax
um but but don't feel bad if you have to
pause the video and take a good look
let's get our hands dirty with this
assignment says textile is launching a
new email messaging product malio I
guess uh SMS and email right fix the
compile time bug in the get formatted
messages function the function body is
correct but the function signature is
not okay so this formatter function here
looks like it will be a problem let's go
ahead and run the code and see what kind
of an error we get so this is compile
time error saying we have a syntax
problem and that makes sense because
here we're basically saying well the
formatter input is a function but we're
not saying what type of function it is
and that doesn't work because get
formatted messages is going to use the
formatter function so it needs to know
essentially what parameters it takes as
input and what it's going to return
right kind of like the arithmetic
function here takes two integers and
returns an integer we need to update
this function signature to kind of
inform the get formatted messages
function what this formatter function
actually does so if we look at the code
because we know the function body is
correct it looks like
formatter accepts a message's input
which is a string
and it's going to return whatever should
be appended to this formatted messages
slice which is a string so it looks like
it takes one string as input and returns
one string as output that kind of makes
sense for a formatter function
so we say it takes a string and it
returns a string
let's go ahead and run that and see what
we get
oh at least it compiled says thanks for
getting back to me which returned thanks
for getting back to me kind regards
Okay cool so the ad signature ads kind
regards to the end and add greeting
thanks for getting back to me hello
thanks for getting back to me cool let's
go ahead and run that
awesome
so this might seem like an exercise in
complexity right like why do I need to
pass around functions as data that just
seems to add a bunch of well needless
complexity and for the most part you're
right you really should only use higher
order and first class functions if you
have a very good reason to do so so the
question is kind of what are the good
reasons to do so well first class and
higher order functions are very often
used for on the back end side of the
stack HTTP handlers right so if you have
some front-end code that needs to reach
out to a backend server and get some
data those handlers are typically first
class or higher order functions because
we need some code right the Handler
function to run like in the future we
don't want to call it now right we want
to call it when something happens in the
UI World kind of on the on the front end
side of the stack they're often used in
on click handlers right so I write a
function and I don't necessarily call it
when my program starts but I call it
when something thing interesting happens
like the user clicks a button right when
a button click happens I want to call
you know this function and so typically
in code we can represent that with a
higher order function we say on click do
this and then we kind of give it the
name of a function to call and then just
to review the definitions uh very
quickly a first class function is a
function that is kind of being passed
around as data and a higher order
function is the function that's using
that first class function right it's a
function that accepts a function as
input or returns it as one of its return
values so the question is what is a
higher order function it is a function
that takes another function as an
argument or returns a function but it's
not a function that is first in this
call stack or a function with Superior
logic
so the next question is what is a first
class function it is a function that is
treated like any other variable right
it's a function that we're going to pass
around as as data to probably be called
sometime in the future
function carrying is kind of like a
special kind of higher order function
it's a function that accepts another
function as input we're kind of familiar
with that idea but that also returns a
new function as its output so it's kind
of a way of like enhancing a function
with new Behavior it's kind of a weird
concept to think about abstractly so
let's jump into this example
okay so here we have a function called
self math and self math is the curried
function it takes a math function as
input that accepts two integers and
returns an integer and it returns a new
function that only takes a single
integer as input and returns an integer
and then what it does again it returns a
function right that takes a single
integer as an input and returns an
integer and it calls the math function
that it was given
with the same input twice right so we're
kind of mapping a function that accepts
two different integers into a function
that kind of forces both of those
integers to be the same integer so like
what does that do in practice well
basically we can use our self math
function to convert a multiply function
into a square function right so multiply
takes X and Y and multiplies them
together this new Square function that
we created dynamically only takes a
single value and multiplies it by itself
right same with the add function we can
kind of use the self-map function to
convert it into a function that just
doubles its input right so we Square 5
we get 25 we double 5 and we get 10. so
when would carrying be used in the real
world to be honest I don't use it very
often but in backend server land I do
sometimes use it for middleware
functions so a middleware function is is
a function that basically changes the
HTTP Handler of a back-end server and
just as a spoiler we will be covering
this in the project at the end of this
course
um but it's for kind of injecting some
additional logic into a function so say
we have an HTTP Handler that accepts as
input a user ID and returns an entire
user object with you know say their
first name their last name that sort of
thing
um a middleware function might do
something like require an authentication
token right so we can write all of our
HTTP handlers that serve different data
sort of independently and then we can
use a curried function to kind of
require authentication Logic on all of
our HTTP handlers in fact in go currying
is very often used to handle the sort of
middleware problem now if all of that
went straight over your head again
that's okay it's kind of hard to talk
about something that we're not working
on at the moment so again we're going to
hover middleware and HTTP handlers in
the project at the end of this course so
stick around for that so jumping into
the assignment it says the mainly API
needs a very robust error logging system
so we can see when things are going awry
in the back end we need a function that
can create a custom logger a function
that prints to the console given a
specific formatter Okay cool so this
function get logger should return a
logger
which is a function right it's a
function that takes two strings as input
and apparently prints them because it
doesn't return anything
and get logger takes as input a
formatter which accepts two strings as
input and returns a single string
okay so it says complete the get logger
function it should return a new function
the inputs should be passed into the
formatter function the order they're
given to the logger function Okay so
let's start writing this so we're going
to return a function
that takes two strings as input right
and I'm going to reference up here for
the syntax we're interested in so I'm
going to do a string
B string
okay
and this function should return nothing
so we can just go straight into the body
and it says
this function prints the formatted
inputs so formatter returns a single
string so we can just do fmt.printline
and we're going to need to oh we already
have fmt imported perfect
so we need to print the result of the
formatter functions it's going to be
formatter
and we'll pass into the formatter A and
B
right so we're returning a new function
a logger
that accepts two inputs
or mats them given the formatter that we
were given right and that just prints it
to the console
cool let's go ahead and run that
error on database server out of memory
and database server CPU is pegged this
all looks good let's see how the test
Suite actually works
it looks like these are the formatters
colon delimit and comma delimit and if
you take a look at our messages some are
delimited by a colon some are delimited
by a comma
so that's how that is working very cool
all right I'm going to go ahead and
submit that I think this is correct
time to talk about the defer keyword
this is a really kind of unique thing to
go if you're familiar with any other
programming languages it's unlikely that
you're familiar with something similar
to the defer keyword at least I've never
used it or used a concept that is
similar to the defer keyword in another
language
um barely go specific okay so the defer
keyword allows us to execute some
function at the end of the current
function or when the current function
exits the Deferred keyword is very often
used as sort of a clean up step
um for example in this in this function
here copy file
we open a source file from the file
system and then we defer closing the
file right so every time you open access
to a file in the file system you need to
remember to close that file otherwise
you're sort of wasting Computer
Resources
the problem is
closing the file at the end of the
function is a little tedious because we
have multiple return statements here so
we'd kind of have to close it before
both of them if that makes sense by
using the defer keyword we can just tell
the go programming language hey I want
to call source.close
right before the copy file function ends
and just defers it kind of until the end
and it will only call it once no matter
where the function actually returns from
on to the assignment it says there is a
bug in the log and delete function fix
it let me expand this a little bit so we
can see it this function should always
delete the user from the user's map Okay
cool so we're given a user's map we're
given a name and we know that maps are
passed by reference so if we delete a
map it will be deleted in the callers
code as well
um it should return a log string that
indicates to the color some information
about the user's deletion okay so delete
should always happen and then the kind
of uh the appropriate log message should
be returned from the function that makes
sense
um but it looks like there's a bug okay
so let's go ahead and run the code and
see what we get
so initial users Brianna Elon John Cade
attempting to delete John deleting Santa
deleting Cade
okay so John's still there the problem
is that we're trying to delete John but
John's not actually getting deleted
right so we need to fix that bug
and if we take a look John is an admin
and here we are returning
log admin but we're not deleting admins
so so that's that's the real problem
right the users should always be deleted
now
here's the problem we can do this
um this will work
if I run this my guess is this should
fix the bug yep John is no longer there
he was deleted successfully but this is
kind of gross right we're calling delete
three different times
um what if in the future we add another
case and we forget we forget to add the
delete again we'll have another bug
um
well what we could do what we could do
is just delete at the top once
right
but the problem is if we do that
we delete the user from the user's map
too soon
and now this OK variable that's checking
for existence so it can change which log
is returned like that logic won't work
it will just always be not okay so we'll
always just return log not fan so that's
a problem
what we can do is defer the deletion so
this code says we'll call this delete
function right before login delete
returns so if it's almost like the
equivalent of you know adding this at
every step of the way so let's go ahead
and run that make sure it works
John's there John's gone perfect and we
have different logs getting returned so
that looks good I'm gonna go ahead and
submit that this chapter is not called
Advanced functions uh for no reason
let's talk about closures closures are
um I don't want to like intimidate you
and say they're really hard but they're
a little weird so let's let's take a
second second to understand uh how they
work
okay a closure is a function that
references variables from outside its
own function body the function May
access and assign to the referenced
variables so in this example
the concature function returns a
function that has a reference to the
enclosed doc value okay so concature is
a function it returns a new function
right and that's what's Happening Here
and it's enclosing this doc string
within the function so it's getting
initialized outside of the function and
then getting used within the function
and what happens is basically when we
call concatter to to make this new
like concat function
we're saving a reference to this doc
variable so every kind of concurrent not
concurrence every uh subsequent call to
this function that is returned we'll
keep adding on right plus equals word
we'll keep adding on to the same doc
variable so let's look at what that kind
of looks like in usage so we're calling
concatter and we're getting back this
Harry Potter aggregator right that's
what we're assigning this function
we're assigning this function into this
variable so Harry Potter aggregator is a
function right it's it's specifically
it's this function right here
cool and then we're going to call it
with mister and then we'll call it again
with and and Mrs dursley Right we're
calling it over and over and over and
what's happening under the hood is we're
appending those words Mr and Mrs onto
that doc variable so at the end when we
finally print
what's being returned which is the doc
variable itself we get the full sentence
Mr and Mrs dursley number four privet
drive now closures are one of those
Advanced things that you to be honest
again don't you usually use in
production code maybe every once in a
while but they're very important to
understand because it is very common to
have kind of bugs surrounding closures
so if you don't understand what's going
on under the hood it can be really hard
to debug a kind of complex code that
might even be using closures by accident
so the assignment says keeping track of
how many emails we send is Mission
critical at malio complete the adder
function it should return a function
that adds its input and integer to an
enclosed sum value and then Returns the
new sum in other words it keeps a
running total of the sum variable within
a closure Okay cool so it's going to be
very similar to this right so we'll
start by creating a sum value so sum
colon equals zero right we're working
with integers not flows and then we need
to return
a function with the signature so return
dunk X int
turns an INT
oh not not returns an X returns an INT
and then here the we need to add X to
sum right so sum plus equals X
and then we need to return
the new sum
right and then if we go take a look at
this test case let's see
okay so we're adding these email bills
with a bunch of different numbers
the test iterates over the bills ah okay
so we're creating two adders here so
we're creating account adder and a cost
adder
and then let me expand this
I'm going to just make that basically
full screen
so the test actually creates two
different adders two different instances
of our Adder function right and one of
them is going to count how many bills
there are and the other one will keep a
running total
of the cost of all of the bills right so
we're actually using our function twice
for two different things and they'll
each have their own enclosed some count
that they keep track of differently
right the count will have its own the
cost will have its own the count is
simple it just adds one either every
time the cost will add the actual cost
and pennies cool let's go ahead and run
this
so um and these values are getting
interpolated into this message so you've
sent one email costs 45 cents two emails
77 cents three emails 120 cents it's
like all of these are going up that
makes sense I mean we could even go
verify right 45 plus 32 77 that looks
right to me let's go ahead and submit it
all right we're on to a little quiz
about closures can a closure mutate a
variable outside of its body uh yes
that's basically the entire point of a
closure another little review question
here says when a variable is enclosed in
a closure the enclosing function has
access to blank a copy of the value or a
mutable reference to the original value
well if it was a copy then our sum never
would have worked right because we'd be
working with a new copy of the sum
variable every time so it's actually a
mutable reference to the original value
we've already been using Anonymous
functions kind of all throughout this
chapter
um now let's kind of just talk about
what they are so Anonymous functions are
exactly what they sound like they're
just functions that do not have a name
they have no name
um Anonymous functions are really useful
when you're kind of just one-off maybe
creating a closure you're returning a
new type of function if if you're not
defining the function for like use
across the entire program but you're
more using it as a value using it as a
first class function
um that's when you're going to see
Anonymous functions use the most so as
an example
um here we have an anonymous function
declaration right we're creating a new
function we're defining its internal
logic it's it's function body but we're
not giving it a name right there's no
name for this function that we're
passing into do math it is an anonymous
function the assignment says complete
the print reports function call Print
cost report once for each message okay
let's take a look print cost report
looks like it takes as input a function
cost calculator
great okay
call Print cost report once for each
message pass an anonymous function as
the cost calculator that returns an INT
equal to twice the length of the input
message okay let's go ahead and do that
so
um it says to do it once for each
message yeah so four
message
range messages
call Print cost report prints cost
report
and print cost report takes a cost
calculator which is a function that
takes a string and returns an INT
is said to use an anonymous function
right so funks we need to actually
Define our X string int
we need to define the body
that returns an INT equal to twice the
length of the input message so X is a
string in fact I'm going to name this
message
and we'll return the length of message
times two
right twice the length of the input
message and then print cost report takes
a second parameter which is the message
itself
right
I think am I am I reading this correctly
cost report
fix the calculator and the message
itself yep because it's gonna it's then
going to call the cost calculator and
then and then print kind of a little
report
okay cool
um that's looking pretty good to me
we don't return anything from print
reports okay let's go ahead and run this
so message here's Johnny costs 28 cents
go ahead make my day 42 cents you had me
at hello 38 cents that's looking correct
right there's 19
28 not 19 what's half of 28 14
characters there looks good to me okay
let's go ahead and submit that
let's talk about pointers and in order
to understand pointers we need to talk a
little bit about Ram or memory right
random access memory which is basically
the part of the hardware in our computer
that stores data right because pointers
and variables are all about kind of how
we store data in the memory of our
computer let's start with something
simple
let's create a new variable
in our program
and let's call it X
and we'll set x equal to 5.
under the hood what happens
automatically when we create a new
variable uh and set it equal to five is
somewhere in our computer's memory that
variable's value is going to get stored
so let's say uh for the sake of the
example that it's stored here in memory
address
169. Now Memory in your computer you can
think of it as fairly simply a memory
address that stores a value so we've got
kind of you know millions of different
memory addresses in which we can store
data and somewhere in memory that value
needs to live so let's just say it gets
assigned again automatically
to address 169.
great now what happens if I create a new
variable let's call it y
and set it equal to the current value of
x
y actually gets a new copy of the value
so X lives here at address 169 y let's
just say is going to limit address 170
and we get a copy of that five so down
here in this table this is where we're
going to keep track of all of our
variables we'll say that X
so X is the variable name lives at
address 169
and it stores the value 5.
now why
lives at address 170
and stores also the value 5. at its most
basic a pointer is just a variable that
stores a memory address so let's say for
example that we create a new variable
called Z
and we set it to point which is uh which
uses the Ampersand I can't draw an
ampersand pretend that that's an
ampersand uh the the the a reference to
X right it points to X
what that does is that we're creating a
new variable called Z
it's going to get a new address anytime
we create a new variable it's going to
live in a new address in memory let's
say it lives at address 171.
but its value instead of being 5 instead
of being a copy of X because we used
kind of the pointer syntax or the
reference syntax
the value is going to be the address of
x
so we're going to store 169 which is the
again the address of X as the value and
Z is going to be a pointer type so kind
of the way the go programming language
works is it knows that Z is effectively
pointing to the value 5 right because
its address is 171.
which stores a pointer to 169 so we can
look up the value 5 at address 169.
so what this means is if we update the
value that Z points to under the hood
we're updating X so we can do things
like pass pointers into functions change
the underlying value and the value
outside of that function is also changed
which again in a language like go
doesn't happen normally because
typically if you pass a variable like X
into a function and then change it those
changes are not seen outside of the
function you would need to return the
updated value and then assign it into a
new variable so pointers basically allow
us to change the value of something from
within a function right from within a
different scope let me show you what
that looks like in a quick example so
remember that Z stores the value 169.
which points to this address
which stores the value 5.
so if we want to update the value of x
without having access to the original
variable x what we can do is use the D
reference operator which is an asterisk
we can dereference Z now this D
reference operator essentially follows
this chain and finds the value right and
we reassign into it let's say the value
6. so this becomes 6 and this location
in memory is updated now to hold the
value 6. so we've updated the value of x
without even without even using right
the name X so now that we've kind of
covered what a pointer is let's look at
just a little bit more of the syntax in
code
so the type of a pointer is not the type
of the underlying value alone so if I
want a pointer to an integer I actually
have to use this syntax here I'm
creating a new variable called p
and it's being initialized as a pointer
to an integer so a pointer is a specific
type in go
now to be fair
um it's not super common that you're
creating blank pointers and the zero
value for a pointer is nil more often
than not what you're going to do is have
a concrete value like this my string
hello and then you'll create a pointer
to that value by using the Ampersand
like we talked about so in this case the
type of my string is string and the type
of my string pointer is a pointer to a
string which would be syntactically star
string they're kind of two primary
reasons that you would use a pointer in
the go programming language the first is
the more common reason which is you want
to be able to pass a value into a
function and change the value and have
those changes kind of persist outside of
the function right because normally when
you pass a value into a function a copy
is passed in so if you want to pass in
sort of the original value so it can be
changed and updated uh you might use a
pointer the second reason is if you're
very concerned about the performance of
your program every time you create a
copy of a variable in memory you have to
copy that variable in memory right which
takes some time so if you're dealing
with lots and lots of data and you're
trying to be very performant you can
make micro optimizations and kind of use
pointers on under the hood if you want
to avoid all of that memory copying now
I will say that you usually won't want
to do this up front because pointers are
dangerous and they can lead to bugs if
not used properly so generally speaking
I would recommend against making those
performance optimizations unless you
really need them let's jump into the
assignment it says fix the bug in the
send message function it's supposed to
print a nicely formatted message to the
console containing an sms's recipient
and message body however it's not
working as expected okay so let's run
the code
and we get these kind of weird weird
looking values that are getting printed
here in the two and the message Fields
now this is hexadecimal it's not binary
it's not decimal it's hexadecimal and
this is the default formatting for a
memory address so we have these
ampersands here they're creating
pointers too
the underlying values that's not what we
want it's not what we want here right
that's why this looks disgusting we need
to dereference or sorry we need to
remove the reference I guess dereference
um
we need to remove the Ampersand so that
we are no longer creating pointers so
run it again
and we get the values themselves which
is what what we've been asked to do
let's recap some syntax sometimes it can
get a little confusing between the
asterisk and the Ampersand what each of
them mean and in what context so when
we're talking about the type of a
variable in go a Pointer's type is
star and then you know the type of the
underlying value so a pointer to an INT
is star int
an ampersand is used to reference a
value so if we want to create a pointer
to the my string variable or the my
string value then we use an ampersand so
the Ampersand followed by the name of a
variable creates a pointer to that
variable now here's where it can get
just a little bit tricky
the asterisk is again used to
de-reference a pointer so the asterisk
is used in a Pointer's type it's also
used as an operator to dereference a
pointer so when we say
asterisk my string pointer this refers
to the underlying value so we can
actually change the underlying value Say
by assigning it to in this case a new
string so in short ampersands to create
new references or new pointers to a
value and the asterisk is used to
de-reference a pointer and get back at
that underlying value let's hop into the
assignment it says complete the remove
profanity function it should use the
strings dot replace all functions this
is a built-in function in the standard
library in the strings package to
replace all instances of the following
words in the input message with
asterisks it should mutate the value in
the pointer and return nothing do not
alter the function signature Okay cool
so remove profanity takes as input a a a
message variable which is a pointer to a
string so because it's a pointer we're
going to be able to mutate it without
returning anything explicitly okay let's
jump into it so first thing we're going
to do is dereference
the message pointer and store
its value in a new variable called
message value
and then we'll just update this
by using that strings dot replace all
functions strings dot replace all
we want to replace the values in message
value we want to or I should say we want
to replace substrings from message value
we'll look for the word dang and we'll
replace it with four asterisks
and we want to do the same thing twice
more
with shoot which has five letters so
let's add an asterisk and heck
which has four so that should be good
cool let's let's run this I need to
import the strings package before I
forget and see what happens
so
in its current state we actually did not
update anything right shoot is still
there dang is still there that's because
we actually need to
point the message
pointer to a string back at the updated
value so we can do dereferenced message
equals
message value
let's run that
perfect
let's submit it
now we've got a pointer quiz so the
question is what is the value of
Ampersand y after the code on the left
executes
so we've got X set to 50 Y is a pointer
to an integer
okay well in this case it's just going
to be 100 because we're explicitly
setting it to 100 on the last line of
the code
so that one was pretty easy now this
question is a little trickier it says
what is the value of x after the code on
the left executes well X is set to 50.
Y is a pointer to X
and then we dereference y instead equal
to 100.
so that's actually also going to be 100
because we're setting X through Y which
is a pointer to X
I mentioned earlier that pointers can be
dangerous and that is definitely the
case if a pointer points to nothing then
it's zero value is nil right so this is
the same for interfaces or errors right
in go fairly often you'll be checking at
runtime if a value is nil or not and the
thing about pointers is if you ever try
to de-reference a pointer that doesn't
point to anything your code will Panic
so pretty much any time you dereference
something you should be checking before
you dereference it to make sure that the
pointer actually points to a valid
location in memory so this assignment
says let's make our profanity Checker
safe update the remove profanity
function If the message is nil return
early to avoid a panic okay so let me
run it in its current state and you'll
see we get this nasty Panic here it says
invalid memory address or nil
okay so what we need to do here is if
message
equals equals nil
return
nothing right if we've been given an
invalid input we'll just bail early
another way to do this if the assignment
expected something different we could
return an error here right we might do
something like return errors.new invalid
input I think that would also be a good
way to write this function but we've
been asked to just do a naked return so
we will do that let's submit it
so let's talk about how pointers are
used in conjunction with methods so
you'll very frequently see that methods
actually take a pointer receiver rather
than a non-pointer receiver and
typically that's done because the method
will be making changes to the instance
of the type itself in this case a struct
right so we have this car with a color
field and the set color method on the
car is going to change the color right
and so here if we create a new car we
set the color to blue and then print it
you can see it's been updated to Blue
instead of white now contrast that with
a non-pointer receiver
this acts like a normal function right
we don't have a pointer so we don't have
a reference to the location in memory so
if we update the car's color to Blue it
actually just stays white it doesn't
persist that change so that's why I say
that it's uh more common that you'll see
pointer receivers on methods than
non-pointer receivers but but you will
definitely see both so the question is
which is more widely used in go and the
answer is pointer receivers now when it
comes to pointer receivers one thing
that's important to understand from like
a syntactic point of view is that even
though the uh the input on the left hand
side right the receiver is a pointer
when you actually call the method you
can call
in this case right the grow method you
can actually call it on just a normal
value or a pointer it will sort of cast
the value under the hood to a pointer if
it isn't one already right so C in this
case is just a circle it's not a pointer
to a circle but when we call C dot grow
the pointer to the circle is passed into
the method so we didn't need to kind of
explicitly you know cast c to a pointer
to a circle by you know adding an
ampersand right here
okay so with that understood
um let's move on to the assignment so
the assignment says fix the bug in the
codes that set message sets the message
field of the given email structure and
the new value persists outside the scope
of the set message method Okay so we've
got this email struct we've got the set
message uh the set message
method
if I run the code in its current state
we've got before messages my first draft
Sandra Bullock after looks identical
right and if we go and take a look at
the test Suite then we can see
that
set message is being called this is my
second draft so we would have expected
this message to say this is my second
draft instead of this my first draft the
reason it's not happening is because
this function essentially doesn't do
anything this method does nothing
because
this is not a pointer to an email
let's go ahead and run that again
first draft second draft perfect
let's submit that
everything we've done up to this point
in the course has been in the browser
we've been writing code right in our
text editor on boot Dev now we're going
to break out of that environment and do
some local development on our own
machine we're going to figure out how to
use the go tool chain to build real
production go programs
but before we do that let's talk a
little bit about packages we need to
understand packages in order to build
our own go programs now you've probably
noticed that up until this point in the
course every coding assignment has had
the words package main at the top of the
file that just means that we've been
writing code within the main package and
that's actually really important the
main package is a special type of
package it's a package that runs as a
standalone program so anytime you're
writing an actual application that you
need to run say on the command line or
as a server you'll be writing code
within the main package a package with
any other name so any name besides main
is a library package and basically what
that means is it's imported by other
libraries and application code so
oftentimes it's just imported by a main
package so that it can use it if you're
familiar with npm from JavaScript or pip
from python that's effectively what a
non-main package is in go it's just some
code that you can publish as kind of a
standalone library that then other
developers can use in their main
packages in their actual applications
so let's take a look at an example here
so you're probably familiar with this
style of code it's what we've been
writing uh all throughout this course
we've been writing within the main
package because we've been writing
executable scripts right code that
actually runs and does something
and then we have this import statement
where we've typically just been
importing from the standard library but
the standard library is made up of
Library packages right like the fmt
package or the Math slash random package
the interesting thing about the main
package is that it always has a main
function and that main function serves
as the entry point to the program so
packages that are not main packages
they're Library packages we'll just
export functions named functions to be
used Again by other libraries and
application code only main packages will
have a main function that runs when the
program starts so to jump into the
coding assignment it just says fix the
bug in the code so let's go ahead and
run the code and see what happens
nothing happens right we're stuck in
this infinite Loop apparently apparently
this code compiles and then does nothing
it's kind of a weird Behavior right in
order to fix this all we need to do is
update this
to be a main package so that we get as
output for our code a runnable
executable a script that we can actually
execute in the browser so let's go ahead
and run that
and we get starting meleosterver
stopping malio server kind of as we
would expect uh based on uh based on
this code here so I'm going to go ahead
and submit that so we're familiar with
main packages but what about Library
packages well by convention a package's
name is the same as the last element of
its import path so for example the math
Rand or Math slash Rand package from the
go standard library has files that begin
with package Rand so the Rand package
lives at Math slash rant now it's
important to point out that the standard
Library actually has another Rand
package at crypto slash rant so they're
both kind of the Rand package but they
have different import paths when a
package isn't part of the standard
Library when for example you make your
own Library package the import path is
typically the same as the remote URL
that you'd use to go look at that
library's source code so for example in
our fictitious maleo products right part
of the textio conglomerate of messaging
products uh they might have their own
GitHub namespace it's slash malio so
github.com malio is their GitHub
organization and then maybe they create
their own package or their own excuse me
repository on GitHub called Rand and
that's where the repository for their
Rand package lives that's where the
source code lives on the internet right
github.com Rand now that package is Name
by convention should be Rand because
that's the last section of the import
path
but that's just a convention they could
if they wanted to change the name of the
package to say random and then all of
the files in their source code would say
package random now again it is possible
to use a different package name one
that's not the same as the last section
of the import path but I highly
discourage it it is best practice to
just use the convention and keep
everything consistent now one last thing
to point out here is that in go packages
live at the directory level rather than
the file level so if you're used to say
python or JavaScript you might be used
to importing code directly from other
files in go if all of the code lives
within the same directory then it's part
of the same package and you don't need
to Import and Export code between files
in the same package or in the same
directory so in go you would only need
to import code if it lives in a
different directory or a different
package and packages and directories are
one and the same you can't have multiple
packages in the same directory so the
quiz question for this section is what
would be the conventional package name
of a package with the path github.com
parser
and the answer is going to be parser
because it should match the last section
of the import path
the next question on the topic of
package naming is given the import path
of path to Rand path slash two slash
Rand which of these is a valid package
name so notice it's not asking which is
a conventional it's asking which one is
actually valid we've got random Rand
spam any of these path well Rand would
be the conventional name but actually
any of these could technically be used
okay it's time to write some go code on
our local machines and you're going to
need three things in order to make it
through the rest of this chapter the
first thing is you're going to need an
editor I'll be using vs code throughout
the rest of this chapter to do all of
our local development stuff you can use
vs code or you can use something else
that you're more familiar with if you do
use vs code you'll probably want to
install the official golang plugin the
next thing you'll need is a unix-like or
sh-like terminal so if you're on macro
Linux then the built-in terminal will
work just fine if you're on Windows you
have a few different options personally
I would recommend installing Ubuntu in
wsl2 I'll link uh in the description
down below how to do that but you will
need to have a terminal in order to
follow along with these instructions if
you choose to use something like the
default Windows command line you're
going to have to change some of the
instructions in the terminal to kind of
translate them to your own machine the
last thing you'll need is just to
install the go tool chain on your local
machine and I would recommend one of two
different ways the first is to use the
official download page and the second is
to use the Webby download script either
of them will work and I've linked to
them both on this page so you can go
check them out and get go download it
now once you've downloaded and installed
go the way you can test to make sure
that everything is working correctly is
type Go version in your terminal if you
get back a valid Go version of at least
version 1.20 which is what I'm using at
the time of recording this video then
you should be good to go now I need to
point out at this point that some people
get confused and think this is Go
version 1.2 it's not it's Go version
1.20 which is the same as Go version
1.20 which is one version greater than
go 1.19 or go 1.19 so make sure that
you're not on Go 1.2 that would be very
very old if you're having trouble
getting go installed so that you can use
it within your terminal the first thing
I'll have you do is definitely try
closing your shell session and
restarting it a lot of times that can
help just getting go into your path if
that doesn't work then Googling around
can be one method to kind of try to
figure out what's going on on your
machine it's really hard for me to kind
of predict what issues you might have
especially considering the fact that Mac
OS windows and Linux can all be a little
different but what I will recommend is
that if you're are having trouble jump
into the boot Dev Discord and ask a
specific question about the trouble
you're having and we'll be happy to help
you out so the question for this step
really just to confirm that we installed
go correctly and that we can use it asks
what does the Go version command print
and if we check the output we can see it
says Go version go 1.20 so that's the
that's the version of the go tool chain
we have uh Darwin I'm on a Mac so this
is like the core Unix operating system
and then amd64 which is my CPU
architecture so it's going to be this
bottom one so we've talked about
packages and we've talked about how
packages exist basically the directory
level and go now we need to talk about
modules a module is a bigger idea than
just a package a module is kind of a
releasable collection of go packages so
sometimes it's just a single package
right you have a single package a single
module and you release it as one package
but other times you might break that
main package up into sub packages and
you'd release all of those packages
together as one go module now a
repository is not a unique idea to go
but it's sort of even greater than just
a module repository or a git repository
is just a collection of code that you
kind of keep in Source control all the
same level and it can contain one or
more modules though it's actually really
common for a single repository to just
have a single go module within it so
while one model repo can have many
different go modules inside of it I
would argue that's not usually the case
typically you'll have one go module
living in one repository that's not a
convention that's just the way I've seen
it more often than not so for the sake
of example let's assume a git repository
that contains a single module and that
means that at the root of the git
repository we'd have a single go dot mod
file that looks something like this the
first line contains the path prefix for
the entire module so remember a module
can contain in multiple packages and
every package in that module its import
path is going to be prefixed with the
path of the entire module the next line
just specifies the Go version and the
last line will specify any dependencies
that this module depends on so to answer
the question what is a go module an
executable main package
um no that could be part of a go module
but it's not a go module itself
a collection of packages that are
released together that is accurate a
file of go code no a module will contain
many many files of go code or a library
package and again no not necessarily you
could have a module that's just a single
Library package but a go module can be
many more packages than that or it could
be a main package for example so it's
going to be a collection of packages
that are released together
so we need to talk just a little bit
more about these import paths now if
you're familiar with npm from the
JavaScript ecosystem cargo from the rust
ecosystem or pip from the python
ecosystem then you're probably familiar
with the idea of a namespace for a
third-party package for example I might
make a package called Left pad publish
it up to npm's Central repository and
now anyone in the world just knowing my
kind of namespace name left pad can
download and use my code as a dependency
the interesting thing about the go
ecosystem is that there is no central
location for third-party packages like
npmjs.com in JavaScript land instead the
goats will chain sort of works on top of
git and actually uses the import path as
the remote URL and it looks to that
import path for where it can go download
code so more often than not you'll see
modules with support pass that start
with github.com or gitlab.com because
that's where the code itself is hosted
an important exception to this rule that
the import path is where you go to
download the code is the standard
Library you don't need to download
standard Library code it comes packaged
with the go tool chain so the question
is do packages in the standard Library
have a module path prefix the answer is
no
the next question is what is an import
path and I know we've already talked
about this but I want to show you a more
concrete example so this is the
github.com wagslane slash go Dash
rabbitmq GitHub repository so this is a
GitHub repository that I maintain it's
just a little package for rabbitmq users
a little go client for rabbitmq so this
is a library module and a library
package it's intended for other
developers to actually import this code
into their applications it's not a
standalone you know main package so
let's take a look at the file structure
at the very root of the repository we
have the go dot mod file now this is
that kind of simple standard setup where
one git repository happens to have one
go module or one sort of releaseable
unit of code and if we take a peek
inside we can see that the go.mod file
specifies the import path github.com
wagslane slash go Dash rabbitmq so this
matches the URL of the git repository
hosted on GitHub now here's the
interesting thing this module only has
one package that's exported to the
outside world and it exists here at this
top level so you can see all of these go
files consume.go consumeroptions.go they
exist at the top level of the repository
so when you import this package to use
it you just import from this root path
because the root package is what you're
importing there are no sub packages to
import here but let's pretend for a
second that we did want to export
another package in the same go module so
we have our top level go module go
rabbitmq and the top level package that
could be accessed at the same import
path as the module let's say we added
another directory we could call it maybe
Network works and inside it would be the
networks package if someone wanted to
import that package then they would take
the import path for the entire module
github.com
which points to the root package like we
already talked about and it would just
append another slash networks onto the
end right so the module path serves as a
prefix for any nested packages
so to answer the original question what
is an import path well it's not an HTTP
connection and it's not a restful server
it's a module path plus an optional
package subdirectory so we've talked
about repositories modules packages
you've got go installed now let's talk
about how you can set up your local
development environment and some of this
stuff isn't going to be necessary and
I'll point that out but I do want to
show you how I've set up my machine and
you can emulate the way I do it if you
like that style now I need to mention
the go path
if you're Googling around trying to
figure out how to set up your local
development environment for go you will
almost certainly come across old
outdated articles that talk about the go
path in kind of any version newer than I
think it's 1.13 right so we're on 1.20
now you can basically forget about the
go path you don't need to worry about it
you used to have to put your code in the
go path now the recommended way is
actually to not put your code in the go
path it can be a little confusing but
again generally speaking you can just
forget about the go path and if you find
any articles that talk about it they're
probably outdated the entire idea of go
modules is what replaced the old go path
so the question is do you need to put
your code inside of your go path the
answers are yes it doesn't matter and no
in fact you shouldn't and actually in
fact you shouldn't
so I've altered my window layout so
that's a little bit easier for you to
see what I'm doing I've got the boot Dev
instructions over here on the left and
then I've got vs code over here on the
right with my terminal at the bottom
cool so I'm just here in my file system
I'm not within the go path I'm just kind
of in my personal workspace and we'll
just follow these instructions it says
create a new directory and enter it so
we'll make directory hello go
and let me just LS show you the new
directory was created and we'll enter
that directory
cool now inside of that new hello go
directory I'm going to create new go
module so we'll do go mod init
and I keep all of my code on GitHub so
I'll do github.com slash my username
because that's my namespace on GitHub so
wagslane slash the name of this project
which we're just calling hello go
cool it says go creating new module now
if I LS I should see that new go.mod
file next let's go ahead and take a look
at that file
so you can see it just created a new
module
github.com hello go with the Go version
and there are no dependencies yet so
there's no other sections to the go
module file so now that we are done with
this step the question is why does go
include a remote URL in module paths
right so this is a remote URL in theory
right when we push this up to GitHub
we'll push it up to this URL and the
answers are to confuse new Gophers uh to
ensure that developers are using Source
control or to simplify remote
downloading of packages and it is
definitely that last one the next
question on the same step asks what is
Hello go in our case the repository
slash directory name or the module path
prefix and in our case it's actually the
name of the repository so again if we
were to push this up to GitHub github's
the name of the website where it's
hosted wagslane is my namespace on
GitHub and hello go would be the name of
the directory that we are in and the
name of the repository up on GitHub
then this next question is just to make
sure that we completed the step properly
what does the first line of go.mod
contain and it contains module followed
by
the module path
now so that vs code will work properly
with all my syntax highlighting with the
go plugin I'm actually going to reopen
uh vs code
to that same directory the hello go
directory so we'll just be working
within this module for a second
and the instructions say inside of hello
go so now I'm inside of this hello go
directory at kind of the top level of uh
my vs code window it says create a new
file called main.go let's go ahead and
do that
conventionally the file in the main
package uh that contains the main
function is called main.go paste the
following code into your file Okay cool
so we should all be familiar with this
code by now right we've we've probably
written code like this uh I don't know
almost a hundred times by now in the
boot Dev platform next it looks like
we're just going to run the code using
the go tool chains interpreter so go run
main.go
and we get a nice hello world printed to
the console there are sort of two main
ways to run go code locally one is with
the go run command like we just used the
other is to use the go build command
which we'll get into in just a second
and actually in general I prefer the go
build method go run is really only
suitable for when you're running a tiny
little scripts like this one and just to
be clear about the difference go run so
go run main.go runs the go code in the
file that we pass in right in this case
main.go and and that's all it does go
build actually builds a production
executable which is how you'll use your
go code in the real world so I typically
prefer building that production
executable just because it's more
accurately reflects how your code will
run in production so the question on
this step is does go run build a
production executable and the answer is
no it just kind of one off runs your
code it doesn't build any production
ready artifacts now at the end of this
same step we're asked to execute the go
help run command in our shell so go help
run which just prints out a bunch of
help information on how to use the go
run command and the question for the
step says which can go run except as
arguments if we scroll to the top so
here's where I ran go help run
uh we can see the usage information and
it says run compiles and runs the named
main go package typically the package is
specified as a list of dot go source
files from a single directory but it can
also be an import path file system path
or pattern matching a single known
package so which can go run accept as
arguments package names file names it
actually looks like it can handle both
great now we get to use go build so you
can for the most part just forget about
go run you probably don't need to use it
all too often so go build compiles go
code into an executable program so all
you need to do is make sure that you're
in the same kind of main package that
you want to build so I'm here in the
hello go directory I can LS to prove it
to you we've got the main.go file here
package main Funk main all that good
stuff we'll run go build
we don't even need to pass in package or
file names it just builds uh the package
of the current directory so as you can
see here we have this new executable
binary in our current hello go directory
now if you remember way back to I think
chapter one of this course we talked
about the difference between interpreted
languages and compiled languages and one
of the amazing things about go is that
we build compiled executables that we
can execute anywhere so this hello go
binary we can now copy this put it on
another machine and run it without even
needing to install the go tool chain on
that machine this is compiled machine
code so we can now run this hello go
program like we would any other
executable dot slash hello go
and it prints hello world now I do want
to show you a little tip here because
every time you update your code let's
say I change this to hello world 2. if I
just re-run hello go it still will just
print hello world and that's because I
didn't re-compile my code so a lot of
new go developers kind of forget to
recompile their code and they think they
have bugs or their code's not doing what
they expect you have to recompile what
I'd recommend doing is just every time
you update your code and want to rerun
it uh you should build and compile and
you can just do it in the same step by
doing go build and then double Ampersand
dot slash the name of your binary so
this basically says compile my code if
that succeeds run the compiled binary
and the question for this step is what
was created after running go build an
executable file named main an executable
file named hello go or a package named
CMD and in this case it was an
executable file named hello go right
we've got it right there it just kind of
defaults to the name of the directory
the next question for this step is what
happens when you run a DOT slash hello
go and I actually change this to hello
world 2 but if we do it again after
changing the code back
um the options are program panics hello
world is printed or the code compiles
um hello world is printed and it's
important to understand here the reason
we don't say the code compiles is
because at this step dot slash hello go
all we are doing is running the compiled
binary we're not recompiling the code
the next command in the go tool chain
that we're going to talk about is go
install now to be honest I don't use it
a ton but I still think it's important
to understand because you'll see it
around okay so ensure you're in your
hello go repo then run go install so I'm
here in the hello go directory and we
run go install
and next we navigate out of our project
directory so I'm going to go up one
level
and what it's telling me is go has
installed the hello go program globally
so the go tool chain when we ran go
install basically compiled that code and
then made it globally accessible to our
entire machine so now if I run a hello
go notice without the dot slash because
I'm not running a program in my current
directory I'm running now a program
that's in my path
it prints hello world so now I can use
this script that I built anywhere on my
machine which is just super useful
um if you're building kind of scripts
for your own local productivity so the
question for this step is what does go
install do saves local code to the
remote Source control provider installs
dependencies or compiles and installs
the program locally and the answer is
that it compiles and installs the
program locally again you would really
only use this if you're building scripts
for your own personal use on your
machine the next question for this same
step is code must be compiled with go
build before running go install it's
true false now if you're paying
attention you probably noticed the
answer here but we actually ran go
install without a binary existing in our
current directory so if I go back into
the hello go directory and run go
install
you'll see there's actually no hello go
binary that exists here and it works
just the same so the code does not need
to be compiled with go build first
all right so we've created a main
package and a executable program now
we're going to build a library package a
custom Library package so uh what we're
supposed to do is create a sibling
directory at the same level as the hello
go directory so I'm in the hello go
directory currently I'm going to go up
one level and let's see so we've got a
hello go in here I'm going to make a new
directory called my strings
and then we'll go into my strings
and here we need to initialize a new go
module so I'll do go mod init
github.com wagslane
slash my strings
and that module is created now to get my
vs code tooling all working properly
again I'm going to just reopen
es code to that level so we'll go back
and find the my strings
directory and open directly into that
directory
okay
next we create a new file called
mystrings.go so this is the go dot mod
that we created with the go mod init
command and now we're creating a new
file called mystrings.go
and we want to paste the following code
okay so package my strings that's the
first thing to notice right this is not
a main package so we won't be able to
build this package as a standalone
executable this package will be kind of
the intention is for us to use it in our
other hello go package
the other thing to notice about this
code aside from the package name is that
there is no main function here again
because it's not an executable program
we're just going to be exporting
functions that can be used in our main
package let's talk a little bit about
this reverse function so this is the
only function in the mystrings package
at the moment and uh you know
theoretically it reverses a string from
left to right although I haven't tested
it
um but the important thing is that we
need to capitalize we need to capitalize
the first letter of the function's name
and that's because in go that's how we
export a function
if it were little r then this function
would not be able to be used outside of
this package but we want to export it
because we want to be able to use it in
our main package right in the hello go
directory and kind of import this logic
and use it now we're told to run the go
build command here in this directory and
you'll notice it doesn't actually seem
to do anything there again there was no
executable file that was built because
this is not a main package but it is
worth pointing out that go build is
still a useful command because it checks
for compile time errors so for example
if I create an invalid token here and
then run go build we will get compile
time errors so it is still kind of
useful just to make sure that this code
compiles so the question for this step
is what was the output of the go build
command in the library package was it an
executable program or was the compiled
package silently saved to the local
build cache well we didn't get an
executable package right this is not a
main package so we don't get get a nice
runnable executable instead it is
silently saved to the local build cache
so it can be used later in an actual
executable program
and then the next question is why is the
function capital r reverse instead of
lowercase R reverse and its lowercase
names aren't exported for external use
or conventionally uppercase names are
used in go the answer is that lowercase
names are not exported so by convention
functions can have either a lowercase
name or an uppercase name and uppercase
names are exported from the package so
this next question is does a package in
a folder named date parser need to also
be called Date parser right does the
package need to be days parser now
you'll notice that we created a
directory called my strings and a
package called my strings and if you
remember back to earlier in this chapter
we talked about how by convention that's
the best way to do it it's not necessary
but it is it is the convention okay so
now let's use our reverse function back
in the main package in the hello go
directory right so it says modify hello
goes main.go so I need to reopen
I'm going to open vs code back into the
hello go directory
it says modify hello goes main.go file
okay so we'll use parentheses here so
that we can do some multiple Imports
and we'll be using the import path that
matches the module name of our mystrings
package so in my case it was github.com
wagslane
slash my strings
and then here we just copy this code
from the instructions and in fact let me
space this out so we can see it just a
little bit better Okay cool so we've
imported the mystrings package and then
down in our code we can use my strings
which is the name of the package dot
reverse
to call that exported function
okay
now because we've added a dependency we
need to update our go.mod file so
edit the hello goes go.mod file to
contain the following
this is the important part down here
so we need to add
replace example.com username my strings
with dot dot slash my strings and
require example.com username slash my
strings version zero now I do need to
update this right because I didn't use
example.com I used github.com wagslane
now what's going on here right
goes dependency management is very
heavily based on git and remote URLs so
normally what you would do is take your
my streams my strings package and push
it up to GitHub and then import it from
there and sort of all of the go packages
in the world that require the my strings
package will point up to that remote
location that remote server what we're
doing here with this replace and require
well specifically the replace is we're
kind of doing a little hack to get
things to work locally without having to
publish to get so we're basically saying
I want you to take this string this
import path right github.com
mystrings and don't go look for it out
on the internet instead just resolve it
to this path dot dot slash my strings
right and now because does well I should
probably get back into the hello go
directory
right dot dot slash my strings this is
the directory containing the mystrings
package right so we're basically just
saying replace this with my local uh
file system we're telling go how to find
this package on our machine so now that
we've made those changes we can build
and run this program again so go build
dot slash hello go
build and run and it looks like it's
working correctly this this function is
supposed to reverse the string and we
get this nasty little
and the question is just asking us what
was printed and that's what we got on
the same step this next question asks
how does the go tool chain know where to
find the imported code
npm hosts the files publicly it
downloads it from Google servers we use
the replace keyword in the gobot.mod to
point it to the relative location of my
strings or it was fetched from GitHub
now again I want to point out that most
of the time you'll be fetching code from
GitHub or gitlab or some remote Source
when you're using third-party
dependencies in our case we used this
replace keyword to point the go tool
chain to the location of the mystrings
package on our machine so we already
briefly talked about this but I just
want to reiterate that this little
replace hack is useful for kind of
testing and doing things on our local
machine but it's not suitable for
production generally what you would do
is push up that my strings git
repository to GitHub and then import
from there so you will typically not see
replace aliases in production go.mod
files very often you'll just see
packages sort of required vanilla from
their remote location so now we're going
to practice using a remote third-party
module says create a new directory in
the same Parent Directory as hellogo and
my strings called Date test so let's go
back up one level
and create a new directory maker
date test
then I'm going to go ahead and again
reopen vs code
into that directory
okay create a main.go with this code
we can do that
next initialize a module so we do
go mod init and again I'll just use
github.com wax Lane slash date test
creating new go.mod to add module
requirements and Subs do go mod tidy
okay cool
um I'm gonna ignore that for just a
second and instead I'm going to follow
the instructions it says download and
install the remote go tiny date package
using go get
Okay so we've used go install in the
past right go install installs and
executable on our machine to be used
anywhere go get is how we go download
and install third-party dependencies so
we're going and grabbing the
github.comytime module
and it gets added automatically
to our go.mod you'll see that it just
kind of grabs the latest version
cool
um print the contents of your go.mod I
don't need to run that because we've got
it open here in vs code and then compile
and run our program again so
let's do that go build
and run and it's going to compile
to
a file called Date test right because
that's the name of our directory
cool and as you can see it's printing
out this date here so what did we do
right we used go get
to download code from this remote
location which also happens to be the
import path right because that's how go
packages work typically so let me go
grab that and just show you this is
this is a package that's hosted on
GitHub so the go tool chain actually
went to GitHub and downloaded this code
right added it to the go dot mod as a
dependency and then created this new
file called go.sum that kind of contains
any uh transient dependencies or
dependencies used by the go tiny time
package that we just imported so it kind
of keeps track of everything that we're
using and the question for this one is
how did the go tool chain know where to
download the Go tiny time package
oh man this uh this question is not
optimized for this ridiculously zoomed
in view it says the module import path
is used for remote lookups EG github.com
go timing time or the go tool chain has
every open source go modules location
memorized uh that is not true it just it
just does a remote lookup right it goes
and fetches that from the remote git URL
and then just to make sure that we did
the step correctly uh it's asking us
what was printed after running the new
date test program you can see it right
there and it looks like it's this
2020-04-03 right it's it's this
hard-coded date in RFC
3339 format
so hopefully that last section gave you
a taste of local development at least
showing you how to build and compile
some code on your own machine we'll
obviously be doing a lot more local
development at the end of this video
with the project but for now for the
rest of this course we'll be back
working in the boot Dev web interface
cool so we're on to talking about clean
packages and this is kind of just a an
article that I'm not going to bother
reading out loud on screen but I'll talk
about each individual section as the
questions are asked so
the question is should you export code
from the main package and that's talked
about down here but it's basically
simple don't export code from the main
package and if you think about it it
makes sense there's no reason to
capitalize function names in the main
package because no other packages can
import from a main package a main
package is built into its own Standalone
executable it's not a library so a
capitalizing functions in the main
package is just kind of confusing
because it kind of signals to developers
that you're writing code that's meant to
be imported and it's not
this next question says when should you
not export a function variable or type
now this is an interesting question I
think a lot of newer developers think
well maybe I should just export more
stuff because maybe the users of my
package will find it useful you actually
want to think in the reverse you want to
export as few things as possible when
you're building Library packages because
anytime you export a function you now
need to support that function right you
can't really take it away later
everyone's code will break right so you
should really think about what you're
exposing to your users as like the
surface area of a shape and you want to
keep that surface area as small as
possible to keep the maintenance burden
down and to make your package easy to
use right the fewer things that your
users need to know about in order to
effectively use your package the easier
it'll be to use so when should you not
export a function variables or type when
the end user doesn't need to know about
it hide everything that they don't need
to to know about the next question is
should you often change a package's
exported API so API stands for
application programming interface and
basically anytime you export something
from a library package you're adding
that thing to the packages API right
it's the interface that other developers
will use to access your package so
should you often change a package's
exported API the answer is that no you
should try to keep changes to your
internal functionality right imagine if
the go programming language let's say
the standard Library changed fmt dot
print line to fft.print right and just
removed fmt.printline that would break
an immense amount of code right so you
don't want to go about publishing
packages that you intend to kind of
update the API for uh very rapidly
stable apis are good apis
so should you often change a package as
exported API no try to keep the changes
to internal functionality yes move fast
and break things or if the package is
main then yes the answer is just no try
to keep changes to internal
functionality again if the package is
main then it's irrelevant because you're
not building a library
I want to talk about the difference
between concurrent or parallel
programming and synchronous or
sequential programming now it's worth
pointing out at this point that
concurrency and parallelism are
different and we'll talk about their
differences in a future course for for
now we're going to kind of treat them as
the same idea and I'll just kind of
refer to them as concurrency similarly
sequential programming and synchronous
they're slightly different terms but I'm
going to kind of bucket them for the
purpose of this discussion we'll be
really comparing uh concurrent code to
synchronous or sequential code so let's
start with the easy one let's talk about
synchronous or sequential programming
say we have some code
X colon equals five
X plus plus and then maybe fmt dot print
dot print
line
X
the nice thing about this code and what
makes it synchronous or sequential is
that the code executes in order from top
to bottom right first we create a
variable named X set equal to five then
we increment it by one and then we print
X right everything's happening in order
from top to bottom one thing at a time
now this is usually what you want it's
simple it's easy to reason about it's
easy to write code this way the problem
is sometimes it's not the most efficient
way to write performance code or code
that can run as fast as possible on a
given set of Hardware so in order to
understand how we can maybe optimize
this we need to look into how your
computer's CPU or Central Processing
Unit works
so your CPU has a clock speed which
basically like from a very high level
means how many instructions how many
instructions
it can do per let's say second those
aren't necessarily the units but it is
basically how many computations it can
do per amount of time you just say it's
seconds to keep things simple
okay so when we're analyzing this code
over here on the right basically what
needs to happen is first we set x equal
to five and that takes up one
instruction right after that we get to
increment X by six that'll take up
another instruction and then we get to
print X so the speed at which we can
execute this little program here is
dependent on how fast the CPUs clock
speed is so if we want our program to go
faster we can basically do one of two
things either we can reduce the number
of instructions required for our program
to execute or we can get a faster CPU
one that can do more instructions per
second the problem is getting a faster
CPU sometimes is really really expensive
and so instead of getting a faster CPU
what we've kind of done over the years
is instead add more CPUs and in this
case we've kind of broken the CPU up
actually into what we call different
cores so you might actually have a quad
core processor Each of which let's say
does I don't know five thousand
instructions per nanosecond I'm totally
making these units up
um but you get the idea any one of these
CPU cores can only do 5000 but the
interesting thing is they can all do
five thousand per nanosecond at the same
time so if we distribute our program
across all of the cores in theory we
should be able to go uh we should be
able to go about four times as fast
again if we use all four cores instead
of just one the problem is that most
code we write can't take advantage of
all four cores for example let's look at
this code over here we set x equal to
five and then we increment it and then
we print it it has to happen in one two
three
right in order one two three we can't do
all of these instructions at the same
time if we did then X plus plus would
have nothing to increment because we
never would have set
um an X variable equal to five in the
first place and print line X would have
nothing to print because X hasn't been
set yet so writing concurrent or
parallel code can drastically speed up
the performance of our programs because
we're able to distribute
um kind of all the instructions that we
need to compute across multiple cores
the problem is we do actually need to
write our code in a different way we
need to expect that some of the
instructions are going to happen at the
same time and that's what's going to
speed up our program so let's say we had
a little bit more code in our program
here maybe we have X or excuse me y
colon equals six
y minus minus
fmt dot print
line
y
okay this code here in this block kind
of dependent on each other right we have
to do it in one two three order and the
same goes for this block here
but we don't have to necessarily do this
block of code where we calculate and
print X before or after we calculate and
print y they're kind of separate in that
way so we can actually do is take this
block of code and execute it in one core
and at the same time execute this other
block of code in another core doing them
at the same time so let's sort of
visualize the runtime of this program
here if we run this code synchronously
or sequentially right not taking
advantage of two CPU cores but instead
of doing it all in one core then our
running time might look something like
this
I don't know let's just say six
nanoseconds
but instead if we run it across two
cores in parallel
each core executes at the same time
and they'll each take approximately
let's say three nanoseconds
so we're done in half the time again
because we took advantage of the
hardware that was available to us so to
wrap up writing concurrent code in many
cases can drastically reduce kind of how
long it takes to run our programs and it
depends just a little bit on kind of
fundamentally what we are trying to do
so in this case we literally could take
a program and chop its run time in half
by utilizing a little bit more Hardware
so this chapter is going to be all about
concurrency in the go programming
language and the great thing about go is
how easy it makes it to write concurrent
code so the question is how do we write
concurrent code in go what's the syntax
well there's actually a really awesome
built-in keyword to the go program
language the go keyword and it spawns a
new go routine when you use it now a go
routine is kind of unique to the go
programming language but at a high level
you can just think of it as a a separate
thread of execution we're essentially
telling the go programming language hey
all this stuff in this function right
that I'm calling with the go keyword can
happen in parallel right we can go
execute that on another core of the CPU
if we need to so whenever we use the go
keyword execution kind of immediately
jumps to the next step after the
function call right so this do something
function will kind of go be executed in
parallel right and then execution
continues in the current function I'm
kind of just on the next line and then
as a last note before we jump into some
code to see how this really works when
we use the go keyword we are not able to
capture any return values from this
function call which makes sense right
because we're kind of moving on we can't
wait for the function to finish and
return some stuff that's the whole point
we want the function to go kind of do
its thing on another thread so let's try
this out in an assignment it says Emilio
we send a lot of network requests right
requests over the Internet each email we
send must go out over the internet to
serve our millions of customers we need
to we need a single go program to be
capable of sending thousands of emails
at once right so we need to be able to
do lots of things at once this is what
go routines allow us to do
edit the send email function to execute
its Anonymous function concurrently so
that the received message prints after
the send message so let's go ahead and
run the code in its current state
and we get email received hello there
Stacy email sent hello there Stacy right
so it looks out of order
now here's our send email function it
takes a message
as a string parameter
and the interesting thing is it calls
this Anonymous function here right so
it's defining this function and then
immediately calling it where it's going
to wait for 250 milliseconds and then
print email received and then this
function will exit
and it will print email sent right and
then print the message so again that's
why this is out of order right we're
we're executing this function first and
then we're moving on to the next line
so the way we fix this is by using the
go keyword
to execute this bit of code at the same
time as this bit of code right the go
keyword will immediately move down to
line 13 on the main thread or the main
go routine and spawn a new go routine to
kind of do this in the background and
because of this waiting time the email
received message should happen
afterwards so let's go ahead and run
this again
sent received sent received looks good
to me
so you may have been thinking to
yourself well how useful is it to call a
function in a go routine if I can't even
get the return values the answer in go
is that we use channels typically to
kind of re-synchronize our code so
typically we'll use go routines or the
go keyword plus sum function let's go do
a bunch of computation all at the same
time and then we can kind of
re-synchronize either in the main go
routine or in some other go routine by
passing data back and forth between go
routines using channels a channel is
really just a thread safe or go routine
safe Q we can put stuff in one end and
read it out the other end in the same
order so we'll typically have one or
more go routines kind of sending data
into the channel maybe they finished a
calculation they're returning their
results over the channel and it'll have
one or more go routines on the other end
reading that data off of the channel and
processing it some way maybe sending a
report maybe printing it to the console
so this is the Syntax for making a
channel and channels are typed so we can
say this is a channel of integers
and then we can send data into the
channel using this Arrow operator it's
it's really pretty intuitive we're
saying 69 is being sent into the channel
and then it's actually the same operator
to read a value out of a channel we just
move it over to the other side again
super intuitive we're reading a value
out of the channel and saving it into
the variable V in this example now it's
important to understand that the both of
these operations sending and receiving
on a channel are blocking operations so
if I'm trying to send a value into a
channel and there's no other go routine
on the other side that will be able to
read it out then my code will actually
stop and wait on this go routine until
there is a reader ready and the same
goes for reading when a go routine gets
to this section of code if there's
nothing being sent into the channel on
another go routine then this code will
just sit and wait until something is
sent so let's move on to the assignment
it says run the program you'll see that
it Deadlocks and never exits so a
deadlock is basically when all of the go
routines in a program are blocking and
there's nothing for them to do it means
there's a bug in the code so let's run
the code just to see what that feels
like although
I think it's just going to feel like
it's running the code for a long time so
I'm going to go ahead and cancel that
filter old emails function is trying to
send on a channel and there's no other
go routing running that can accept the
value from the channel okay so let's
take a look filter all the emails take
some emails as an input create an is old
Channel and that looks like it Loops
over the emails and if they are before a
certain date it's going to pass the
Boolean true into the channel otherwise
it's going to pass in false and then
once that Loop exits
it's going to read out
of the channel here and print to the
console you know whether or not the
emails were old okay cool
so this makes sense this makes sense why
this is blocking right this first send
either here or here whichever one
happens first is going to block because
the reader
like that code hasn't happened yet this
is the same this is the same go routine
right this is not happening at the same
time as this is happening so we'll use
the go routine to fix it fix the
deadlock by spawning an anonymous go
routine to write to the is old Channel
instead of using the same routine that's
reading from it okay cool so we need to
run this Loop essentially in a new go
routine so we'll do go bunk
and we'll just use an anonymous function
here because we don't really care about
naming it
and we'll just run that entire block of
code
in a new and auto suction so now this
and this will happen at the same time
let's go ahead and run that
cool and this looks like what I would
expect I'll go ahead and submit that so
there's this concept of a token when
we're talking about concurrent programs
a token is basically a unary value right
so not binary there's not two possible
values true and false unary there's just
one possible value and when there's just
one possible value we really don't care
much about that value it's not
interesting in any way right so it's not
that we care what is passed when we're
working with tokens it's that we care
when and if something is passed through
a Channel at all so for example this
code here is reading a value out of this
Channel and it's just discarding
whatever it reads out it doesn't even
care what it is it's just waiting to see
kind of when something comes through the
channel so let's move on to the
assignment and kind of put that into
practice it says our malio server isn't
able to boot up until it receives the
signal that all of its databases are
online and it learn about them being
online by waiting for tokens which are
just empty structs on a channel complete
the weight for DBS function it should
block until it receives num DBS so this
integer here tokens on the DB Chan
channel right so this is a channel of
empty structs and again empty structs
are tokens they're unary values they're
not interesting they don't have any
fields
each time it reads a token the get
databases Channel go routine will print
a message to the console for you okay so
I'm guessing that's down here yeah it
looks like it's gonna watch
um and and print here
okay
so let's get started and write some code
it should block until it receives
numdb's token so it's a variable amount
of tokens so I guess the easiest way to
do this would be for with a loop so 4 I
clone equals zero
I is less than num DBS
I plus plus
and then in here we're just going to
wait for a token to come across the DB
channel right so it'll block once and
then we'll move on to the next iteration
of the loop block again move on until
we've waited for you know numdbs tokens
um and then block until it receives the
tokens each time reads a token
that's it looks like we don't have to
return anything so let's run that
database one is online two is online
this looks good to me so now let's talk
about buffered channels so the channels
we've been using up until this point
haven't really stored anything in them
right we needed a sender and a receiver
at the same time as soon as the sender
sends the receiver receives there's
nothing kind of stored in the channel at
any given time but that is exactly what
a buffered channel is so we have a
buffer of some length let's say five
different items and senders can actually
send into the channel even when there's
no receivers until the buffer fills up
so a sender could send five things into
the channel and then the buffer is full
the channel is full right and when a
receiver finally goes to read and pop
items off of the other end it will read
and pop them off in order one by one
until the channel is empty
so this is the syntax we'd use if we
want to make a Channel of integers with
a buffer size of 100. we just use that
optional second parameter to the
built-in make function so let's move on
to the assignment it says we want to be
able to send emails in batches a writing
go routine will take an entire batch of
email messages to a buffer channel uh
we'll write an entire batch of email
messages to a buffer Channel and later
once the channel is full a reading go
routine will go read all of those
messages so we can actually go find
where that's happening here in the test
Suite
okay here so send emails
um oh nope this is where they're getting
read I'm sorry ah I'm silly the function
that we'll be working on is what's
writing into the channel so emails to
send is the channel we're supposed to
write an entire batch of emails into the
channel and theoretically sometime in
the future
those emails will be read out of the
channel and actually sent off okay
cool so what happens if I run the code
in its current state
kind of imagining that it's going to
block forever
yeah that's never going to exit so add
emails to queue is getting called here
and send emails is getting called here
and notice that they're getting called
on the same they're both running in the
same go routine
Right add emails to queue is there's no
go keyword anywhere that I see so that's
why we are blocking here
there's no reader on the other end
right but because we want to do this
batching we actually should be able to
do it all on the same thread
we just need a big enough batch size so
we need a buffer
if we buffer this emails to send Channel
with the length
of the emails slice
then we should have enough room to push
all of the emails into the buffer
Channel let's go ahead and try that
cool that looks like it is working
channels and go can actually be closed
and there's really only one reason you'd
want to close a go Channel and it's to
indicate that you're done with it
a channel should always be closed from
the sending side so the sending go
routine the one that's pushing values
into the channel will be the one to
close the channel and that will indicate
to any readers of the channel That this
channel is closed there's nothing else
to read from it and the actual syntax is
really simple it's just the built-in
close function where we pass in the
channel itself now on the reading side
we can actually check if a channel is
closed using this kind of optional
second variable that comes back when
reading a channel this OK variable it's
a Boolean if the Boolean is true the
channel is open if it is false the
channel is closed if the channel happens
to be buffered then OK will remain true
until the channel is emptied out so OK
will only be false once the buffer
channel is empty and closed the last
thing I'll mention before we jump into
the assignment is that you never want to
send a value across a closed Channel if
you do that go routine will panic and
that's why it's really important that
you only ever close a channel from the
sending side because that go routine is
going to be the one that knows when it's
done sending values okay on to the
assignment it says Emilio we're all
about tracking what our systems are up
to with great logging and Telemetry the
send reports function sends out a batch
of reports to our clients and reports
back how many were sent across the
channel it closes the channel when it's
done okay so the send reports function
here
sends the reports or sends the number of
reports across the channel and closes
the channel great
complete the count reports function it
should use an infinite for Loop to read
from the channel if the channel is
closed break out of the loop otherwise
keep a running total of the number of
reports sent and return the total number
of responses Okay cool so first things
first
we need to keep track of a total
so let's start at zero
and we know that at the end of the
function we'll be returning
the total
right
and it says use an infinite for Loop to
read from the channel okay so four
um and then we need to read from the
channel so we'll do
um
numsense
and read from the numset channel
okay if the channel is closed break out
of loop ah right so we need to use that
syntax to check if the channel is closed
so if not okay if the channel is closed
then we'll return
total
or I suppose we're returning down here
so we could just break let's just do
that instead
break
otherwise uh we do total plus equals num
sent and it's important to understand
that as soon as okay is false num sent
will just be a zero value so it's not a
valid value that was sent across the
channel
so it's safe to just just break like
that
okay cool this is looking correct to me
let's go ahead and run that
let's see batch of 15 38 and 61 Cent do
those add up to 114 uh it looks like
they might uh like my terrible in in my
head arithmetic says that that's perfect
so I'm going to go ahead and submit it
the range keyword works with channels as
well as slices and Maps so we can
actually range over the channel and it
will block until a value is ready it
will read it into in this case the
variable item and then execute the body
and it will do that over and over and
over for each new value coming across
the channel
um and we'll only exit the loop once the
channel is closed so onto the assignment
it says it's that time again malio is
hiring and we've been assigned to do the
interviews for some reason the Fibonacci
sequence is melio's interview problem of
choice we've been tasked with building a
small toy program that we can use in the
interview
okay so complete the concurrent
Fibonacci function if you're not
familiar with the Fibonacci sequence I
don't want to go like too crazy far into
it but it's basically this sequence of
numbers here where
each number
is the sum of the two proceeding numbers
so one and two equal three two and three
equal five in fact you probably can't
even see that let me Zoom this in a
little bit
so one and one or one and two equal
three two and three equal five three and
five equal eight right so this is just
this kind of set sequence of numbers
okay complete the concurrent FIB
function it should create a new channel
events so let's go ahead and do that
so Channel ins
make
Channel events
great
call Fibonacci in a go routine passing
to it the channel
and the number of Fibonacci numbers to
generate okay so we have a Fibonacci
function here
and it takes the numbers and the channel
itself so let's start a go routine
in an anonymous function go funk
call the function
um and in here we call Fibonacci let me
just copy and paste that because I can't
spell it
uh it takes n and
this channel of ins as input okay
then use a Range Loop to read from the
channel and print out the numbers one by
one each on the line okay so the
Fibonacci function is going to pass its
results back over this channel so it's
it's taking the channel and it's going
to act as the sender on the channel so
we down here below kind of where we're
spawning that go routine need to act as
the reader so for the range Channel
events
print out the numbers one by one
print line V
and then when the Fibonacci function is
done it will close the channel so we'll
exit from the loop
cool let's go ahead and run that
does this look accurate 10 numbers zero
and one zero plus one is one one plus
two is three two plus three is five
looking good to me on to select
statements so a select statement is
similar to a switch statement if you're
familiar with switch statements from
other languages or from go or it's kind
of this if else uh chain and we're
really looking to kind of match a
specific case but what's interesting
about select statements is they're
unique to channels and they basically
let us listen on two different channels
and kind of execute one block of code or
or rather execute a block of code for
the channel that sends a value the
soonest so we can kind of simultaneously
listen on both channels and if this
channel sends a value first then we'll
do you know one thing otherwise when
this one sends something we'll do
another thing so one go routine can kind
of process events from multiple channels
at the same time using a select
statement so this this is the syntax
here we create a select block and then
multiple cases one for each channel that
we are interested in kind of listening
for values on or reading values off of
so if this channel ins has a value ready
then this case will be executed
otherwise if this one if Channel strings
has a value ready then this case will be
executed if both have a value ready at
the same time then one will be chosen
randomly so you don't want to kind of be
dependent on any weird ordering
basically as stuff comes across it's
going to get processed so on to the
assignment says complete the log
messages function use an infinite for
Loop and a select statement to log the
emails and SMS messages as they come
across the two channels okay so channel
of emails channel of SMS messages add a
condition to return from the function
when one of the two channels closes
whichever is first use the log SMS and
log email functions to log the messages
Okay cool so uh infinite for Loop start
there and inside we'll need to select
can use this as our syntax guide over
here we've got case uh email
okay
value from Channel emails
if that case fires and we say if not
okay so if the channel is closed we just
return and this function returns nothing
so we can just make it return
otherwise we need to log email I think
that's
it log email there it is
the email
cool other case uh sms okay from the
channel of SMS
if not okay
return
otherwise
log the SMS
right
so this for Loop will just go forever
until one of these two channels closes
in which case it will return
right and it's important that we return
before we do the logging because when a
channel closes the OK variable is false
and a zero value comes across the
channel
that wasn't sent into the channel that
makes sense like the closure happens
after the last value comes out
let's go ahead and run that
looking good to me we'll submit it
the select statement also has a default
case you don't always need to use the
default case and basically the default
case only fires if you're interested in
non-blocking so for example this select
block here will fire the case uh that
kind of pulls this V value out of this
channel if there is a value ready to be
pulled at the time that we enter the
select block if there's not a value
ready to be read out of the channel then
the default case is fired immediately so
it kind of turns the select block into a
non-blocking block of code and then
there's a few things we're going to need
to know for this assignment the first
are these uh there's several standard
Library functions so time dot tick
returns a channel that sends a value on
a given interval so we could say pass in
a second to time.tick and we would get
back a channel that receives a value
once per second pretty cool for like
rate limiting doing something on a set
interval time dot after sends a single
value after the specified time has
passed so if we've created a new Channel
with time.actor and passed in one second
then one value would come across after a
second had passed and then the channel
would be closed
um time dot sleep just blocks for the
specified amount of time in fact I think
we've kind of seen it around um so far
in the course
and we have read only and write only
channels and these are pretty cool from
like a type safety standpoint basically
we can take a channel and we can pass it
into a function but specify that within
the function we are just going to read
from it so then within the function the
compiler will not allow us to write to
it so this is a great way to kind of
keep a go routine safe in terms of which
functions are readers of channels and
which functions are writers of channels
and we do the same thing with writers by
using this syntax here so readers read
out of the channel writers right into
the channel the assignment says like all
good backend Engineers we frequently
save backup snapshots of the maleo
database complete the save backups
function okay it should read values from
the snapshot ticker and save after
channels simultaneously okay so the
ticker and the save after these are
channels that are created down here
using those standard Library functions
that we just talked about
okay
so we need to use a select statement it
looks like read values continuously so
I'm going to use a for Loop
and a select statement
if a value is received from snapshot
ticker call take snapshot Okay so
case Val okay
we want to read out of a snapshot ticker
um do we actually do we care about the
channel being closed let's see I assume
saved after no actually we don't so we
just need
the value from snapshot ticker
oh and we don't even care about what the
value is so we can just completely
ignore the value
um call take snapshot
okay
if the value is saved after so case
save after
call Save snapshot
and return from the function because
we're done okay
so again we don't need to return
anything from this function it doesn't
have any return values if neither
channel has a value ready call wait for
data okay so default
wait for data
and then sleep for 500 milliseconds so
time.sleep
time dot millisecond
times 500.
okay
this is looking good so we've got this
infinite for Loop we'll we're looking
for values
um that are coming across these channels
anytime a snapshot should be taken we
take it anytime this save after Channel
passes us a value we will save the
snapshot and exit the function otherwise
we'll wait for data whatever that does
and sleep for 500 milliseconds in fact
I'm curious what does wait for data do
okay so all these do
um is kind of Print Different messages
so let's go ahead and run that
Okay cool so nothing to do waiting
nothing to do waiting right so every 500
milliseconds we're kind of logging out
that we're waiting we're waiting for
things to to do
um taking back backups taking backups
and
um finally saving the backups at the end
cool let's submit this this looks
correct to me
Dave Cheney is a fantastic author and
contributor to the go programming
language and the go ecosystem and he has
this awesome article that I would
definitely recommend checking out it's
called Channel axioms I've kind of
summarized it here and we're going to
talk about a few key points so the first
is that Ascend to a nil Channel blocks
forever so the zero value for a channel
is nil if you don't use the make
function to initialize a channel then
the Channel's value is just nil and if
you try to send on a nil Channel your
code's just going to block forever
similarly a receive from a nil channel
will just block forever now this one's a
lot more dangerous trying to send on a
closed Channel panics so you need to be
really careful and make sure your only
closing channels from the go routine or
the function that's writing to the
channel so that you can be sure you'll
never try to write to that closed
Channel again and then a receive from a
closed Channel Returns the zero value
immediately so if you're trying to pull
data out of a channel and it's already
closed you'll just get the zero value
and we've already seen how you can also
kind of optionally check for that okay
value which will be returned as false so
what happens when you read from a Nils
channel uh the receiver will block
forever and what happens when you send
to a closed Channel you'll get a panic
and you never really want to panic and
go that's almost always indicative of a
bug
so channels are one tool that we have in
go to sort of synchronize State across
different go routines right we can send
data from one go routine to another
safely mutexes are another built-in
primitive well rather they're not built
into the language but they're built into
the standard library and they allow us
to also sort of communicate or share
data between to go routines mutexes work
by locking access to protected resources
so that only one go routine can access
that resource at a time so the
sync.mutex type
is exposed by the standard library and
basically the way it works is you create
a new mutex and then you share it across
many different go routines
and then you wrap whatever code that
that is dangerous or whatever resource
that is dangerous
um that you never want to go routines
the same time kind of getting access to
you wrap them in a call to lock and
unlock so for example in this function
we have this protected function and it
calls mutex.lock at the top of the
function and then it defers an unlock
and what this means is when one go
routine calls this protected function if
it's the first call to this protected
function then this mux.lock will lock
the mutex for this go routine and it
will be able to move on and kind of
complete the rest of the function and
then call mutex.unlock every other go
routine
that calls this function right on this
shared mutex will actually block at the
mux.lock function call
because the mutex is locked by another
go routine so mutex stands for Mutual
exclusion because it excludes every go
routine except one except for the one
that holds the lock and once that first
one actually unlocks the mutex then one
other go routine is able to pick up the
lock execute its protected code and move
on from there so it's a way to take some
dangerous resource and sort of share it
across many different go routines safely
there are a couple of different reasons
why why you would want to protect a
resource and only allow a single go
routine to kind of work on that resource
at a time but one super common one is
Maps so maps are not thread safe and go
if two different go routines are trying
to read from and write to the same map
go will actually panic because that has
a very high likelihood of causing a race
condition and if you're wondering what a
race condition is a race condition is
kind of what it sounds like it's when
two different go routines are
effectively racing to get access to a
specific resource so imagine a case
where we have a count variable and it's
set equal to maybe five and you have one
go routine that reads that count
variable and saves it into say another
variable my count right and then maybe
doubles it and then saves the doubled
value back into account
well what if we have another uh thread
of execution doing the same thing if
they both read count let's say they both
read five double
five so now they both store 25 and they
both go to write 25 back into the
variable
all you did was double five once where
you were probably expecting to have two
different threads doubling the variables
you you probably were expecting for it
to go 5 to 25 and then double again 25
squared
6 25 I think um the point is depending
on exactly how those operations are
threaded into the CPU you'll actually
get different Behavior so race
conditions are awful to debug and
mutexes allow us to lock access to those
protected variables so we could wrap
that count variable in a mutex to avoid
it being accessed at the same time by
different go routines
so this should make a lot more sense
once we write some code the assignment
says we send emails across many
different go routines at Amelia to keep
track of how many we've sent to a given
email address we use an in-memory map
Okay so we've got this counts map stored
within a safe counter struct the map is
of string to integer and then we've got
a pointer to a mutex that we're sharing
across all of these different go
routines
our safe counter struct is unsafe update
the increments and the value methods so
they utilize the safe counters mutex to
ensure that the map is not accessed by
multiple go routines at the same time
Okay so we've got the safe counter and
it looks like it's going to be kind of
copied across different go routines so
we create one instance of the safe
counter it's getting passed into this
test function and then we've got this go
routine
um it looks like we're spawning go
routines in a for Loop and then uh and
then using that safe counter right so
increment is being called many different
times across many different uh threads
of execution and that is not safe
cool
um so let's see what happens if I run
the code right now
Jill has three emails John has four
and if I look down into the tests like
that is wildly inaccurate right so it
kind of looks like what's happening is
is like the example I described where
maybe you're multiplying numbers
together at the same time so you kind of
end up with a smaller number because
everyone's doing it at the same time
then saving the variable back it kind of
looks like that's what's happening we're
getting these tiny results because all
of these different go routines are
incrementing uh the number at the same
time
okay
so we need to lock this down
foreign
the mutex and then defer the unlock
it's important to understand that we
could do this and it would be the same
um right we lock we do the dangerous
thing and then we unlock
um but this is the preferred
the preferred way kind of the idiomatic
go way to do it
um it's just it's just a little safer
right if we add multiple Returns the
defer will never not execute so that's
how we're going to do it and then we
also need to lock on the Val function
because reading and writing at the same
time is also dangerous
cool let's run that see if we get some
bigger numbers in our counts
notice it's taking a lot longer
to run and and that's because we're
locking and unlocking so every thread
has to kind of go one after the others
so it slows it down but it's a lot safer
so we get these accurate counts let's go
ahead and submit that
so as we discussed a mutex is called a
mutex because it's short for Mutual
exclusion and the conventional name for
a mutex is mutex or sometimes it's
abbreviated to mux personally I use mux
a lot
so to answer the question what does it
refer to it's going to be mutual
exclusion the next question is how many
threads or go routines can lock a mutex
at once or at the same time the answer
is one right if any more could lock it
at the same time it wouldn't be very
useful
the next question is why would you use a
mutex to safely access a data structure
concurrently to stop other packages from
using my code to protect data from
network access or to encapsulate private
data members of a struct it's going to
be to safely Access Data concurrently
time to talk about another type of mutex
so we've already covered pretty much all
of the functionality you need to know
about the sync.mutex type but there's
another type there's a sync.rw mutex or
sync.read write mutex so the sync dot
read write mutex has a little more
functionality it has the same lock and
unlock methods and works exactly the
same way as a normal mutex but
additionally it has two more methods r
lock and R unlock so the reason you
would use a read write mutex is because
it allows you to have multiple readers
at the same time for example it's
actually safe to read from a map on
multiple go routines at the same time as
long as you're not reading and writing
at the same time or writing and writing
at the same time writing is the
dangerous operation so the way this
works is if the mutex is locked like
with the Dot Lock method then no other
go routines can lock or r lock the mutex
however if the mutex is just are locked
then other mutexes can still are locket
so you can get multiple readers but you
can't get readers and writers or writers
and writers it just allows many threads
to concurrently read so what this does
is if you have a program with a shared
resource where most of the threads are
interested with reading the shared
resource and you only have a few writers
you can make your code a lot faster by
using a read write mutex and allowing
multiple readers at the same time your
code will move faster and have fewer
locks slowing down and synchronizing
your application so onto the assignment
it says let's update our same code from
the last assignment but this time we can
speed it up by allowing readers to be
read from the map concurrently update
the vowel method to only lock the mutex
for reading notice that if you run the
code with a right lock it will block
forever Okay cool so if I try to run it
right now it's going to have issues
because I believe believe it is are
locked
by the test Suite out of the gate so
that's a problem we can fix it
by changing those to our lock and R
unlock
perfect looks good to me I'm gonna go
ahead and submit that
so a quick review on read write mutexes
how many writers can access an RW mutex
at once or at the same time uh the
answer is one and how many readers can
access nrwmutex at once it's going to be
infinite there is no limit
the next question is can readers and
writers use RW mutexes at the same time
the answer is still no right no one can
use the mutex if it's being written to
generics are an amazing new feature in
the go programming language at least
they are new as of the time of this
recording we're on version 1.20 now and
generics were just released in 1.18 and
they were one of the most widely
requested features by go developers so
let's talk about what generics are and
why they're so useful
let's take a look at this code here we
have a function called split int slice
so it takes a slice of ins and it splits
it into two smaller slices of integers
it effectively just splits the slice in
half and returns to new slices the
really interesting thing about this
function is that if you take a look at
the function body
it doesn't actually care that this is a
slice of ins it could be a slice of
strings or a slice of booleans the logic
and the function body would be the same
right it would calculate kind of the
midpoint of the slice and return two new
slices with all the values up to that
midpoint the annoying thing is that
prior to generics in version 1.18 if we
wanted to split a slice of strings we
would actually need to write an entirely
separate function because in go we have
static typing and we need to tell the
compiler what type of slice it is that
we are splitting now it is true that
prior to generics you could write a
function that takes a slice of the empty
interface which is essentially a slice
of anything and then returns to slices
of the empty interface the problem with
that is that you need to cast the return
values back into whatever they were
which is kind of a dangerous runtime
check
so generics or type parameters are
really just a way for us to write that
function with the empty interface but do
it in a compiler safe way because if you
think about it the compiler can know
that this function doesn't care about
the types going in but that any time
it's called the types coming out will be
the same as the types coming in so how
does it work well we effectively have a
new type of parameter that can be passed
into a function so after the function's
name we have these optional square
brackets and here we're defining a new
type we're calling it t and we're saying
it is of type any or it can be anything
now because we are using T the type
parameter as both the input and the
output we're telling the go compiler hey
whatever I pass into this function
that's what I'm expecting to get back
out right if I pass in a slice of
integers I expect to get out two slices
of integer so now if we take a look at
how the code is actually used right how
the function is called we can use the
split any slice function give it a slice
of integers and we'll get back to slices
of integers everything is type safe
so in a nutshell the reason to use
generics is to dry up our coat right dry
is just an acronym for don't repeat
yourself it's a way of writing code that
can be reused more easily so instead of
having to write two nearly identical
functions just to deal with two separate
types of slices we can now write a type
safe function once and reuse it
throughout our application so let's Jump
Right In the assignment says at malio we
often store all of the emails of a given
email campaign in memory as a slice we
store payments for a single user in the
same way so those are two very different
things right emails and payments
complete the get last function it should
be a generic function that Returns the
last element from a slice no matter the
types stored in the slice if the slice
is empty it returns a zero value of the
type okay cool let's get started okay so
we can kind of use this syntax as a
guide so we're going to need to specify
a type it can be anything like the
assignment said and we're going to take
his input a slice of that type and
return one element of that type
okay now it says we need to return the
last element from a slice so we need to
slice the slice essentially check its
length right so we can say if the length
of s
is zero so if there's nothing in the
slice we're going to have to just return
uh the empty type of tea
which
down here it says we can create uh we
can create a new empty variable like
this so we'll just do
r
zero Val
and then we'll just return it
Okay cool so if the slice is empty we'll
return the zero value otherwise
we'll return
s at
the length of s minus 1. right okay so
there's nothing in the slice we'll
return the zero value otherwise we'll
return the element in the last index and
the reason we have to do this guard
Clause is because otherwise this would
be an unsafe operation we'd get an index
out of bounds error if we tried to do
this operation on a slice of zero length
so let's go ahead and run it
and it looks like
okay so the test case with a zero length
slice returns an empty struct that looks
correct to me getting last email from a
slice of like three
there's the last one looks like it
returned it correctly and then here we
have payments right so a completely
different type and the last one is Jane
example.com yep that looks correct to me
Margo Margo cool let's submit it so why
are there generics in the go programming
language well there's kind of three main
points that are important to understand
the first as we already covered is that
generics reduce repetitive code so
whenever we have code that doesn't
really care about the type or maybe it
only cares about a small superficial
part of the type then we can write more
abstract and more reusable code if we
have access to generics right because it
keeps the code compile time safe and
type safe before in go if we wanted to
reuse code we had to do sort of
dangerous runtime checking right casting
things to empty interfaces and back from
empty interfaces
it's also important to understand that
generics are going to be used much more
frequently in libraries and packages if
you're say a back-end developer and
you're building applications and not
libraries or packages that are intended
to be used by other people
um You probably don't need to use
generics all that often which is why the
go programming language was able to get
away with not even supporting them for
so long now if you do work on libraries
or packages or maybe you're even a
contributor to the go standard library
then you probably are going to use
generics quite a bit more they'll make
it a lot easier to write more abstract
code that's useful for more and more use
cases the last Point that's important to
understand is just Why did it take so
long to get generics into the language
right they're super useful why didn't we
add them I don't know five years ago or
a decade ago and go was kind of getting
started the answer is that one of the
philosophies behind the go programming
language is just to kind of keep it
simple go doesn't have all that many
features because go developers and go
maintainers don't buy into the idea that
more features necessarily makes a better
programming language by having fewer
features it means there's less to learn
to get up and running with the language
it also means that anytime you see a
piece of go code you'll have an easier
time understanding it and working with
it so even more so than other languages
the go team is very hesitant to add new
stuff so generics were in the works for
a long time and it was only after many
years of thinking about it and making
sure that we really needed them that
they actually got their way into the
language so the question here is what
code would generics be most likely to
help with a binary tree detecting
whether or not a string contains a given
substring or calculating the area of a
circle
well
detecting whether or not a string
contains a substring we'll probably just
use string types and calculating the
area of a circle just sounds like floats
to me but a binary tree is a data
structure that can store any type it's
kind of like you know a slice in that
way so I'm going to go with binary tree
on that one the next question is Ghost
approach to language design is to
support as many useful features as
possible to resist adding new features
until they're extremely important or
proven extremely important or to never
add new features the language doesn't
change and the answer is to just resist
adding new features unless they're
proven to be very very important the
next question is generics will probably
be used more heavily in blank main
packages which are executable
applications or Library packages and I
definitely argue that they'll be more
heavily used in library packages Okay so
we've talked about how generics are
super useful when the type that is being
used in your function doesn't matter
right when it can be anything but
constraints allow us to write generics
that are actually just useful for a
subset of types right so maybe this
function doesn't care too much about the
types that are being used but it does
care a little bit so let's take a look
at an example this concat function
is similar to the other generics that
we've worked with the big difference is
that the type T the type parameter
instead of being able to be anything
we're saying it has to be a Stringer
right we've specified the Stringer
interface here it's just anything with a
string method on it that returns a
string with the built-in any constraint
which is effectively the empty interface
we can't really do anything with the
values inside the functions right which
is why it works for something where
we're just say splitting a slice of that
type
but in this function the concat function
we're actually able to use the type a
little bit we're able to call the method
that's implemented on it and that's just
because the only thing that we know
about these values coming into the
function is that they have that string
method so what does the concat function
do well it takes a slice of stringers
it Loops over all of them
grabs the string representation right by
calling that string method the string
representation of each value and it kind
of just mashes them all together right
it concatenates them and Returns the
result so let's take a look at the
assignment
we have different kinds of line items
that we can charge our customers credit
cards for line items can be things like
subscriptions one Pi or one-time
payments great complete the charge for
line item function first it should check
if the user has a balance with enough
funds to be able to pay for the cost of
a new item okay so we're given a new
item which is of type T doing a slice of
old items and a balance which is just a
float
um if they don't have enough funds then
we'll return an insufficient funds error
but if they do have enough funds then
we'll add the line item to the user's
history by appending new item to the
sliceables old items okay this new slice
is your first return value right so
we're returning three values here so
we're returning kind of the new list of
old items after new item has been
appended
um and we need to calculate the user's
New Balance by subtracting the cost of
the new item from their balance this is
my second return value Okay cool so we
take in their balance we're going to
subtract the cost of the new item and
then return the New Balance
um and obviously if nothing went wrong
we'll return a nil error okay
so we have the type
here as a line item so line item is this
interface and it looks like we we kind
of have these two methods available to
us within our function we can get the
cost of a line item or we can get the
name of a line item so the first thing
our function is supposed to do is check
if the user has a balance with enough
funds so we need to do something like
uh new New Balance
is equal to
balance
minus
the new item
dot get cost
right so we're going to check what the
New Balance would be after subtracting
the cost of the item from the user's
balance then we can say if the new
balance
is less than zero
then we'll return this insufficient
funds error
right and zero values for everything
else so it'll be a nil slice 0.0 float
and
errors dot new insufficient funds
we'll need the errors package
okay cool otherwise that means this uh
this balance is uh zero or greater right
and it says
add the line item to the user's history
by appending it to the sliceable items
so we could do old items equals append
old items new item
okay
this new slice is your first return
value great
otherwise and then calculate the user's
New Balance by subtracting the cost of
the new item from the balance so we
already did that um this is your second
return value so I think we just return
um old items New Balance
and
nil
right
let's go ahead and run that
okay charging customer for a yearly
subscription current balance is one
thousand new balance is 750 total number
of line items is now one
sorry for monthly subscription
new balance is less total number of line
items is now three let's go take a look
at those test cases just to make sure
that this makes sense
okay so they had zero now they have one
subscription
here they had two subscriptions now they
have three subscriptions cool that looks
or three line items that looks good to
me I'm gonna go ahead and submit it when
generics were released a new syntax for
writing interfaces was also released
um partly just because this new syntax
is super useful if you're trying to use
interfaces as constraints for your
generic functions so let's take a look
at an example a type list is pretty much
as simple as it sounds we're basically
just creating a new interface in this
case we're calling it ordered and then
we're just listing all of the types that
we are saying Implement that interface
so there's no methods here but the
interesting thing about all of these
types is that they all support these
inequality operators like less than less
than or equal to greater than and so if
we use ordered as a constraint then
we're free to use these comparison
operators on that type and the question
that goes along with this is why might
you create an interface using a type
list and and the answers are you know
exactly which types satisfy your
interface or it's too much trouble to
define the methods required by your
interface that second one is a bad
reason uh it's it you would really only
do this if you know exactly which types
satisfy your interface let's take a look
at parametric constraints which sounds
like a kind of complex term but it's
actually really simple it basically just
means that we can use type parameters in
interface definitions as well so instead
of just creating interfaces which we
then use in our type parameters for
functions we're actually using type
parameters to Define new interfaces so
for example here we have a store
that takes as a type parameter P which
is a product now a product is just an
interface right it's a product is
anything that can return a price and a
name so a store which is again an
interface is just anything that can sell
a product now the idea really is that
simple if you want to get an idea for
kind of how this whole snippet of code
works the example code I'm not going to
talk through every line that would take
a little bit too long but feel free to
kind of browse through this and get a
feel for how that interface Works we're
going to jump straight into the
assignment so getting onto the
assignment does the Chief Architect at
malio has decided she wants us to
implement billing with generics
specifically she wants us to create a
new biller interface a biller is an
interface that can be used to charge a
customer and it can also report its name
okay so let's take a look at what a
customer is
so a customer is this interface it's
just anything that has a get billing
email method on it
so in this case a user is a customer and
an org is a customer okay
um
and it can also report its name okay
that's simple enough
um there are two kinds of billers user
billers and org Builders Okay so we've
got user Builder here
and org Builder here
create the new biller interface just
have two methods okay so let's go ahead
and do that
type
filler
interface
two methods charge
and name
the good news is the architect already
wrote the user biller and orgular types
for us to fulfill this new Builder
interface right we took a look at that
use the definitions of the types and
their methods to figure out how to write
the biller interface on line seven Okay
cool so let's start with name it looks
simpler so a user biller has a name
method it takes no parameters and
returns a string same with the org
Builder so that one's simple
it just returns a string
okay the charge method for user biller
accepts a user returns a bill
but for the org Builder accepts an org
and returns a bill okay so it always
returns a bill that part's easy
but what it accepts is a little bit
different
right and if we take a look at
the customer interface where did it go
customer interface here
then we see that we have
um
we have this common interface that we
can use to represent both a user
and an org
okay so that's convenient because we can
use that interface right as a parametric
uh constraint so
let's create a new uh
parametric type or you know but we'll
create a new type parameter
call it C because it's a customer
should be easy enough and then charge
will actually take as input C
right it will take a customer rather
than specifically a user or an org
okay let's try that
it compiled at least let's see what we
got using basic user biller to create a
bill for Joe at example.com fifty
dollars basic user biller for Samuel
Boggs
fifty dollars
Pro user Biller
or Jade 100 okay that's looking correct
to me it looks like the pro uh Pro and
basic uh have a discrepancy of fifteen a
hundred dollars and then the org biller
is being used here you can see it's
actually much more expensive so that
looks correct to me so let's talk about
naming generic types we can take a look
at this old example or the example from
earlier in the course where we had to
split any slice right and it has t as a
type parameter of Type n e and then we
use T kind of L throughout the function
signature T is variable name it doesn't
we don't have to
you can name this whatever we want right
we could name it my type
whatever the heck we want right slice
value it doesn't matter however it turns
out that capital t is actually fairly
common convention
um when there is just a single type
parameter for a function
so the question here is the name of a
type parameter blank
can and should be whatever you want can
be anything but T is a common convention
or must be t uh it turns out it can be
anything but T is a fairly common
conventional name
Rob Pike one of the creators of the go
programming language created an awesome
set of Proverbs that outlines some more
of the philosophies behind the language
I'm not going to read them all to you
but I am going to cover some of the ones
that I think are the most important and
if you are interested I'd highly
recommend going and watching his talk
about the Proverbs if you want to go
more in depth on them so let's start at
the top don't communicate by sharing
memory share memory by communicating so
this basically is telling us we should
probably try to use channels more often
than we use mutexes when we're trying to
share memory between go routines
which leads right into the third one
which is channels orchestrate and
mutex's serialize so when we use
channels we get kind of this elegant
flow of data through our program right
one go routine did something another go
routine can react to it mutexes are all
about just locking access to protected
resources if we can use channels to
express logic in our program it will
tend to work a little bit better another
great one is that the empty interface
says nothing right every type in go
fulfills the empty interface you should
really avoid using the empty interface
just because it doesn't tell you
anything interesting about your types
the empty interface is sometimes used by
new go developers to kind of get around
the type system and that just leads to
unsafe code go format style is no one's
favorite and yet go format style is
everyone's favorite so we'll get into
this in just a bit when we jump into the
project but the go tool chain comes with
its own formatter and pretty much every
production piece of go code out there
uses the same formatter which is
fantastic because it means all go code
looks the same while not everyone
necessarily agrees on the formatters
choice of say tabs versus spaces it's
still everyone's favorite because it
means we all get something consistent
that works reasonably well the next one
is one of my favorites it's a little
copying is better than a little
dependency now if you've ever worked in
the JavaScript ecosystem with node
modules you'll know exactly what this
means node modules is typically a huge
folder and a lot of times when you're
working on a front-end framework your
dependencies are much greater than your
actual application code and in go we
typically just kind of inverse that way
of thinking we want our application code
to be the bulk of the code within our
project and we tend to use far fewer
dependencies as almost a philosophy and
this brings us to the one mentioned here
in the question which says which is
better clear or clever and at least
according to Rog pipe clear is better
than clever so if you can write your
code in a way that is very clear to
anyone else reading it or even just to
yourself that's better than trying to do
a trick that might seem clever but is
actually hard for humans to understand
remember code is written for humans not
for machines
the next question is which is better
copying a little code or including a
small dependency and Rob Pike would
argue that it's typically better to copy
a little bit of code rather than include
a very small dependency in your project
the next one I want to point out is that
errors are just values right in GO error
is just a specific interface and we
return it from functions just like we do
any other value there's not some special
way to handle errors with tries and
catches errors are just values and we
deal with them just like we would any
other value
and the last one I want to point out is
that documentation is for users this is
actually an interesting one I think what
he's saying here and I I need to go
re-watch the talk to confirm but that
documentation is primarily for people
who aren't maintaining the code in other
words it's best if the code itself is
really easy to understand so it doesn't
need to be heavily documented so that
other maintainers can work on it right
documentation in the sense that you know
we should be writing external documents
that explain how the code work or how to
use it should be for the users of our
code right in the sense that if we're
writing a library we should be writing
documentation for the users of the
library the developers calling our
exported functions right not the
maintainers of the library itself so
documentation should primarily be
written for the users of your code
it's time to build a fully fledged
backend server in go from scratch on our
local machines the purpose of the server
will be to aggregate data from RSS feeds
if you're not familiar with RSS it's a
protocol that makes Distributing things
like podcasts and blog posts really easy
so what our server will allow users to
do is add different RSS feeds to its
database and then it will go
automatically collect all of the posts
from those feeds and download them and
save them in the database so that we can
then view them later
before we get started there are four
things you're going to need the first is
a basic understanding of SQL the
language that's most often used to query
relational databases if you're not
familiar with SQL yet that's okay I've
got a full course on SQL I'll link that
down in the description below go watch
that then come back here if you're not
familiar with SQL number two is you're
going to need a text editor and a
command line I'm using vs code and zsh
here in the video so you'll see me using
that feel free to go download those if
uh you want to try them out but you can
use whatever text editor you want as
long as it can edit your files and you
have access to a terminal to run
commands number three is the go
programming language itself if you don't
have that you can go download it I will
link the download page down in the
description below and I'd also recommend
just installing the go plug-in if you're
in vs code there is an official go
plugin Go download that it'll make your
life easier with syntax highlighting and
formatting and that sort of thing number
four the last thing you'll need is an
http client so an HTTP client will allow
you to make get and post and put
requests into the web server that we're
building we'll need that for testing I
use the Thunder client it's a vs code
extension but you can use anything you
like even curl on the command line or
Postman insomnia there's tons of choices
Google HTTP clients or if you don't
already have a preference again if
you're in vs code I'd recommend the
Thunder client extension now that you
have all of those tools installed and
hopefully working let's jump into the
project the first thing we're going to
need is just a main.go file we'll create
our entry point it will be a part of the
main package and it will need a main
function so func main takes no arguments
return those returns no parameters and
for now let's just print hello world
make sure we can kind of build and run
this program we're going to need to
initialize a new module for our project
so I'm going to do go mod init
and I like to name my modules after
their remote path right where they will
exist
um kind of out on the internet so in my
case I use github.com my GitHub uh
namespace which is wagslane Slash the
name of this repository which again is
where I'll be keeping this code on
GitHub so I highly recommend you keep
track of this code in GitHub this entire
project should be checked into git and
uploaded to GitHub or gitlab or whatever
you prefer so I'm going to name this
repository
RSS aggregator RSS AG so we'll go ahead
and create that
that will create this new go module
and now that that's ready we should be
able to just go build
and execute the new
um binary or the new executable that
will be created from go Belgium I'll
just run it once so you can see
that created this new binary file here
in my current directory and so from now
on I'll be running this command go build
and Dot slash
RSS act so that will build and run
and we got hello world back so we're
good to go like I said before we're
going to be building this project with
Git and storing our code in Source
control as we go so I'm gonna go ahead
and create a new
git repository and in vs code it
highlights all the code that has changed
but not yet been committed to Source
control here in green but I don't want
all of this in my source control the dot
vs code file is configurations for my
editor that's a personal thing that
doesn't need to be in the project itself
same with the RSS AG binary we don't
want to commit the binary that we are
building or the executable file that
we're building we just want to commit
our source code so I'm going to create a
new DOT get ignore file
and we're going to ignore the dot vs
code folder and the RSS AG binary
and next
um we're going to add all of the secrets
the like configuration Secrets uh for
our project in a DOT EnV file and read
them out of the file itself so uh for
example one of the configuration
variables that we're going to set is the
port that the server will run on so I'm
going to set that port to 8000.
and I'm going to also ignore that dot
EnV file in the git ignore
again because configuration data is
something kind of local to my machine in
production this port might be something
different so we don't need to commit
this file to Source control but I do
want it here in my repo now at this
point I do want to pause and say if you
have no idea what a port is or you have
no idea what HTTP requests are or rest
apis are
um we're going to move fairly quickly in
this project so if you're not familiar
with that stuff again I will link down
in the description below my HTTP course
that would be a good one to go brush up
on before working on this project
so now we need a way to read this port
variable into our program so that we can
use it and the go standard library has a
built-in function called
os.getn so it's a an exported function
called get end from the OS package and
we can get the value of a variable by
its key so in this case the key is port
and we'll get back a
Port string
and then for now let's just uh let's
just say if Port string equals the empty
string
then we'll say
uh log dot fatal so log dot fatal will
exit the program immediately with arrow
code 1 and a message and we'll say port
is not found in the environment
otherwise we'll say
port
and we'll print the port string
okay cool let's go ahead and run that
word is not found in the environment
okay so the problem here is that Port
the environment variable doesn't exist
in my current shell session if I wanted
to add it I could run in my in my
command line export Port equals 8000.
and then run this again
and then we get Port equals a thousand
the problem is I don't want to manually
set this environment variable every time
I work on my server I want to pull it
from this file so we're going to use a
package that allows us to grab
environment variables from a DOT ENB
file and it is this package here
github.com joho slash go.env
um that's also the URL of the library
you can paste that into your browser go
check it out but we're just going to
install it here locally
and that will add it here to our go.mod
and then I'm going to run go mod vendor
to copy that code here into
my my vendor folder we get kind of a
local copy of that
we'll run
um
here we're going to need to actually use
it so we do go.env.load
and by default load loads the dot EnV
file I think we can also optionally pass
in dot EnV
as the file path
and what's uh what's my error here could
not import no required module provides
go that's let's go mod tidy
that should clean up my imports okay
perfect
and
do I need to do anything else what are
we getting here could not import no
required module I should probably go mod
vendor again
that should pull in the code okay so you
can see we've kind of imported and
downloaded all of that code from the
package
and now I'm not getting air any errors
in my console okay so this will take the
environment variables from my DOT EnV
file and pull them into my current
environment so then I can use os.getendv
to load the variable so to test that
let's go ahead and change uh the port to
8080.
and rerun the server
still says 8 000 so something went wrong
maybe I'm misremembering how to use this
uh use this package
let's try just go dot end without load
still port 80.
what am I doing wrong
does it not overwrite you know what it
might not overwrite my current session
I'm going to kill my current sell
session shell session and create a new
one
and then we'll do this again so now I
won't have that exported 8 000 that I
had in my terminal
um run that again
Okay cool so now it's pulling it from
the file because I don't already have it
defined in my shell session now I want
to take just a second and point out
there are text instructions for this
entire project over on boot.dev and I'll
link that down in the description below
we're going to be using a lot of text uh
you know code Snippets from those text
instructions and they'll be easier to
kind of copy and paste and grab from
boot.dev directly than trying to you
know retype what you're seeing me type
here on the screen now we're going to
actually spin up our server and we're
going to be using the chi router to do
it it's a third-party router very
lightweight built on top of kind of the
same way that the standard library in go
does http routers and so let's go ahead
and install those now we'll do go get
github.com go Dash try chai or chi I
always struggle to pronounce that one
we'll install that and we'll install
this the cores package from the same uh
the same name space the G namespace next
we'll create a new router so I'll do
router colon equals Qi dot new router
in fact I should probably go mod vendor
have it there and I'll do another go mod
tidy and go mod vendor to bring it in
cool so this creates a new router object
next we'll connect up this router to an
http.server so that serve colon equals
a pointer to an HTTP dot server
and a server needs a Handler
which will be the router itself
and we also need a or an address which
is just a colon plus that Port string so
in this case it'll be colon you know
8080. cool and then we can call
http.listen and serve
or sorry not http.listen server we want
to call it on the server object so
serve.list.serve
cool and before we call that in fact I
think that returns an error so let's
capture that error
say if error is not equal nil
log dot fatal
s in the air is a message
okay listen and serve will block so when
we get to line 30
our our code basically just stops right
here and starts handling HTTP requests
if anything goes wrong in the process of
handling those requests then an error
will be returned and we'll you know log
it and exit the program but it kind of
the happy path for our code is that you
know nothing should ever be returned
from listen and serve because our server
is just going to run forever before we
run this let's just add one more kind of
logging statement we'll do log dot print
line actually let's do print f
and we'll say server starting on Port
percent V and we'll pass in that Port
string
okay cool
with that let's go ahead and build and
run again so go build
see what we get
Hello World server starting on Port
8080. I should probably remove I should
probably remove that hello world at this
point now that we have a running server
let's go ahead and test it so I'm over
here in the Thunder client tab again
because I'm using the thunderclient
plugin and I'm going to click new
request
and we're going to make a request to
http colon slash localhost right you
want to make a request to our own
machine on the port that we're running
on which I believe is 8080.
okay with that let's go ahead and start
up our server
okay server starting on port 8080 so it
should be good now you'll see I don't
have a new prompt because my my server
is still running
um if I send this get request perfect we
get a 404 that's exactly what we'd
expect because remember in our code we
haven't actually set up any handlers or
anything we just have a server running
so we're getting a 404 because we're
trying to hit a path in this case the
root path and it doesn't have anything
any logic there to handle that code if
we killed our server
and ran it again we just get the
connection refused I've configured my
thunderclient to actually store all of
my tests or my HTTP requests as plain
text here in the working directory but I
don't want those going into my source
control so I'm going to go ahead and add
that to the git ignore Thunder Dash
tests will ignore everything in there
next let's add a course configuration to
our router so this is so that people can
make requests to our server from a
browser and we're going to be using some
fairly permissive configurations here
and we'll use router dot use and then
we'll pass in
this cores.handler configuration this
comes from that course package that we
installed earlier
and let me see what am I doing here we
need one more parenthesis there
and then I'm going to go ahead and
vendor this as well so go mod tidy
go mod vendor
cool so we should have all of that code
here in our vendor folder as well I'm
not going to go too in depth on exactly
what cores are you can definitely go
look that up but just to give you a high
level overview this configuration is
essentially telling our server to send a
bunch of extra HTTP headers in our
responses that will tell browsers hey we
allow you to send uh you know requests
to http or https versions We allow you
to use these methods we allow you to
send any headers it's just a way to say
hey we're going to allow you to do
basically whatever you want there are
ways you can tighten up this
configuration for security purposes but
for now we're just going to be running
our project on our local machine so
we're going to just open it up make it
permissive to avoid any sort of uh kind
of weird testing issues if we try to
connect to our server through a browser
This Server we're building is going to
be a Json rest API which means all of
the request bodies coming in and
response bodies going back will have a
Json format so let's create a little
helper function that will make it easier
to send Json responses so I'm going to
create a new file called json.go it's
going to be in the main package
and the function signature is going to
look like this so we've got a function
we're calling it respond with Json it
takes as input a response writer this is
the same HTTP response writer that HTTP
handlers in go use it's exposed by the
standard Library
it will take a code so this is the
status code we're going to respond with
and it will take an interface which is
just something that we can Marshal to a
Json structure the first thing the
function will do is Marshal the payload
into a Json object or a Json string and
the way we do that is with the standard
Library so we need data and error equals
json.martial
and we pass in the payload
so this function will attempt to
Marshall whatever it's given into a Json
string and it will return it as bytes
and the reason it returns it is bytes is
so that we can write it in a binary
format directly to the HTTP response
which is pretty convenient if that fails
for whatever reason
then what we'll do
is we'll write a header to the response
and we'll use status code 500 we'll say
something went wrong on our end right
internal service error or internal
server error
and then we'll just return from the
function and actually if something goes
wrong we should probably log it as well
on the server side so that we can see
our own logs and see hey we tried to do
something in a broke uh so we'll do log
dot
print line
failed to Marshall
Json response
and let's print the response
or let's print what we tried to Marshall
that's probably more
more interesting we'll use printfs that
we can interpolate that value there next
we're going to need to add a header to
the response to say that we're
responding with Json data so we'll do w
dot right header
and or not right header I'm sorry w dot
headers
is it header
dot add
and we want to add the content type key
so content type
and the key will be applica or the value
of the application Json
so this adds a response header to the
HTTP request saying hey we're responding
with a content type of application slash
Json which is the standard and a value
for Json responses
um and then we should be able to write
the status code so we do w dot right
header 200 so everything went well and
then we need to write the data itself so
w dot write
and pass in the Json data this will
write the response body now that we have
a way to respond with some Json data
let's create an HTTP Handler that does
that so we'll do handlers
or Handler
readiness
again this will be in the main package
and we're going to create a new function
called Handler Readiness and this is a
very specific function signature this is
the function signature that you have to
use if you want to Define an HTTP
Handler in the way that the go standard
Library expects so it always takes a
response writer as the first parameter
and a pointer to an HTTP request as the
second parameter and then in the body of
this Handler we can just call our
respond with Json function
so we'll say respondus Json
we'll pass in that HTTP response writer
we want to respond with a 200 status
code
and some
some response payload in this case
all we care about is the 200 okay status
codes I'm actually just going to respond
with an empty struct which should
Marshal to kind of an empty Json object
and now that I'm writing this I realize
that we actually made a mistake or I
made a mistake in the Json response Json
code we should pass in we should use the
passed in Response Code instead of hard
coding the 200. so if everything goes
right we'll use the code given okay now
with that we need to hook up our Handler
Now using the chi router what we do is
we hook up a an HTTP Handler which is
this function to a specific HTTP method
and path okay so the way we're going to
do that is I'm going to create a new
router so V1 router and we'll use that
same Qi dot new router to do it and I'm
going to specify V1 router dot handle
handle Funk excuse me
I want to handle the slash ready path
and I want to handle it with this
Handler Readiness function
okay so we're we're connecting the
Handler Readiness function to the slash
ready path and the reason I created this
new V1 router is because I'm going to
mount that so I can do router.mount
to the slash V1 path
okay so I'm nesting a V1 router under
the slash V1 path and I'm hooking up the
Readiness Handler at the slash ready
path so the full path for this request
will be slash B1 slash ready and that's
just so that if we make breaking changes
in the future we can kind of have two
different handlers one under version one
and one under version two for our rest
API this is fairly standard practice and
actually I'm going to name this path
health
Health Z that's just a habit uh that I'm
bringing with me from kubernetes Land
that's pretty standard to have a slash
Health Z path
um that you can hit to see if your
server is live and running so that's the
purpose of this Handler it should just
respond if the server is alive and
running and everything's good okay so
let's go ahead and run the server and
make sure it's doing what we'd expect so
go build and Dot slash
RSS AG that starts up the server
and then we can open up thunderclient
and now instead of making a request to
the root which we'd expect to get a 404
from we'll do slash V1 slash Health Z
and make that get request and we get the
200.
now here's the weird thing if I change
this to a post request and I make that
I actually still get a 200 but that's
not really Our intention the health Z
endpoint should really only be
accessible by get request so I'm going
to make an update here rather than using
the v1rander.handlefunk I'm going to use
v1router.get and this will scope the
Handler to only fire on get requests
okay with that let's go ahead and
rebuild our server
and check again
post should fail method not allowed
perfect but the get request should still
work
so we have a nice helper function for
responding with arbitrary.json now I
want one for responding with arbitrary
error messages so let's do function
respond with error it will look very
similar but instead of taking a payload
which is an interface it will take a
message string and this function is
basically just going to format that
message into a consistent Json object
every single time
okay uh first thing we're going to do is
say if the code is greater than 499
we're going to log a message and that's
because uh error codes in the 400 range
are client-side errors so we don't
really need to know about them it just
means someone's using our API in a weird
way but we do need to know whenever
we're serving we're responding with a
500 level error code because that means
we have a bug on our end and we should
probably go fix it
so we'll do log dot print line
responding with 500 level error
and we'll just tack the message itself
on there
okay cool after we do that logging we'll
use the respond with Json function
but we'll be responding with a specific
structure of Json so let's go ahead and
Define that as a struct so type
error response
is a struct and has one field error this
is just a string
and we'll add this Json tag to just say
this the key that this should Marshal to
is error so in go we typically take a
struct and add these Json reflect tags
to it to specify how we want this
json.martial function or on the other
side the json.unmarshall function uh to
kind of convert this struct into a Json
object so in this case we're saying I
have an error field it's a string and I
want the key for the field to be error
so this struct will Marshal into a Json
object that looks kind of like uh like
this
error
you know something went
wrong
right
it wouldn't have uh actually wouldn't
have that but it would look like that
okay and we'll see that in just a second
okay so now we get to respond with Json
we pass in the response writer a cut the
same code that we were given and then
we'll just respond with an error
response
and the error message will be the
message that we were given
okay let's hook this up to another
Handler
so here we can do V1
router dot get
we'll create an error endpoint and oh I
need I need an actual Handler
so we'll create a new one called Handler
Handler error and we'll respond with an
error instead of passing in an empty
struct we'll say
something went wrong
and we'll respond with a 400 status code
client error right
okay now we can hook up this error
Handler
here
it will only work on get requests that
seems reasonable and basically it's just
going to call that respond with error
function so it'll be a good way to test
that
okay
let's go ahead and rebuild the server
oh what do we screw up routing pattern
must begin with Slash ah
let's go fix that
so you can see here we've got slash
Health Z slash V1 we need to start these
with a slash
it's just the way the chai route or the
QI router works
cool
um let's go open up the Thunder client
and send a request
to the slash error Handler
cool we get the 400 bad request status
code and this is that Json body so every
single time that we need to return an
error from our server now we can just
use this function and it will always use
this consistent error format which is
great because we can throw this in our
documentation and just tell all of the
users of our API hey this is what you
should expect when something goes wrong
now that we have a little bit of our
boilerplate set up I'm going to take the
opportunity to commit all of this to get
uh so that I don't lose it
um I will say that I generally recommend
committing the vendor folder so you can
think of the vendor folder kind of like
the node modules folder if you're
familiar with JavaScript land and in
JavaScript you would never commit it
it's way too big but in go we typically
don't have all that many dependencies so
it's actually perfectly fine to commit
the vendor folder in most scenarios and
I'd even recommend it so I'm going to go
ahead and add that and commit it
we'll say boilerplate or HTTP server
complete
for this project we're going to use
postgres as our SQL database it's a
production ready database in fact it's
the one I used to build boot.dev
you're going to need to install postgres
on your local machine make sure that the
postgres server is up and running and
that you have a client installed that
you can use to make kind of one-off SQL
queries against it I have detailed
instructions on how to do all of that in
the text instructions for this project
over on boot.f so again go check those
out if you need to figure out how to
install postgres locally and get a
postgres client up and running on your
machine I use PG admin so that's what
you'll see me using in this tutorial
so if you followed those instructions
then you should have a postgres server
running on your local machine and a
postgres client installed again I use PG
admin that's what you're seeing here on
the screen
okay so because postgres is running
locally I Have This localhost Server
here in PG admin that I've connected to
again that's the postgres server running
on my own machine and under databases I
have kind of the built-in postgres
database but I want to create a new
database that we're going to use for
this project so in this case I'm just
going to name it RSS AG
and we'll create that database
and then here within the RSS AG database
as long as the uh kind of icons are cold
then you're connected and everything is
working at least up to this point let's
run a quick query against the database
just to really make sure everything's
working so I'm right clicking here on
the RSS AG database and I'm going to
click query tool
and from this tool I should be able to
just write some raw SQL so I'm going to
go ahead and do a select
version this should just return the
current version of postgres that I'm
using
I'm on version 14.7 and as long as
you're on something
14.7 or newer you should be good to go
now it's important to keep in mind here
that PG admin is just a client for
interacting with an SQL database right
we're able to write raw SQL code here
and run it against our database server
if you think about it kind of in an
analogous sense PG admin is basically
just the same thing as the Thunder
client where the Thunder client is a
client for running one-off HTTP requests
against our server PG admin is a client
for running one-off SQL requests or SQL
queries against our database directly
next we're going to install two command
line tools that will allow us to work
with SQL databases from our go code much
easier now these aren't fully fledged
orms if you're familiar with that term
these are kind of lightweight libraries
that allow us to work with SQL databases
using the standard library and just sort
of streamline the process for us the
first one is called sqlc and again you
can find all of these commands in the
text instructions over on boot Dev so be
sure to be following along over there
but we're going to use the go install
command to go grab
sqlc and install it into our command
line once that's done you should be able
to just run sqlc version to make sure
it's working
next we'll install Goose the same way so
go install and then the installation
path for goose again that link is over
in the text instructions and then you
can make sure that goose is installed
working correctly by typing Goose Dash
version the great thing about sqlc and
goose is that they work based on Raw SQL
there's no kind of fancy query language
that's unique to those tools we can just
write SQL queries and we're going to
store all of that in our repository so
I'm going to create a new folder which
is called SQL and in there I'll create a
new directory called schema and this is
where we'll store all of our table
definitions or more specifically our
migrations so uh we'll start with a
users table and the way Goose works is
it runs the migrations in order so we're
going to start with a 0 0 1 migration
and we'll call it users.sql
from a very high level the way that
database migrations work is they have an
up and a down statement so for example
here we're creating a users table the up
statement will just create a new users
table and the down statement will delete
that same table so any down statement
should just undo the operation of the
upstatement and that just makes it easy
to roll back changes to our database
schema if we ever need to the goose
command line tool Works based off of SQL
comments so we'll start with a comment
dash dash plus goose
up
and dash dash plus goose
down
and then anything we type here will be
considered an up migration and anything
here will be a down migration so let's
start with the up migration it's going
to be create
create table users
and the first field will just be called
ID it'll be a uuid a universally unique
identifier I prefer uuids to integer
primary keys for a number of reasons
um I'll link a blog post down in the
description below
um and that's just going to be a primary
key
next we're going to need a created at
which is a time stamp
not null but we must have must have it
created at must have an updated at same
thing
and then a user will also have a name
and we'll just
make that a text field again
let's say that's not null
I need to remember to terminate my SQL
statements with a semicolon and for the
down by migration it's pretty simple
we'll just drop the table so drop table
users all right let's run our migration
but first we're going to need to be able
to connect to our local database from
our program and from our command line so
very first thing is we'll need a DB URL
and we'll set it equal to the URL that
we use to connect to our local postgres
server so this isn't to connect to PG
admin this
this same connection string that PG
admin uses to connect to the databaser
we want to go directly to the database
so it's going to look something like
this postgres
is the protocol so colon slash again
this is just a URL and then we have the
authentication part which in my case is
Wags Lane because that's the user on my
machine and then colon and then password
if you have a password for your local
database this is where it goes I
actually did not set one up because it's
just my local database
and it's going to be at localhost
colon
5432 which is the standard port for
postgres and the last part of the URL is
just going to be the database name that
you created so in my case I believe it
was RSS AG
o okay so your url should look very
similar to this with maybe you know the
username the database name something
like that could be could potentially be
swapped out on your machine
okay to run our migration here I'm going
to copy I'm going to copy this database
URL
and then I'm going to CD into this
directory so CD SQL schema
and then from here I can run goose
hostgress
so I'm telling I'm telling Goose that
hey I'm using a postgres database and
then I'll paste in my connection string
and type up so this will run the up
migration a nasty error here turns out I
forgot some commas we need to separate
all of these field names with commas
cool save that file let's try again
so we got
okay001 users.sql no more migrations so
that should have run let's check PG
admin to make sure that it works so now
over in PG admin under my RSS AG
database I should be able to come into
the schemas tab
the tables tag and I can see here that I
now have two tables Goose DB version so
this is an automatic table created and
managed by goose and then I've got the
users table that I just created let's go
ahead and do a select star from users
and we should just be able to see those
column names come back now let's make
sure that the down migration works as
well
go ahead and run the exact same thing
but this time down instead and you can
see that it down migrated the same file
now over in PG admin if I right click on
tables and click refresh you'll see the
user's table is gone and this query
should fail now
okay so let's re-up migrate to get that
database table created again and then
the interesting thing about migrations
is you can rerun the same up migration
and you won't get any errors because
Goose knows that you're already migrated
up to the most recent version of your
migrations now it's time to write a
query so we're using sqlc to handle our
queries and Goose to handle our
migrations so to get sqlc set up we need
to create a new file in the root of our
project called
sqlc.yaml I'm going to paste in this
configuration here basically it's just
telling sqlc what version we're using
what database engine we're using and
where we're going to store our queries
the raw SQL for our queries are going to
live in the SQL directory under a new
subdirectory called queries
we've specified that here right and here
I'm going to create a new file I'm just
going to call it users.sql
and again this is where the SQL will
live and the way sqlc works is that it
takes the SQL statements and it
generates go code Type safe go code that
matches the SQL every sqlc query starts
off with a comment that starts with its
name so name we'll do a create user
statement and it returns one record so
we're saying I want a new function
called create user oops and it's going
to return one user that statement will
be insert into users
ID created Created at updated at and
name
values
dollar sign one
dollar sign to dollar sign three dollar
sign four okay so what's this nonsense
right in sqlc each dollar sign number is
interpolated with the parameters for the
function so this statement will create a
new function called create user with
four parameters and the first parameter
will go in right here
the second one the third one the fourth
one Etc so it allows us to create
queries that take arguments as input and
then we'll end the query with just
return returning
returning star
okay
we want to create a new user and return
that record right we expect one record
back now let's use sqlc to actually
generate the go code for this query we
always run sqlc from the root of our
package rather than within the queries
directory itself and the reason that
works is because we have this sqlc.yaml
file at the top level okay so if
everything was written correctly we
should be able to do sqlc generate
and what happens is it goes and reads
that query and it also reads our table
definitions
which we've
specified here right SQL schema so it
knows the shape of our tables and it
knows the query we want to create and it
can go automatically generate all of
this go code in the internal slash
database package
now we need to actually use the database
in our go code so here in main.go I'm
going to create a new struct called API
config and it's going to hold a
connection to a database
now this database dot queries type is
actually exposed by that code that we
generated using sqlc so you can poke
around through this package and kind of
get familiar with the generated code we
never manually update this code that's
generated by sqlc it's completely
managed by sqlc we're just going to
write raw SQL to generate this code
okay next thing we need to do is import
our database connection
so here in dot EnV we have our DB URL
and we need to grab that and pull it
into our application we're also going to
need to disable SSL mode so SSL mode
equals disable and this just this just
tells our code hey we don't need to be
connecting to our local database using
encryption we kind of trust our local
database
so we'll parse that as a string so I'll
do DB URL
and if the database URL
is not found then we'll
we'll report a message
or we'll log an error message and exit
after that we need to actually connect
to the database so the go standard
library has a built-in SQL package we
can do sql.open
the driver name that we'll be using is
just postgres
and then we can pass in the connection
string and this will return a new
connection and an error
and again if there's an error
we'll just go ahead and log a message
and exit
can't connect to database
now this is kind of a weird quirky thing
about how go handles databases but we
actually need to import
a database driver into our program but
we don't actually need to call anything
from it so the sqlc docs mentioned this
but basically we just need to include
this line at the top of our program and
we do need to import it so I'll do a go
get on that lib PQ
and we'll import it using that
underscore just to say include this code
in my program even though I'm not
calling it directly
okay with that there now we should be
able to create a new API config
and let's just call it API CFG
and it takes as one of its Fields a DB
where am I at I think I scrolled too far
BB oh and I should probably go mod tidy
and go mod vendor
so that I stopped getting weird errors
in my in my vs code
okay uh this API CFG takes a
database.queries but if you look here we
don't have a database.queries we have an
sql.db so we actually need to convert it
into a connection to our package and we
can do that with database
dot new and we pass it as input the
connection and we'll get back
queries error
here we can say if it's not equal nil
and pass in the queries
to the struct
oh did I do that wrong maybe this
doesn't return an error
mismatch two variables but database.new
returns one okay cool so this actually
can't fail it's just a it's just a
simple conversion
we could actually even just do this it's
probably easier
great now we have an API config that we
can pass into our handlers so that they
have access to our database
let's write that create user Handler
okay so I'm just going to copy paste
this Handler Readiness and change it to
Handler
user
and we'll update this to say Handler
this will be the create user Handler
now here's the interesting thing about
HTTP handlers and go the function
signature can't change but we do want to
pass into this function an additional
piece of data we want to
add this API config so the way we do it
is by making this function a method so
we do API CFG is a pointer to an API
config so our function signature Remains
the Same
right it still just accepts these two
parameters but now we have some
additional data stored on the struct
itself that we can gain access to
and let's hook up this create user
Handler in Main
so we'll add it to the V1 Handler we'll
do V1 router Dot
post we want this to be a post request
to slash users
and we want to use the
create Handler create user method which
we defined on this struct so we can pass
in API CFG dot Handler create user and
now our Handler will have access to
um to the database
okay cool
this Handler needs to take as input a
Json body it should expect
some parameters so we'll do type
parameters
is a struct
and I think for now we just need a name
and we need to parse the request body
into this struct so we'll do Json dot
new decoder
and r dot body
okay and this response or this returns a
decoder
then we do decoder dot decode
and we want to decode into an instance
of the parameters struct so we'll do
params is an empty parameter struct and
we'll decode into
a pointer two parameters and this
returns an error if anything goes wrong
if there is an error then we should use
that Handler function that we made
earlier respond with error and say
something like well we need to pass in W
um if something goes wrong here it's
probably a client-side error right so
I'm just going to pass in a 400.
and we'll say
um
let's see error parsing Json
cool and then we'll return because we're
done at that point if there is an issue
okay otherwise we have access to a name
so we can use our database to create a
user so we do API
cfg.db dot create user now this is the
method that SQL C generated for us right
because it read our create user SQL and
it created
a create user function for us right and
it created the parameters as a struct so
that's pretty convenient
uh let's see how this works so create
user accepts a context and some create
user param so I'm going to use uh I
think it's
CTX no
r dot context there we go
so that's the context for this request
and then we pass in database dot create
user params this is struct and it should
have yep all of our uh types that we
need to pass into the create user
function okay
so first things first an ID
the ID is a uuid
um and this is the first point at which
I think we've needed to use them so
we're going to have to import this
package so github.com Google slash uuid
this is a very uh well-known uuid
package and go
we will go get it
with that install we should be able to
do
uuid.new
and that will just create a new random
uuid and if you aren't familiar this is
what a uuid looks like in string form
it's basically just this really long
random uh bit of I mean in this case
represented as text that we can use as a
primary identifier for every user so
every user will get their own random ID
cool
um I should probably go mod tidy go mod
vendor
we practice every time you install a new
package to make sure you vendor it and
go mod tidy kind of cleans up any unused
Imports um and resolves some issues
there
okay uh created that I'm going to set to
just time dot now dot UTC
it's created now and then updated that
should represent the last time it was
updated uh which would also be now right
because we're creating something new
and the user's name will just be
params.name right it's whatever was
passed in to this HTTP request in the
body
oh and I just am now realizing that I
messed up this Json Tech should look
like this
okay cool
um so create user should probably return
an error yep returns a new user and an
error
again if there was an error creating the
user we'll want to respond with an error
and we'll say
couldn't create user
400 seems fine
and then we'll actually respond with the
user object itself
okay database dot user and see how that
goes well let's actually take a look and
see what does a database.user even look
like
I'm curious
yeah so all these I mean all these
fields are exported so they should
Marshal to Json just fine let's go ahead
and run this and see and see what we get
before we run the code though it looks
like I've got a couple little things to
resolve here so error is already defined
there and then here oh I'm messing
something up we need to pass that in we
need to interpolate that
cool oh and here as well
percent V because those are errors okay
cool
um now let's go ahead and run build and
run the code so go build and
run RSS hack
wait server has started so let's go
ahead and open up the Thunder client
and now we'll be sending a post request
to the user's endpoint
and we'll be sending in a Json body
oh me
grow this just a little bit
and we need to specify a name
I'm going to create a new user called
Lane
and let's see what happens
couldn't create user
database wagslane does not exist
it looks to me like I probably messed up
my connection string let's go take a
look at that
so here in dot EnV
y yeah okay we forgot to or I forgot to
add the name of the database here at the
end so we we need to do slash name of
database all right let's try that again
let's rebuild the server
and resend that request
cool we got a 200 response it looks like
that is a new random ID great
of that updated at and the name
next just to make sure that the record
actually was created in the database
server itself I'm going to pop back over
here to PG admin refresh my tables
there's our users table and rerun this
select star from users
perfect looks like we've got one record
in here with all of the data that I
would expect now I want to make one more
optimization to our code here you can
see in this Json response that the fee
the key names in the Json object are the
same as the exported key names here in
the user struct in the database package
now we can't change this struct manually
again this is generated by sqlc so what
I think we should do is instead create a
new models folder models.go
in the main package
and here we'll create our own user type
so type user struct and it will be
nearly identical so let me go grab this
one
be nearly identical
the only difference at this point is
that I'm going to add Json tags
so that I can specify you know what
these names should be and we've been
using kind of this snake case convention
so I'm just going to stick with that so
updated
at a name
and I'm going to create a function uh
we'll say database user to user and it
will take a DB user
and return a user and all this does is
return a new user struct where we've
kind of populate it with all of the
all the stuff from the database user
so again the purpose of this is really
just
I want to own the shape that's being
returned over the wire right on our HTTP
responses and now I have the power to
configure that easily within within my
application
so we'll go ahead and just uh
paste these in here
okay and then in my user Handler rather
than responding with the database user
I'm going to respond with our user
cool
let's re-run and build that
and let's run our query again now
remember we already have a user in our
database so I'm going to
create a second one let's call this one
Rob
and this time you can see we have those
snake case keys
and again I'm going to go check in PG
admin to make sure that Rob is there
perfect now we've got Lane and Rob and
you can see they have different randomly
generated IDs and their timestamps are
slightly different
we're going to be using API keys to
authenticate our users on This Server
the nice thing about an API key is Not
only is a little more secure than a
username and a password but because it's
so long it also serves as a unique ID
for that user so we don't even need a
combo of username password we can just
use the API key in order to kind of
uniquely identify people so we need to
run a migration that adds a new field to
the users table
so that we can store their API Keys now
we've already created this migration
that creates the users table and we
don't want to modify this because it's
generally a really bad idea to go
modifying your existing migrations
instead we create a new one so I'm going
to create a new one and we'll call it
zero zero two because we want it to run
after the first migration and again
Goose uses these numbers to know in
which order it should run the migrations
and we'll call it users API key
and the migration statements are going
to look a little bit different okay so
the up statement is going to be an alter
table so alter table users We'll add a
column
and we'll call the column just API
underscore key
it's going to be a varchar so varchar
64. now the difference between varchar
and text at least for our purposes here
is that the varchar is exactly 64
characters long so we're saying we want
our API keys to be 64 characters long
and we want those API keys to be unique
no two users should have the same API
key we also don't want them to be null
and we're going to set a default
a default API key and this is important
because if we didn't set a default we'd
run into an issue when we run this
migration remember we already have two
users in our database currently so if we
just try to add a column that has these
unique not null constraints on it then
what's the SQL database going to do how
is it going to generate new API keys
that are unique and not null typically
it would just default the new
um you know you know the field in the
existing records to null but because
we've said they can't be null and they
must be unique we need to provide a
unique default for every new record or
for excuse me for every existing record
in the database
so the default value that we need to add
again needs to be unique for every
person so we're actually going to have
to use some random number Generations so
we can generate a unique API key for
every user and this is the snippet of
code that does that again you can go
grab this in the text instructions for
this project over on boot Dev but let me
explain basically what it's doing we're
generating some random bytes and then
we're casting it into a byte array
and we're using the Sha 256 hash
function to get kind of a a fixed size
output so we're saying take a a big
random slice of bytes
hash them with straw 256 so that we get
a fixed size output and then encode it
in hexadecimal
and that's so that we get 64 unique
hexadecimal characters this one makes
more sense when we actually run the
query and you see what the output looks
like
and then as far as the down migration
goes we just need to alter able users
and drop
column API key again
down migrations should just undo
whatever was done in the up migration
let's go ahead and run this migration so
I'm going to need to change directory
into SQL
schema
then we'll run goose postgres
and then let me go grab the connection
string now we do need to peel off this
SSL mode disable Goose doesn't need that
um just our code needs that so I'm going
to grab the rest of the string
and we'll run an migration
cool so it looks like it ran
successfully
let's go see if those default values
look good
run the select star statement and there
you can see the new API keys
so big old hexadecimal strings that
uniquely identify every user and should
be kept secret by the user because just
the API key is enough to authenticate
the user
now that we've got our migration and
we've updated our schema we actually
need to go update our query right we
need to be creating new API keys for new
users so let's go update our create user
function it should now accept an API key
as the last parameter
and pass it in here
actually you know what
if we do it this way we're basically
telling our application code hey you
need to go generate an API key in the
same way that we generated it here in
our SQL I think it would actually be
easier what if we just take this
and plop that
in here
right so now we'll use we'll use SQL to
generate the new API Keys we don't even
need to update the function signature of
our create user function cool so the SQL
will just handle the creation of new API
Keys every time a new user is created
all right now we should be able to run
sqlc generate
insert has more Expressions than Target
columns let's
let's oh right sorry we do still need to
pass in the API key as the column name
the difference is because we are not
using dollar sign five our function
signature won't change this got a little
confusing I was reading it like a
function signature even though it is it
is SQL okay run that again
it went off without a hitch you can see
it updated a few files in our database
package now we should be able to go use
that in our code
but before we test our server let's add
one more thing let's give us a way to
get a user so we'll create a new
function
and this one we'll call
get user
by API key
it's return a single row
and it's going to be a select statement
so select star
from
users
where
API key equals dollar sign one
and we'll run sqlc generate again to
generate the code for that query you can
see it created it here
so in our Handler user function we
actually don't need to make any changes
to our create user Handler right we
didn't change the number of parameters
that we need to pass in for the API key
it's handled kind of under the hood by
the SQL query
but we do need a new Handler for getting
users so let's go ahead and add that
so I'm going to copy paste that do
Handler
get user by API key
maybe we can just let's just simplify
this let's just call it Handler get user
now this Handler is going to look very
different
this is an authenticated endpoint so in
order to create a user on our API
basically to register a new account you
don't need to have an API key but if you
want to get your own user information
you have to give us an API key first
this isn't going to be the only
authenticated endpoint or the endpoint
that you can only do if you're logged in
so I think it makes sense to kind of
abstract the logic for getting a user by
their API key into a package so under
the internal package here where we have
our database code I'm going to create a
new package and we'll just call it auth
and in there I'll create a new file
we'll call it auth.go this whole package
will just be called
auth
now the only function that we care to
export in this auth package is going to
be this one called get API key
and its purpose get API key it will say
it extracts
an API key
from
the headers of an HTTP request so it's
going to go into the headers look for a
specific header and see if it can find
the API key if it can it'll return it
otherwise it will return an error
now as the authors of This Server we get
to decide what we want the
authentication header to look like so
I'm just going to say
example
let's expect an authorization header so
the key of the header will be
authorization
and the value will be API key
and then sum you know like insert API
key here
okay so we're looking for a header of
this format
so first let's look and see if we can
find a value associated with the
authorization key
um we're just using the HTTP standard
Library here so we can do headers dot
get
authorization
and this should return let's see a
string okay so the value associated with
this
with this header key now if value is the
empty string then we can just say
turn empty string and an error say
errors.new
no authentication info
about
so otherwise we have a valid value so we
could do something like this uh
vowels
strings dot split
bowel
okay so
strings.split takes a string as input
and a delimiter so we're going to say we
want to split this string here right the
the value given to us by the
authorization header we want to split it
on Spaces okay
so next we can say if the length of
vowels
does not equal to
then again we can return an error saying
like you know maybe malformed
malformed ah header
right because we're expecting that the
value of this key is two like two
specific values separated by a space the
first should be API key and the second
should be the API key right the first
would just be the string API key and the
second should be the actual API key
okay so if the length is wrong then uh
next we should probably check and make
sure they typed this in correctly so we
can say if vowels it's zero does not
equal API key
malformed auth header
we could say malformed first part of
auth header
okay otherwise
we can just return
thousand one and no error right
because by that point we're sure that
all the all this part was correct and
we're extracting just the API key
okay what did I screw up here errors.new
oh right you're not supposed to
capitalize errors in go that is a a
linting error
stylistic error okay cool
so now we've got the get API key
function we can go ahead and use this in
our get user Handler
so let's go ahead and grab that API key
so API key and error
auth dot get API key and we pass in the
HTTP headers so r dot header perfect if
there is an error let's handle it
we can just respond with an error saying
auth error
and 400 we should probably do like a 403
and in fact now that I'm thinking about
HTTP codes creating a user
probably should be a 201 instead of a
200. like you probably won't run into
any issues for using a 200 but 201 is
the created code so it's like a little
more correct uh if you're looking at it
from kind of a restful HTTP standpoint
and then 403
um is one of these kind of permissions
errors so that should be good
okay now that we have an API key we can
use our
database query that we created dot
getuser by API key
again we'll pass in the requests context
and
the API key I haven't really touched on
this yet
in go
um there is a context package in the
standard library and basically it gives
you a way to track
something that's happening across
multiple go routines and the most
important thing that you can do with a
context is you can cancel it so by
canceling the context it would
effectively kill the HTTP request I
don't want to go too much into detail on
how all of that works here you could
definitely go read up on it but for now
just make sure that it's important to
kind of use the current context so every
http.request has a context on it and you
should use that context in any calls you
make within the Handler that requires a
context just in case uh kind of
cancellations happen
okay cool uh that returns a user and an
error
again if there is an error
Let's do let's use a better uh
string here maybe
couldn't get user
and this one let's just go with a 404 or
a 400 for now
cool and then we can respond with Json
this time it will just be a 200 code and
again we should cast that database user
to the user model that we defined here
right with the the nicely formatted Json
tags
and that should be good okay let's hook
up our get user Handler
to our router
so here we'll do V1 router dot get so
same path slash users
but we'll be hooking up
the get user Handler to the get HTTP
method so again same path different
method all right let's test our new
endpoint
um first I'm going to go ahead and rerun
sqlc generate because I can't remember
if I've done that and then we'll build
and run the server
okay with that running let's head over
to thunderclient
and first let's create another new user
so Json body
let me minimize this a little bit
let's keep create a new user we'll call
them Rand
and it'll be a post request that looks
good
okay response came back
Rand was created and this is rand's ID
ah we screwed something up we're not
responding with the API key
let's go update that
so here in our model I believe it's
because we're not casting
so we need API
e
string
Json
API key
and then here
I need to do that conversion so it's
just getting dropped because we weren't
we weren't setting the API key anywhere
okay uh let's rebuild
and we'll create a new user let's call
this one Joe
okay cool
so Joe was created and it actually
returned the API key perfect now let's
go ahead and I'm going to create a new
request
this one
also to localhost
slash V1 users but this one will be a
get
and we're going to add some headers or
specifically one header right we're
going to add our authorization header
and its value will be API key
and then the actual API key just paste
it in there
okay let's go ahead and run that
and it's returning Joe
it's good to test failure cases too so
let's just see what happens if we
update this header and let's just like
let's just make something
broken let's just remove a section of
the API key and see what happens
cool we get a 400 bat request couldn't
get user SQL no rows in the result set
so essentially user is not found perfect
so we've got our users set up and our
authentication system now it's time to
actually get to some business logic
right this is an RSS feed aggregator so
we need a way to store feeds let's
create a new schema or rather a new
migration in our schema folder this will
be 003 and we'll call it feed
s.sql
now this is going to be a create table
migration right we want to create a
beads table so we'll do create table
feeds
now a feed and the drop will also drop
the feed stable a feed has an ID just
like a user it also has a created at and
an updated ad and it also has a name
like all of that is actually very
similar
um what's unique about a feed is it has
a URL
which is text as well that is unique
and not null
and it also has a user ID
which references sorry it's a user ID is
a uuid which references
users ID
and we'll also add the on delete Cascade
[Music]
essentially what this does is it says we
have a user ID stored in our feeds table
that references the ID of a user in the
users table right so this is this is
relational data this is a relational
database
essentially what this means is if we try
to create a feed
for a user ID that does not exist in the
users table we'll get an error which is
what we want because we don't want feeds
to be able to exist without a user who
created them and then this on delete
Cascade bit just says when a user is
deleted I want all of the feeds
associated with that user to be deleted
automatically it will Cascade and delete
all of them and let's run this migration
so I'm going to hop into the SQL schema
directory
and from here we can run goose postgres
postgres and grab my connection screen
again we don't need the SSL mode stuff
for goose
grab the rest of it
and up
cool now over here in PG admin I can do
a select star from feeds and make sure
that that table exists with those fields
next we'll need a query to create a new
feed so I'm going to go ahead and copy
this queries file update it to feeds and
then we'll delete this one because we
don't need it and we'll create a
create feed
and insert into feeds ID created I
updated that name there will not be an
API key but let's see we need a
name URL and user ID okay name URL
user ID
we won't be generating an API key here
instead all of these values I think will
just be passed in from our application
code so one two three four five six we
need six parameters for this function
five and six and then we'll just return
the entire feed row after it's done
being created and then I'll just
navigate back to the root of the project
and run SQL sqlc generate
to create the code for that new query
next we're going to create a new Handler
that will allow users of our API to
create a new feed
here's the thing that Handler is also
going to need all of this same logic
that we have in the get user Handler
right we'll need to grab an
authentication a token or an API key
from the authorization header fetch the
user and then use that user in the
Handler and rather than copying and
pasting uh this what 10 lines of code
into every Handler that's authenticated
instead we're going to build some
middleware to kind of dry up the code
right
um
let's go ahead and do that so I'll
create a new file I'm going to call it
middleware
off
dot go
art of the main package
and here we're going to define a new
type and it's our own custom type I'm
calling it auth Handler and you'll
notice it looks almost exactly like a
regular HTTP Handler the only difference
is that it includes a third parameter it
has a user associated with it so if you
think about this it makes a lot of sense
for any authenticated Handler to accept
three parameters where the third one is
the authenticated user now the problem
with this auth Handler type that we
created is that it doesn't match the
function signature of an HTTP dot
Handler func right those functions with
just the response writer and the request
as the only two parameters so what we're
going to do is create a new function
called middleware auth that works it's a
method on our API config so it has
access to the database
um but it its job is to take an auth
Handler as input and return turn a
Handler Funk so that we can you know use
it with the QI router
okay
let's Implement that the way this
function will actually work is we're
going to return a closure so we're
returning here a new Anonymous function
with that same function signature as
your normal HTTP Handler func the
difference is that as we Define this
function we'll have access to everything
within the API config so we'll be able
to query the database so we can
basically just go rip out the code from
our get user Handler
and paste it in here
right we're going to go get the API key
from the request well from the request
headers at least and then we can go
ahead and grab the user using that API
key
all right so we'll have access to the
user here in the function
finally all we need to do is run the
Handler that we were given
with the response writer the request and
the user right so by the time we get to
actually calling the auth Handler we're
able to give it
an actual user from the database and
this is really great let me show you why
so now that the middle middleware auth
function exists we can remove all of
this code from the get user Handler
we can update the get user Handler to
accept as input
a database user
user database.user
look at how clean this function becomes
right now it's just now it's literally
just one line cool and now to hook it up
you'll notice we have an error over here
we just need to call our middleware auth
function
API CFG dot middleware off
we call this function to convert the get
user Handler into a standard
http.handlerfunk I kind of move fast
through that hopefully it all makes
sense though basically we're just
calling the middleware auth function
first
to get the authenticated user and then
we're calling that callback the the get
user Handler the nice thing is now we'll
be able to reuse that middleware across
many different HTTP Handler functions so
now let's create the create feed Handler
I'm going to go ahead and just copy this
Handler user change it to Handler feed
and for now we just need a create
function so I'll delete this get
and we'll call it Handler
create feed
and remember it's an authenticated
endpoint so we can have it accept the
user directly so user database dot user
we know who's creating the feed by the
time we get to this function which is
awesome
all right in order to create create a
feed
use our new create feed function which
takes
create feed params
and create feed params have ID created
updated at name that's all the same the
difference is a URL and a user ID
so URL
and a user ID
which is a uuid
which actually exists already on the
user object so we can just do user.id
okay
what do we want as input we need a URL
so we also are going to want a params.u
well
so we want the user that's creating a
new feed to be able to just send us a
name and a URL and we'll go about
creating the entire uh kind of you know
feed object in the database or feed Row
in the database
so this is what our parameters should
look like uh what error am I running
into here cannot use API cfg.create feed
no new variables on left side of that's
odd create feed should return a feed
let's take a look at that definition
yeah it does return a feed what am I
messing up here
oh first of all that shouldn't be a user
that should be a feat okay that's the
problem I was over I was trying to
overwrite the database.user type with a
feed type that won't work
okay so we're creating a feed we're
generating a new uid that's great we're
using the current time perfect
um this is getting messed up uh variable
of type uuid.uid as uuid.no uuid ah okay
I see the problem
the create feed params
except a uuid.null uuid that's a problem
we don't ever want a you the null uuid
type from the uuid package is a nullable
uuid
but we don't want it to be nullable
because we expect that every feed will
be created by a user so let's go update
our
our uh I think it's our is it our
migration let's go look schema feeds
yeah user ID uuid
not null
cool it doesn't need to be unique a user
can have multiple feeds but it should
never be null
all right
um with that we're actually going to
need to go
uh rerun our migration so SQL
um
schema
and we'll do a down to drop the table
down
and then back up to create the new table
with the proper schema
and then we should re-run
SQL C generate
okay
did that work
create feed create feed params looks
like that error is gone it's now just a
uuid type perfect now at this point we
have a valid database feed I should
probably update this error so that it
actually says feed and we want to return
it
in our HTTP response trouble is remember
we don't want to just directly return
the struct let's go create a new model
for a feed
so we'll do type
feed
then I'm going to go just copy
the types from here and we'll use those
and we'll make our own Json tags or the
type
user ID
URL
name
updated at
and created that okay
and then we'll want a
what is it database database feed to
feed
and we'll return a feed
all of this should be
pretty straightforward
again this just gives us more control
right now we in our code that's not
generated by SQL C
are able to Define
you know what the shape of the response
will look like if for whatever reason we
needed to store some data in the
database but never wanted to respond
with it in our Json API we could make
those changes here in this struct okay
so now we've got database feed to feed
we'll call that
and now we should be good to go
all right let's test out our new Handler
so I'm gonna rebuild our server and run
it
and over in the Thunder client let's see
so we just created a new user Joe so we
have our authentication key here or our
API key
I'm going to do a new request to HTTP
slash localhost
8080 slash V1 slash feeds ah now that I
type this out I realize that we never
hooked it up
let's go hook up that feed
so
speed Handler Handler create feed we
need to go paste this in to
the main function
so this one will go under slash feeds
because we're creating a resource we're
going to use a post request
Handler create feed
okay that should be hooked up now let's
restart our server
and over here again I need to grab that
API key all right
what do we want here post request
localhost 8080 V1 feeds
we do need to authenticate again so
query headers
authen
authorization
API key
paste in that API key
okay uh what do we send in as the body
let's take a look at our Handler again
a name and a URL okay
so name now remember this is this is
this is not a person this is a feed
right and a feed is a URL that kind of
links to an RSS feed out on the internet
so this one I'm going to put just lanes
lanes blog
and then
the URL is going to be
https colon slash wagslane.dev
slash index dot XML so in case you're
not familiar with what an RSS feed is
let me just show you really quick
um I'm here on my blog wagslane.dev and
if you click RSS up at the top it'll
take you to my RSS feed now every RSS
feed will have a different URL it's kind
of up to the author of the blog or the
podcast what that feed URL is but you
can usually find it by poking around on
their website so in my case it's just
wagslane.dev slash index.xml and it will
look something like this if you open it
up in a browser it's basically this
structured XML document that describes
what each post on the blog says at least
from a high level it'll usually have
something like a link to the post maybe
a short description
um basic stuff like that again podcasts
also work on the same RSS structure so
for testing you can use my blog or if
you know of any other RSS feeds out on
the web you can use them
so now that I've pasted in that URL uh
let's go ahead and create that feed
and what do we get back
cool the feed's got a new URL created at
updated at the name and the URL seem to
have persisted correctly and that is the
user ID associated with the API key that
we use to create the feed next we're
going to add the ability for any user to
get all of the feeds in the database
this is not an authenticated endpoint
okay
we need new query I'm going to go ahead
and use the same file this query will
just be called get feeds
and it will return many rows instead of
just one
all right and this one will be uh select
star from feeds
super super simple query here we're just
gonna go grab all the feeds and return
them
okay from there we should be able to
sqlc generate
and let's go hook up that Handler
I'm going to use the same Handler feed
file
uh but this one will be a little bit
different
you're going to
call this one Handler get feeds
it's not authenticated so we don't need
to pass in a user and it doesn't even
take any parameters right it's just
going to go get all of the feeds so API
cfg.db dot get feeds
and it the get feeds function if you
remember we just wrote it in SQL it
doesn't take any parameters and it just
returns all the feeds that are currently
in the database
so this error should be say something
like couldn't
get feeds
cool now we need to return all of the
feeds this is not a single feed this is
now a slice of database dot feeds so not
only do we need to return them but we
need to actually convert them so let's
go update our models a little bit let's
create a new function
this one will be database feeds to feeds
and the difference is it will accept a
slice of database fees and it will
return a slice feeds
let's do this slice feed we'll create a
new empty slice of feeds and then four
DB feed
range DB feeds
feeds equals append
feeds
database feeds
or database feed
and return
Beats sorry not we don't want to append
it directly we have to we have to call
our conversion function
okay
so this function will just iterate over
all of the database feeds one by one
converting them into our new feed
structure and then returning them
cool now here we can use that function
to do that mapping
great let's hook up this Handler
so in main.go we'll create a new
entry here
this is going to be a get request
and it's not authenticated
it'll be Handler
get feeds
cool let's regenerate I can't remember
if I generated my SQL C so I'll do that
couldn't hurt
and then we'll build and run the server
okay with that running let's go ahead
and create a couple more RSS feeds
so here
update the body
of my request sorry I'm so zoomed in so
that you guys can see and it just makes
it hard
um no this was to create users this is
users here's feeds
okay let's let's just add the same URL
with a couple well no we can't we can't
add the same URL let's just use some
garbage URLs just to test
all right
okay that created properly
now let's test our new endpoint
this one is going to be a get request to
feeds and we don't need to add any
authentication information okay
run that
awesome this looks good to me we've got
an array at the top level and then two
feed objects one for garbage blog and
one's for one for lanes block so it
looks like everything's working so we've
given users a way to create feeds and a
way to query all of the feeds now we're
going to give users a way to follow
specific feeds so that they can see kind
of an aggregated view of all of the
feeds that they care about on the system
okay so uh let's go ahead and add a new
migration
we need a new table
so this will be the fourth migration and
we'll call this new table feed follows
and this table is just going to store
the relationship between a user and all
of the feeds they're following so it'll
be a many-to-many kind of table of user
IDs to feed IDs
all right the table is going to be
called feed follows
so create table feed follows every feed
follow like every other record in our
database will have an ID created at and
an updated at
but its unique Fields will be a little
bit different
first it's going to need a user ID
which is
oh my gosh why can't I type fingers
throw the wrong place in the keyboard
so a user ID is a uuid
um that can be it doesn't see it doesn't
need to be unique
um but it does need to be not null
then we need a feed ID
also a uuid not null
and then we're going to create a unique
constraint on the combination of user ID
to feed ID so unique
user ID
so again this constraint is going to
make it so that we can never have two
instances of a follow for the same user
feed relationship right you as user can
only follow a certain feed once you
can't follow it twice that doesn't
really make sense right so we're gonna
ensure that that's unique also I missed
a couple things here the user ID should
reference so references
uh the users table
ID field and on delete will Cascade
so if a user is deleted we're going to
go delete all of the data about what
feeds they're following
and then this one's going to be very
similar
except it references the feeds table
with its ID and again if a feed gets
deleted then we'll go delete all of the
following data related to that feed
cool okay let's go ahead and run this
migration
so I'm gonna go back up into the SQL or
say back down into the SQL schema
directory
and from here
I'll need my connection string do goose
postgres
connection string ah I didn't grab the
whole thing let's try that again
all of that
goose postgres
up
cool speed follows databases or feed
follows table is there so now we need a
way for users to follow feeds alright
let's go ahead and go create that so I'm
going to copy and paste the feed Handler
file and we'll call it Handler
feed follows
and update this so Handler create feed
follow so remember in order for a user
to follow a feed all we need to do is
create a new feed follow record with
that user feed relationship
okay this is an authenticated endpoint
right we so we we need a user and we
need them to be authenticated have
passed an API key right
and let's see what do we need them to
give us as input I think all we need is
a feed ID
right they just need to tell us which
feed they want to
follow
so a feed ID is a uuid
all right and now we should be able to
create the oh we never we never made we
never made the SQL query what am I doing
what am I doing I'm getting way ahead of
myself let's go add that query quickly
so feed
follows
and to start we'll need a create feed
follow
okay what's in a feed follow right we've
got all these
all of these fields and I think yeah
we're just gonna have them all passed in
directly that seems like the easiest way
so
insert into feed follows
ID created that updated at
user ID
ID
that's five parameters right one two
three four five
cool that looks good
now I should be able to go back and run
sqlc generate
cool now I should have
a
create feed follow function
with create feed follow params
all right
it accepts a user ID and a feed ID so
the user ID is just the author
authenticated user the feed ID is going
to be passed in his params right
cool couldn't create feed follow
don't need a get Handler quite yet and
then we're gonna just need to make make
that uh mapping function as well for
feed follows
so in our models file I'll create a new
feed follow struct and it's going to
have a user ID and a feed ID
and a new function database feed
follow to feed follow
all right DB feed follow dot ID
by the way I'm not using GitHub copilot
in this video just so that you could
just just so you can see more of my
thought process but I typically do use
GitHub copilot and it makes this kind of
function just like way faster to write
it would guess this kind of function
almost perfectly
um so just so you know I I do recommend
those kinds of tools to speed up the
development process
um I'm just not using it uh right now so
you can see how I think through you know
architecting this this application
without all the AI prompts getting in
the way
okay now we should be able to database
feed follow to feed follow and we're
gonna be clear that this is a feed
follow not a feed
and that goes there
perfect
all right let's hook this up so we're
going to need to go into main.go
V V1 router dot post because we're
creating a resource
slash feed follows
and this is an authenticated
authenticated Handler
Handler create feed follow okay let's
test this new endpoint so we'll build
and run the server
and we'll need a new request
this one will be kind of similar it'll
be
oops a post request to the feed follows
endpoint
and we're going to need to authenticate
so let's go grab some authentication
information
let's see get users let's go ahead and
send this couldn't get user SQL no
result okay I need to figure out what
users I have available to me
oh that's right we we changed this API
key we wanted it to break let's go
create a new user
we'll make a new one called
uh Billy
and there's Billy's API key
cool we've got some feeds
but our feed follows
need an auth section
sorry in the headers
we're doing it manually
authorization
API key
there's Billy's key and then in the body
we need to pass in the ID of the feed
that we want to follow
so let's do a get on all of the feeds
and we can follow either of these let's
follow Lane's block
there's our feed ID
paste that in there and create
amazing new ID for the feed follow
there's the user ID the feed ID what
happens if we try to recreate it cool
couldn't create feed follow duplicate
key value violates unique constraint
that's what we'd expect right we
shouldn't be able to follow the same
feed multiple times we're already
following it we already have a record uh
indicating that we are following it
everything appears to be working just
fine next let's give users a way to see
all of the different feeds that they are
currently following
so we'll do get
feed follows
it will return many
and the query will be select star from
eat follows where user ID equals dollar
sign one
right so get all the feed follows for a
given ID
so let's get that hooked up I need to
run SQL C generate to create that query
and then down here we'll create a new
Handler
this Handler will also be
authenticated but it's going to be get
feed follows
have the user we don't need any
parameters here
and we're just going to call get
follows
and we'll just need to pass in the
user's ID
couldn't get feed follow this
cool now we've got a list of feed
follows or a slice of feed follows so
we're going to need to convert an entire
slice so again down here we'll write
this type of a function
it's going to be database feed
follows
to feed follows
all right
lots of copying and pasting here feed
follows
okay so now we have a way to convert an
entire slice of database feed follows to
our own struct
that looks good to me
there feed follows
okay cool now we have a Handler for
getting feed follows let's go ahead and
update this
so we need a new V1 router dot get
slash feed underscore follows
middleware off
if feed follow us
Perfect all right let's give that a shot
so we'll build and run again
and now
let's see so this is
um
this is the request that we use to
create
so let's grab
so hard working on such a small screen
let's grab our API key and create a new
request
80 V1 feed follows
it's going to be a get request it does
need to be authenticated
okay
see if that works
cool we got the one feedback that we are
currently following finally we need a
way to unfollow feeds or to delete feed
follows so let's create a new one new
query
we'll do delete
feed follow
now this one is going to be our first
query that doesn't actually return
anything
um it's just going to be an execute
right we're not returning one record
we're not returning many records we're
returning no records we're just going to
run a a SQL query so uh it's going to be
delete
ROM
feed follows
where ID equals dollar sign one and user
ID equals dollar sign two now it's
important it's important to point out
that we don't actually need the user ID
here for this query to work right the ID
is already a unique identifier the
reason I'm tacking on this user ID is
because this will prevent someone who
doesn't own a feed follow
from trying to unfollow a feed on behalf
of somebody else
that makes sense uh if for whatever
reason another user got accessed let's
say if if for some reason user B got
access to the feed follow ID of user a
if we didn't have this check here then
that user who hijacked a feed follow ID
would be able to like unfollow like
force the other user to do an unfollow
if that makes sense this ensures that
only the user who actually owns the
follow record can execute the unfollow
command
hopefully that makes sense
okay uh from here let's just go ahead
and generate that
and go hook it up to a new endpoint
so we'll do
Handler
delete feed follow
now this one's going to be a little
different
in that it is authenticated but we need
to get a feed follow ID and delete
requests so like HTTP delete request the
delete HTTP method they don't typically
have a body in the payload it's it's
possible but I would argue it's not
super conventional it's a little more
conventional to pass the ID in the HTTP
path so it's going to look something
like this
you and router dot delete feed follows
slash
feed follow
ID
and then this will be Handler
uh Delete feed follow right so we want
the feed follow ID dynamically passed in
the path of the request
so the question is how do we grab this
feed follow ID in our Handler itself
well the chai router has or Chi oh I'm
never going to say that the proper way
the chi router has a I think it's Pat is
it URL let's see URL
parameter that's the one uh you are pro
URL parameter function where we can pass
in the request and a key and in this
case it's going to have to match so feed
follow ID matches whatever we type in
here between the open and close brackets
okay and that's going to return a string
so this is the feed follow ID string
great we're going to take that and we're
going to parse it into a uuid so we'll
do uuid.parse
and that will return a feed follow ID
and potentially an error
if the error it's not equal nil
say couldn't parse feed
Hollow ID
and that will be a 400 level error
perfect
okay
from here we should be able to do API
cfg.database dot delete feed follow and
we need to pass in the request context
and
feed follow params so database dot
delete feed follow parameters it takes
an ID and a user ID so the ID of the
feed follow
we just parsed
and then the user ID
comes in with that user object because
this is an authenticated request
cool and that should return just an
error
right oh and it's just it's just given
me yellow squigglies because I need to
handle the error
I couldn't
delete feed
follow
perfect uh what do we respond with here
I guess we have a couple different
options
um the simplest thing would just be to
respond with like an empty Json object I
guess uh what matters to the client is
probably the 200 Response Code
um so we could like for the sake of
Simplicity just so we can use our
respond with Json function we'll just
return an empty Json object
alternatively maybe we could return an
object that says like message you know
unfollow successful or something um
but it doesn't matter too much I think
as long as it's a 200 level code we're
pretty much good to go
okay and that's already been hooked up
so let's go ahead and test it
I can't remember if I generated let me
do that again and then we'll restart the
server
and take a look
okay so this was our endpoint it's
returning the feeds that we are
currently following
let's go ahead and delete
this feed follow so we need new request
this is going to be a delete request
we're going to unfollow a specific ID
we're going to unfollow this
we're going to delete this feed follow
you'd follow with that with that ID
and the headers we do need to be
authenticated as the same person
so authorization
same API key
okay let's run that delete
we got a 200 response now let's go do a
get and make sure that it's gone yep
empty list or empty array we're good to
go okay we've built out the majority of
the crud section of our API but we
haven't built the most interesting part
which is the part of the server that
actually goes out and fetches posts from
the different RSS feeds that exist in
our database again the whole purpose of
this server that we're building is so
that it can keep track of all of these
different feeds in the database and then
go out periodically and actually
download all of the posts that are on
each individual feed so for example we
have a feed for my personal blog post
this server will actually go out to my
blog every I don't know 10 minutes and
check to see if there's a new blog post
to download and store in the database so
the first thing we need to do is update
the feeds table
to have one more column we need a new
column called last fetched at and it's
just so we can keep track of when we
last fetched the posts for a given fee
so let's go ahead and add that we'll
need new migration
um and it will look kind of like this
migration uh it's going to be our fifth
migration so far it's going to be on the
feeds table and we're going to be adding
the last fetched at
last fetched at
field okay so alter table feeds add
column last fetched at
and this one is going to be
timestamp
and it will be nullable so we don't need
a not null constraint
um
in fact that's it
um it's okay like we don't need to
specify any defaults that should be it
um and then as far as the down migration
goes we'll just be deleting or dropping
the column from the feeds table okay
cool let's run that migration
so goose postgres
perfect so we don't need to update the
create feed function we want the last
fetch that field to default to null so
no changes are necessary there but we do
need a new we do need a new query this
one's going to be called
yet next
oh my gosh get next feed to fetch can't
type today get another speed to fetch
and it will return a single row
and this one should say select star
from feeds
order by
last fetched at
descending nulls first
limit
one
okay so we always this the purpose of
this function is to go get the feed that
next needs to be fetched like we need to
go get posts for this feed next and the
whole idea is
first we want to go find any feeds that
have never been fetched before those
need to take priority after that if
every feed has been fetched then we want
to go find the one that was fetched the
longest ago like the farthest in the
past right so we're ordering by last
fetched at nulls first in descending
order
actually scratch that we're going to
want to do
ascending right ascending would put the
lowest the smallest time stamps right
the ones further in the past at the top
and then Ascend into the present okay so
order by last fetch that ascending nulls
first perfect
okay just to make sure that my SQL code
is valid we'll generate that looks good
okay next we need one more query this
one will be called
Mark feed fetched
Arc feed I guess as fetched
this is one we'll call after we fetch a
feed to say that we fetched it and we'll
return the updated feed
okay so it's going to be update
feeds
set
last fetched at equal to now
and update it at also equal to now so we
haven't really gone over this but the
updated and created that feels are
mostly for auditing purposes it's pretty
standard practice to set these fields on
basically every record in an SQL
database just so you can see when
they've been created and updated it's
kind of again auditing purposes
okay where
ID equals dollar sign one
and
returning star
okay so we update the feeds we set the
last fetch that and the updated at to
the current time
for the given ID that looks good to me
let's go ahead and generate that
perfect next we need a way to kind of
take an RSS URL or a feed URL and parse
it into an actual response body and in
this case we're going to represent it as
a struct let me show you what I mean so
let's create a new file I'm just going
to call it rss.go
and it's going to be part of the main
package
and we need a new function and we're
going to call it RSS to
or actually let's call it url
url to feed
okay
and it's going to take as input a URL
which is just a string
and it will return a new type so we need
to specify the new type type
RSS feed
it will return both an RSS feed and
potentially an error if there's
something wrong with the request that
it's making
now that RSS feed struct that we just
created is going to represent basically
this giant this giant document here
right so if you go to
wagslane.dev
index.xml which is a valid RSS feed then
you'll see this giant document and
really you can think of RSS as just a
structured data in XML format and XML is
just kind of like crappy Json so the way
we parse XML in go is very similar to
The Way We parse Json let me show you
what I mean I've done the Dirty Work of
scanning all of the valid values in that
big RSS document and I found that
basically these are the keys
um for the RSS entries in my blog so RSS
is kind of a standardized set of keys
within XML and basically what I'm saying
is these are the keys that we care about
right at the top level of an RSS feed we
expect a channel key right in the XML
document and we expect a channel to have
a title a link a description a language
and then a slice of items and then items
are kind of these nested objects that
each have their own title link
descriptions and publication dates right
and each item is a new blog post and if
you're asking how I came up with those
names of all of the different Keys it's
because I went and looked here in this
document I saw okay at the top level we
have a channel right and then we have
this entry with a title a link a
description right so I just kind of
manually looked through this document
and found all the stuff that I wanted to
parse out so let's fill in the rest of
this URL to feed function so first we're
going to need an HTTP client I'm just
creating a new client using the HTTP
Library um we'll set it to a timeout of
10 seconds if it takes more than 10
seconds to fetch an RSS feed we don't
want that feed anyway probably broken
okay uh then we can use that client to
make a get request to
the URL of the feed
and that's going to return an HTTP
response and potentially an error
if there's an error we'll just return
let's just do
um for cons for ease of use I'm going to
make this a pointer to an RSS feed so we
can just return nil and the error
cool
um if everything's okay then we're going
to defer a close
on let's close on the rest sorry it's
not it's not the close function it's
resp.body Dot close
okay and then after that we want to get
all of the data from the response body
so it's going to be io.read all we have
to read everything from
resp dot body and that comes back as a
slice of bytes and an error
okay this slice of bytes we want to read
into
this RSS feed so dealing with XML in go
is very similar to dealing with Json and
go it's actually going to be XML Dot
unmarshall pass in the data and a
pointer
to where we want to unmarshul today so
actually I need to create an empty
struct we need RSS feed
is an empty RSS feed struct
then we'll unmarshall into that location
in memory
that will return an error
if everything goes well then we can just
return the new populated RSS feed
perfect now as I type this out I'm
already kind of dissatisfied with this
pointer solution I don't think that
needs to be a pointer I think we should
just
return empty structs
either way would work I think this is a
little cleaner though because it means
the user of this function us right we'll
get an actual RSS feedback and not a
pointer to an RSS feed
okay let's go ahead and test this really
quick I'm just going to do a little kind
of hacky thing
just right at the top of main I'm going
to call URL to feed and give it the URL
of
um my blog so wagslane.dev
slash index dot XML
that should return a feed
and an error
right and then if error not equal nil
blog dot fatal
error otherwise I want to just print out
fmt Dot
print line let's just print out the
whole feed it'll be disgusting but at
least we'll get to see if it kind of
worked
okay let's build and run that
there we go
cool so if you kind of scroll through
this you'll see it looks like I mean
there was no errors and then it looks
like we properly
at least you know at first glance looks
like we properly filled out that struct
it's kind of just dumping all of the
data
so now that we've done a sanity test on
our URL to feed function let's go write
the actual scraper
create a new file just call this
scraper.go
again in the main package
okay
um the scraper is a long running job so
this scraper function is going to be
running in the background as our server
runs so we'll let's name it something
like start scraping
and let me split up these parameters so
we can really see so we can actually see
what uh
what we're dealing with here so it'll
take three inputs a connection to the
database
um a number of concurrency units I guess
the best way to think about this is how
many different go routines we want to do
the scraping on
and then how much time we want in
between each request to go scrape a new
RSS feed
cool and it shouldn't return anything
because this is going to be a
long-running job now because this worker
this scraper is going to be running in
the background of our server I think
it's really important that we have good
logging that kind of tells us what's
going on as it's happening so when we
start scraping I'm going to do a little
log message here so log dot printf
we'll say
scraping
on percent
the go routines
every
percent s duration
as in the concurrency and the time
between requests
cool after that we need to figure out
like how we're going
to make our requests on this interval
and there's a really cool
um mechanism in the standard library and
go called a ticker so we can create a
new ticker uh using the standard Library
so time dot new ticker and we give it a
duration in this case time between
requests
and it responds with a ticker
and then we can use a for Loop
to execute the body of the for Loop
every time a new value comes across the
e-ticker's channel so the ticker Has a
Field called C which is a channel where
every
kind of let's say that you know time
between requests was set to one minute
in that case every one minute a value
would be sent across the channel so by
using this syntax here we could say run
this for Loop every one minute and the
reason I'm passing in an empty
initialize and an empty middle section
to the for Loop is so that it executes
immediately the first time so the very
first time we get to line 17 the body of
the for Loop will request will will fire
immediately
and then it will wait for the for the
interval on the ticker if that makes
sense if we just did this
oops if we just did what is it for range
ticker.c uh then it would actually wait
for the minute up front but I want to do
it once immediately it'll make it easier
to debug and work with now at this point
I realize that I've made a mistake
the purpose of this concurrency
parameter here is to you know indicate
to the start scraping function how many
go routines we want to use to go fetch
all of these different feeds and the
whole point is that we can fetch them at
the same time so that means that each
time that this ticker fires we need to
be potentially go you know going it out
to the internet to fetch 10 20 30
different RSS feeds and download all of
their blog posts at the same time which
means we'll actually need to be able to
grab a a multiple number of feeds we'll
need to grab more than just one at a
time so rather than get next feed to
fetch let's change this to get next
feeds to fetch and we'll have it return
many and then rather than limiting to
one let's limit to dollar sign one so we
can actually pass in how many feeds we
want as a parameter to this function
okay then we should be able to
regenerate that
and we should oh we're not even using
the function yet so okay so that was
actually the perfect time to do that
okay let's fill out the body of this for
Loop so every Interval Timer tweet
request we want to go grab the next
batch of feeds to fetch so we can just
call that function that we just wrote
database dot get next feeds to fetch
it takes a context and a limit so the
first thing we'll just use context dot
background
so again I haven't gone into a ton of
detail on the context passage but
basically context dot background is like
the global context it's what you use if
you don't have access to a scoped
context like we do for our individual
HTTP requests
okay so that'll work for now and then we
also need to pass in a limit so we'll
just cast into 32 and the limit or the
sorry the concurrency
and that should return some feeds and an
error
if there's an error we should probably
print something
now notice I'm continuing here that's
because this function should always be
running as our server
operates like there's no time in which
we want this function to ever stop so if
I returned here that would be a problem
it would actually stop scraping
completely just because maybe I don't
know our database connection was down
temporarily so for now we're just going
to log and continue now that we have a
slice of feeds let's write some logic
that goes and fetches each feed
individually and importantly fetches
each individually at the same time so
we're going to need a synchronization
mechanism I'm going to use a weight
group so the standard library has this
awesome thing called a sync.weight group
and we can iterate over all of the fees
so four feed range feeds
okay so the way that the weight group
works is anytime you want to spawn a new
go routine within the context of the
weight group you do a weight group dot
add
and you add some number to it so here
I'm iterating over all of the feeds that
we want to fetch on individual go
routines and I'm going to add one to the
weight group
then at the end of the loop I can do a
weight group dot weight
and within the loop I can spawn a new go
routine so we're going to go do some
function in fact I guess I should just
name it kind of what we'll be doing uh
let's call it scrape feed go scrape
feed
and here we're actually going to pass
the weight group in as one of the
parameters
and within
scrape feed
takes a weight group which is a pointer
to a sink
weight group
within this function we'll defer a
weight group dot done
okay
so what happens here basically
we're iterating over the the all of the
feeds on the same go routine as the you
know the start scraping function so on
the main go routine
on the main go routine we're adding one
to the weight group for every feed right
so say we had a concurrency of 30 we
would be adding 30 to the weight group
now we'll be spawning all of these
separate go routines as we do that and
when we get to the end of the loop we're
going to be waiting on the weight group
for 30 30 distinct
calls to done so done effectively
decrements the counter by one right done
decrements the counter by one so we're
adding one every time we iterate over
the slice and then we're calling done
when we're done actually scraping the
feed so what this does is it allows us
to call scrape feed at the same time 30
times we go spawn 30 different go
routines to scrape 30 different RSS
feeds
and when they're all done
line 35 will kind of execute and will
move past that until they're like before
they're done we'll be blocking on line
35 which is what we want to do because
we don't want to continue on to the next
iteration of the loop until we are sure
that we've actually scraped all of the
feeds
so we've sort of stubbed out the scrape
feed function right now it doesn't do
anything other than call weight group
dot done let's actually go scrape some
feeds
so it's going to need access to a
database connection
and it's also going to need a specific
feed to go fetch so feed is a data base
dot feed
cool and then here we can pass in
database and speed
great the first thing scrape feed should
do and and keep in mind we're deferring
the weight group dot done so this will
always be called at the end of this
function
um the first thing we should do is Mark
that we've fetched this feed or that
we're fetching this feed so it's going
to be database.mark feed as fetched we
can just use the background context
again
and we need the ID of the feed so feed
Dot ID
cool that should return an error if
there was an error I think oh it also
Returns the updated feed I don't think
we care about the updated Feats I think
we can ignore that
say if error is not equal nil now keep
in mind we're not returning anything
from this function remember we're
calling it on a new go routine so
there's nothing to return here if
there's an error instead we'll just log
there was an issue
and return nothing and next we need to
actually do the heavy lifting which is
to go out and scrape the feet so we
already wrote Our URL to feed function
let's just use that
so URL to feed and we'll pass in the
feed dot URL and we should get back an
RSS feed and an error
and if error does not equal nil
error fetching feed
and we'll return there
otherwise we need to do some
logging so in the future what we'll do
is instead of iterating over all of the
items in the RSS struct that we get back
and just printing them to the console
we'll be saving them into the database
but for now just so that we can test our
scrape feed function we're just going to
log log all of this to the console so
we're going to log each individual post
or rather that we found a post and then
how many posts we found the last thing
we need to do is go hook up this start
scraping function to our main function
so that it actually starts okay so start
scraping takes database concurrency
actually I'll just open this up my
screen's too small to be working in two
tabs at the same time
okay
um we're going to need to call it before
listen and serve because remember this
is where our server kind of blocks and
waits forever for incoming requests so
we should probably call it I don't know
right
here seems like a good spot
so
um
it's just a function right yeah it's not
a method takes database concurrency and
time between requests okay
so we go go start scraping remember we
want to call it on a new go routine so
it doesn't interrupt this main flow
because remember start scraping is never
going to return it's a long running
function this is an infinite for Loop
okay
it needs a database connection so we'll
actually need to save this in
a new variable so that we can use it in
the API config and in the start scraping
function
next we need the concurrency
um
let's just start with 10. seems good and
then time between requests let's do time
dot minute
perfect
I went ahead and added a second RSS feed
so let's go ahead and check the database
and see what feeds we have currently
so I've got Lane's blog and the boot Dev
blog so there's two now remember when
you're setting a concurrency of 10 so we
should definitely be able to fetch both
of these blogs at the same time on the
first iteration of that Loop if we say
deployed this to production and allowed
users to start creating feeds maybe we'd
get up to 100 200 400 different feeds in
here then we'd only be fetching 10 at a
time right just so we understand how
that mechanism works but for now this
should be good enough to test I'm going
to update our logs just a bit so we can
see which blog
each post is from so found post
item.title
on feed
.name okay let's go ahead and run that
found Post Properties of pointers and go
on feed boot Dev blog perfect kind of
scroll up we should be able to see some
the boot Dev Blog has way more blog
posts than my personal blog here it is
here's some Lanes blog stuff okay so
that looks like it's working we should
be able to move on to the next step now
where we'll actually save these blog
posts into the database rather than just
logging the titles to the console we're
going to need a new table in our
database so let's start there
we'll call it posts
so the purpose of this table is to store
all of the posts that we are fetching
from all the different uh from all the
different RSS feeds
okay
um what am I doing this is this is
queries we need to start with a
migration
so let's grab this we'll make it zero
zero six
posts dot SQL
all right Goose up is going to be create
table posts
what goes in a posts table
um we are going to need an ID to create
that and update it that pretty much
never changes
um what else does a post have well it
has a title
right title
um is that text Dot null that makes
sense uh posts also typically have a
description
text I'm going to allow that one to be
nullable I think it's okay if a post is
missing its description
posts also typically have a published at
date published
at it's a time stamp
um should we allow that one to be
nullable
no no let's make that not null
what else does a post have it has a URL
a URL should be not null for sure
um I'm also going to say that it should
be unique
unique
I don't think we ever want to store the
same Post in the database twice
there's no point right if we have a post
I don't see why we would need it a
second time so let's let's go ahead and
make that one unique
and then lastly let's just put in a feed
ID
and the feed ID is going to be a uuid
that uh
we're going to want it to be a reference
of references
um feeds ID
right
and that's going to be
does that need to be unique
it doesn't need to be unique but it
should be not null we should always have
the feed ID of a post and let's here put
on delete Cascade if we delete a feed
we'll Cascade and delete all of its
posts and I forgot to put the type here
so URL text not null unique okay that
looks good to me let's go ahead and run
our migration so it's going to be we
need a CD into
SQL schema and run goose postgres
we'll need this connection string
up
perfect
next we'll need a couple of queries to
interact with this table the first one
is going to be just a way to create a
post so posts and we'll do
create
oops
free post
return one thing
and we'll just kind of be inserting a
bunch of stuff I think let's take a look
at the post table so we've got ID
created at updated let me just grab this
so I don't forget it
okay
so insert into posts
ID created at updated at
we also have we have a lot of stuff so
I'm actually going to start spacing this
out a little bit
create it at updated at it's going to be
a title
and
the description
publish that
URL
and a feed ID
okay and the values one two three four
how many do we got
just eight
five
six
seven
eight
returning star
straightforward right insert into posts
all of these fields
no fancy logic that should be good okay
let's run sqlc generate
add that function to our internal
package and then we just need to go use
it so down in the scraper now instead of
just logging all of these posts to the
console let's save them to the database
I'm going to leave this log message it
says feed blank collected blank posts
found so that'll just log all of the
different feeds we're collecting but
each individual post I think it's
wasteful and kind of busy to log
everything so we're not going to do that
instead we'll just call DB dot create
post
context.background
and what does it take create postparams
database dot create post params okay
cool I kind of like how sqlc
breaks down the parameters into
um
into a struct makes it pretty simple to
work with
okay
um we've got an ID created updated that
okay ID is just going to be a new ID
created that updated that that'll just
be time.now
dot UTC
what's next title description idle
item.title
I just realized oh I just realized now
that I'm not putting the field names
kind of embarrassing
okay title description
do they not have a description what does
an item have
let's take a look at an item
items have title link description yeah
it does have a description what am I
messing up here
can I use item.escription variable of
type string as sql.null string ah right
okay
so we need to do sql.null string
a null string has the string itself and
whether or not it's valid so we just put
in the string
and then we say it is valid string dot
valid is Boolean true
although actually this is a problem
right this is a problem because if
item.description is blank if it's an
empty string we're going to be putting
in an empty string and saying that it's
there even though it's not so let's not
do this
let's do something a little different
let's go
description
it's a new sql.null string
why is why is that giving me trouble
oh because I'm doing it within the call
to create post do it right here
okay so we'll create a new sql.null
string and then we'll say
if item dot description does not equal
the empty string
then we get to set description dot
string equal to item.description
and description dot valid
equals true
and then we'll use the description here
does that make sense so if if the item's
description is blank then we'll set the
value to null in the database
effectively
otherwise we'll create the valid
description entity
okay next we need a published at
let's see we've got an item dot Pub date
which is a string okay so we're going to
need to parse that string to parse that
date there is a Time dot parse function
in the standard library and we're going
to use this RFC one one two three Z
layout so this is the layout that I'm
using on the boot Dev blog and on my
blog to be more robust and support all
of the different publishing formats for
all the different blogs that we want to
scrape we'd probably need to make this
logic a little bit more robust but for
now
I'm just going to say we're parsing it
this way if it's not that way I guess we
take a hike okay
if there's an error so if error does not
equal nil
we can say log dot print line
couldn't parse date
sent V with error
sent V
and we'll pass in the actual Pub date
and an error and that's going to be a
printf
oops
cool and then if that's an issue we'll
just continue so if we don't get a valid
time uh then we'll just we'll just log
it log in move on
okay so published at pass in that I
shouldn't use single name variables like
this let's do
up at
okay
what else do we got a URL and a feed ID
so URL
is just going to be the item.link
and feed ID
do we have access to the feed ID here
we do we have the feed right because we
passed in the feed here
e dot ID
now db.createpost does return an error
so we need to handle that error
what am I screwing up here
oh it also Returns the post itself
I don't think we care about the new post
though I think all we care about is if
it failed so if error
equal nil
ton create post with error
okay let's give that a shot okay build
and run
now remember we're expecting this time
to get logs that just say that the blogs
were collected so 21 posts from Lane's
blog 321 posts from the boot Dev blog
were collected I'm going to go ahead and
kill the server and let's check PG admin
so now if we select star from Posts
you should see a bunch of stuff in here
IDs created at titles descriptions
published at dates
awesome this is looking fantastic
we scroll down to see how many rows
there are 342. that looks right to me
now I think we have an issue here let me
show you what I mean if we run this
again so remember we've scraped both of
the feeds and pulled in all of the posts
so if I rerun my server at this point
yeah we're getting all of these issues
failed to create posts duplicate key
value violates unique constraint posts
URL key right now this makes sense we
didn't want to store duplicate posts in
our database so we have a unique
constraint on the post URL which means
when we go try to recreate the posts it
fails because we already have the posts
in our database
so let's do a little string uh string
detection so that we don't log this crap
every time this happens because this
isn't really an error this is expected
Behavior so we can do something like if
strings dot contains
air dot error
uh duplicate duplicate
e
then do we continue what are we doing
here
then we continue
otherwise we'll log the air so we're
only going to log the error if it's not
a duplicate key error okay so let's run
that again and make sure we don't get
those errors
perfect
we have one last feature to add to our
RSS aggregator we need a way for users
to be able to get a list of all of the
newest posts from the feeds that they're
following so we'll need a new query
we can call this one
get posts for user and it will return
many posts
now let's think about this query for a
second it's a little more complex than
the other queries we've done in that I
think we need to do a join so we have
our posts table
right posts have IDs created ad updated
at but importantly they have a feed ID
so we know what feed every Post in the
database belongs to and we also have a
feed follows table that tells us which
feeds an individual or user is following
so if we join those two tables together
right if we take all of the feed follow
information kind of join it to the posts
table then we should be able to filter
by all of the feeds that a user is
actually following so what does that
look like
you do select
hosts.star so everything from the post
table
ROM posts
join
feed follows
on
oops on post dot feed ID
equals feed follows dot feed ID
okay so this adds essentially all the
feed follow information to our like the
virtual table for this query right we're
joining those two tables together so now
we should be able to filter
um the way we want Okay so we've we've
joined them together where
posts dot wait post no where feed
follows dot user ID
equals
dollar sign one
okay so we join the tables and then we
filter all the posts down or rather the
entire table down by the specific user
ID so all of the posts that belong to
feeds that the user is not following
should at this step get trimmed out
then we can order by let's do Post dot
published at descending so give us the
newest stuff first
and we'll limit by a configurable amount
so dollar sign two
cool
let's go ahead and try to generate that
looks like it worked let's see if uh see
if when we run the actual application it
does what we expect let's hook that
query up to a new endpoint so I'm here
in the users file that seems like a
reasonable place we'll do Handler
get posts for a user
it will be an authenticated endpoint so
we'll need that that user data but here
we're going to call DB dot or sorry API
config
dot DB dot get
hosts for user and then we can pass in
the
request.context and user dot ID
oh we also need I think a limit
oh get no no sorry we take we take
database dot get post for user params
right because we have multiple
parameters here so we'll need the user's
ID and a limit the user dot ID and for
now let's just say a limit of 10. and
that will return to us some posts and
potentially an error
if we get an error
we'll respond with it
couldn't get posts
otherwise we need to return the post
themselves now we should go create
a special posts model right so that we
get our
our own tag so type post struct
go mostly copy this from
our internal
host model
wherever it ended up here it is
okay
add some Json tags
goodness typing is hard
now here's an interesting thing
this sql.null string is not something
that we're going to want to use in this
struct because this is a struct that
Marshals to Json the null string object
is a nested struct so if we marshaled it
directly to Json we would actually get
description as a Json key and then
string as a Json key and then valid as a
Json case would be a little nested
object there that's pretty bad user
experience because Json natively
supports kind of null in the sense that
you can just omit the key or use like
the actual value null so what we're
going to do is instead do a pointer to a
string
and the way Json marshalling and go
works is if you have a pointer to a
string and it is nil then it will
Marshal to what you'd expect in Json
land which is that null value
okay then published at
URL
and feed ID
okay did I miss anything let me look
over this really quick
that's looking good
and next we need the conversion so we'll
do
database post to post
now this one gets a little hairy right
we probably need to do some logic here
so we'll say
bar
description pointer to a string
and then if DB post dot description dot
valid
then we'll set description equal to
the address of dbpost.description.string
cool then we can just directly use the
description variable there
all right published at
what else we got URL and feed ID
okay and last but not least we need a
way to do it uh do the conversion for an
entire slice
bunk DB
database posts to posts
and the logic will look
pretty much identical to that but I
actually think it'll be easier to type
it out so we'll do uh
posts slice post
database post post
s in the database post
okay
there we go
a lot of conversion logic there
but now we should be good to just
respond with some Json
and we can pass in
those posts as database posts
cool what am I getting here
struck literally uses unkeyed Fields oh
yeah let's not do that
we want an ID
and I think it's a limit
right what am I messing up user ID
perfect
okay let's build and run the server
again
oh I realize I made a mistake I need to
actually hook this up to something so
let's go back into main.go
we need a new endpoint
we'll do get
I don't know user feed
now feeds probably a loaded term in this
uh in this application we should say
let's just do posts
and it's going to require middleware so
middleware off
and API CFG Dot
Handler get posts for user okay so get
slash posts it's an authenticated
endpoint Perfect all right let's rebuild
and run that
okay
opening up thunderclient
first we need to check
well actually let's just grab some auth
information so
um
this clearly has some off
let's grab that API key create a new
request
HTTP colon localhost
V1 posts
headers close that
authorization
API key okay
so
if I make that request I'm getting back
no posts now we know we have posts in
the database but my my user that I'm
currently logged in as is not following
anything
all right I'm getting back the empty
array when I
when I check my feed follows
um but I can check which feeds Exist by
running this API request
so let's grab this feed let's grab the
Wags Lane feed and let's go follow that
one
so we'll post to feed follows here
this feed ID
okay so now I should be following let's
check my feed follows
great I'm following them so now if I go
get my posts
there we go
I should just be getting posts
from the wagslane.dead block
perfect let's try following
let's try following um
the other one
so
where is it feed follows no feeds
let's try following the boot Dev blog as
well
so post
feed follows
send that check my feed follows now I'm
following both
now if I go get my posts
perfect we're seeing stuff from the boot
Dev blog
that's it
thank you for sticking with me through
all of this mess we've created an
amazing blog aggregator that will
actually work pretty darn well at scale
you could run this thing uh you know
over a long period of time collect
millions of blog posts and it would do
pretty well I hope you had a ton of fun
with this project I do want to remind
you that this is a server right we've
kind of been running it stopping it
restarting it but at the end of the day
you can just turn it on ADD new feeds
and follows and interact with it
directly and it will once a minute go
out and collect all of those blog posts
so you could just keep this running on a
Raspberry Pi in your house to aggregate
you know blog posts podcasts all that
kind of stuff
um I will point out that we have done a
bit of happy path programming so happy
path programming is when you're not
necessarily handling every Edge case out
there you're you're handling kind of you
know the thing that you expect to happen
most of the time so for example um we
only had one type of date parsing for
the published at dates in our RSS feeds
but maybe there are RSS feeds out there
that use a different date format and
will fail to parse them
um so one way that you could extend this
project would be to just add a ton of
new RSS feeds and make sure that you
deal with the issues as they come up
make sure you improve the logging so you
can see the issues when they come up
anyways I hope you had a ton of fun with
this project and that you learned
something
I just want to remind you that we do
have an entire back-end learning path
over on boot.dev in go lay so if you
liked this project if you liked this
course and are looking for some more
content definitely go check out boot.dev
we also published a lot of different
ways that you could potentially extend
this project to make it cooler for
example maybe you add a front end or a
command line application that interacts
directly with the API so that you don't
need to use a manual client like
thunderclient every time that you want
to interact with your posts and then I
also just want to remind you before I go
that you can find me on Twitter at
wagslane or on YouTube at boot.dev
definitely go subscribe to our YouTube
channel as well thank you again to free
codecamp for allowing us to publish this
course and this project walkthrough I
hope you enjoyed it and I'll see you in
the next one